THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING AND AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS TO
MANAGE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
RECESS AND IT CONTINUES TO WORK
ON THE PUBLIC UNITS PROVIDE
ACCESS IN BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES PATIENT FOR CO
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
BE THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON A
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS BEING DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE. HEARINGS INTO TEN
TWENTY ONE- STREET BUILDING- AND
ALL MEMBERS ARE PRESENT. AT
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR A
RUN REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE.
USE YOUR MICROPHONE AND USE YOUR
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE WHEN
YOU'RE WANT TO SPEAK. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED SOME. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED. IT'S ESTABLISH
OUR QUOTE MARC WARREN MISTER-
GUESS IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. EGGMAN I'VE BEEN HERE
MELENDEZ ONE IS HERE HERE AND
HERE. EIGHT PLEASE NOTE THAT A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
DURING THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL PRESENT
AN OVERVIEW OF THE HEALTH
RELATED ITEMS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S ME PROVISIONS IN THE
BUDGET. WILL BE DISCUSSING ALL
THE ITEMS LISTED IN THE OVERVIEW
SECTION OF THE AGENDA TOGETHER
TODAY. BUT FIRST WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND
AGAIN THESE ARE ITEMS THAT WE'VE
HEARD EARLIER- BUT TODAY WE'RE
DOING A VOTE ONLY ON THEM AND DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE VOTE ON
THE CALENDAR. SO MOVED. A NOTICE
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS LISTED IN
THE CALENDAR AND WE'LL VOTE ON
THOSE ITEMS. IN THREE GROUPS.
OKAY FIRST WEIRD DO GROUP ONE-
WHICH ARE ISSUES ONE THROUGH
FOUR SIX THROUGH SEVEN NINE
THROUGH. FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE THROUGH
TWENTY TO TWENTY FOUR THROUGH
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE THREE
THIRTY THREE. 352-405-4072 FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE SIXTY ONE
THROUGH. SIXTY THREE SIXTY FIVE
TO SIXTY SEVENTY ONE AGAIN TO
SAY THAT AGAIN SIXTY FIVE TO
SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY THREE
THROUGH SEVENTY SIX AN ISSUE
SEVENTY EIGHT THROUGH NINETY
SEVEN IS THERE A MOTION SO
MOVED. ALL RIGHT- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN AYE MULLIN DOES WONDERS I
VAN **** AND HIGH. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO GROUP NUMBER
TWO ON THIS WILL BE VOTE WILL BE
VOTING ON ISSUE SIXTEEN.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR AND SEVENTY TWO. IS THERE A
MOTION MOVED. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HI EGGMAN AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO FAN ALL
RIGHT AND I. OKAY AND NOW WILL
MOVE ON TO GROUP NUMBER THREE
AND THAT IS ISSUES FIVE. EIGHT
FORTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT SIXTY AND
SEVENTY SEVEN IS THERE A MOTION
SO MOVED THAT HE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL EGGMAN. HI
EGGMAN AYE MELENDEZ. THEM HI AND
I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
IS OUT ON A TWO TWO ZERO.
SENATORS EGGMAN AND PAN VOTING I
SENATOR MELENDEZ X. X.
ABSTAINED. OKAY AND NOW. AND
THAT AND THAT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE OF BOTH OF THOSE AS ALL
MADAM MEMBERS WERE PRESENT. OKAY
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS STAFF
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BUDGET EXCHANGE HAVE RESPONDED
TO HAVE FINANCE PRESENT THEIR
THEIR ITEM FIRST TWO THEY CAN
ATTEND THEIR BOARD MEETING. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLEASE
PROCEED. EACH YEAR JOSEPH
JOHNSON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF SENDING ON COVERED
CALIFORNIA'S ITEM. AND DUE TO
THE UNCERTAINTY OF FEDERAL
SUBSIDY FUNDING STANDING BEYOND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
ADMINISTRATION ACROSS THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION TO
REINSTITUTE CAL THREE INSTITUTO
FOR HIS PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM.
FOR BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THIS WOULD BE
FUNDED THROUGH THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY MR FONG. WITHOUT
GOING IS FUNDED THROUGH THE
GENERAL FUND NOW THE PROPOSED
PROGRAM CONTINUES. TO PROVIDE
PREMIUM SUPPORT TO LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS JUST SAYS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE KNOW THAT THIS LEVEL
SUPPORT IS MORE GENEROUS THAN
WHAT IS ESTABLISHED BY FEDERAL
ACA LEVELS. AND IN ADDITION THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM WOULD CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES FOR
MIDDLE INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO
DO NOT QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIES
UNDER THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF ARCA-
COMPARED TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PROGRAM. THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM PROVIDES
INCREASED SUPPORT TO MIDDLE
INCOME INDIVIDUALS BY REDUCING
THE CONTRIBUTION CAP FROM 18% TO
SIXTEEN PERCENT. OF ENROLLEES
INCOME WHO ARE BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND 6100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL- FINANCE NOTES.
SUSAN GOT A FUNDING EXPIRE AT
THE END TWENTY TWO. IN A STATE
SUBSIDY PROGRAM IS NOT
REINSTATED INDIVIDUALS ABOVE
FOUR HUNDRED FPL WILL LOSE
PREMIUM SUPPORT ENTIRELY BASED
ON THE CURRENT AC LEVELS OF
SUPPORT. WE NOTE THAT THE
ORIGINAL STATES OF THE PROGRAM
WAS DESIGNED WITH THE INTENTION
OF SYSTEM- THE MIDDLE CLASS. NOT
ONLY DOES THIS PROPOSAL BUILD
UPON THAT ORIGINAL DESIGN WITH
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IT ALSO AIMS
TO ADDRESS THE POTENTIAL
EXPIRATION OF FEDERAL SUBSIDY
FUNDING. LASTLY THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PROPOSES
STATUTORY CHANGES TO ALIGN WITH
PROPOSED STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM.
BUT THAT'LL POTS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- L. A-
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
MOREOVER THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE WOULD WE
ARE STILL REVIEWING THE PROPOSAL
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- WE DO
THINK THERE IS A STRONG POLICY
BASIS IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-DOES NOT EXTEND. THE ENHANCED
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES TO PROVIDE-
STATE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES TO
ENSURE THAT. HOW CALIFORNIA
REMAINS AFFORDABLE AND DATA
MINIMIZE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
REDUCED- HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE AS A RESULT OF
INDIVIDUALS. CANCELING THE
HEALTH INSURANCE IF THEY FACE
HIGHER PREMIUMS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH THIS IS
A BEEN AN ISSUE THAT I'VE BEEN
TRACKING CAREFULLY AND SO I'M
GLAD THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
RESPONDED IN A- WE HOPE IT WILL
BE AN APPROPRIATE. MANNER AFTER
THE L. A- REALLY DIGS DOWN INTO
IT BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
WILL REALLY HURT PEOPLE AND THE
POCKETBOOKS OF THE IF THE- IF
THE FEDS CUT OFF THIS IS SO.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND SO I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT IT'S INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN. DR PAN.
I THANK YOU AND FIRST OF ALL I
DO APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL FROM
THE- ADMINISTRATION OF THE MAY
REVISE- TO RESTORE THE-
ESSENTIALLY A PREVIOUS SUBSIDY
PROGRAM WE HAD BEFORE THE-
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT. BUT I
GUESS THE QUESTION I WOULD POSE
AND I DON'T KNOW THEIR- PERHAPS
COVER CALIFORNIA MIGHT BE THE
ONE MOST APPROPRIATELY TO ANSWER
THIS SO MY CONCERN IS THAT. AT
LEAST FROM MY UNDERSTANDING-
THE- THIS COMPONENT THE IN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLANS AT THE
SUBSIDIES FOR. ESSENTIALLY
COVERED CALIFORNIA THE LARGER X.
YA OVER OVERALL THROUGH THE ARE
BUT THAT THAT DOES ACTUALLY
FAIRLY AS YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME
FAIRLY BROAD SUPPORT FOR THAT-
NOW IT WAS PUT LUMP BILLS PUT IN
THIS PART BILL BACK BETTER PLAN
SO AND THAT YOU KNOW HAS HAD
PROBLEMS AND THAT'S WHY THERE
HASN'T BEEN ACTION TAKEN- SO.
THERE IS POLITICAL UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN. AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR BECAUSE ARE
BOTH COURTS WOULD END AT THE END
OF. DECEMBER SO THERE IS
UNCERTAINTY. THE ISSUE I GUESS
SAID RAISES THAT IN THIS PERHAPS
AGAIN THIS QUESTION FOR COERED
CALIFORNIA IS THAT. NOW YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING THE RATES WITH THE
PLANS OVER THE SUMMER. CORRECT.
AND I AS YOU REVEL EVERY
CALIFORNIA YES WE ARE YES SO I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS THAT WHY
APPRECIATE THIS PROPOSAL IS THAT
. GIVEN THE UNCERTAINTY AND
BASICALLY THE PLANS LOOKING AS A
OKAY THERE'S A POSSIBILITY ARE
BUT GOES AWAY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T TAKE ANY ACTION. THERE
WHILE THERE WILL BE SOME
SUBSIDIES IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE DEFINITELY BE A DROP THEY'LL
STILL BE A BIT OF A CLIFF FOR
OUR- YOU KNOW FOR THE PEOPLE
WERE FOUR HUNDRED PROBABLY A
LAUGH THE L. LESS OF A CLIFF
THAN THEY WOULD HAD BEEN WITHOUT
THIS ACTION. BUT SO FAR AND THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY PUT UPWARD
PRESSURE ON PREMIUMS AND EVEN IF
CONGRESS TO SAY THE ACT LET'S
SEE AS IN THE LAME DUCK SESSION
AND EXTEND THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
A FAIRLY. THIS IS A FAIRLY
POPULAR PROVISION. WE WOULD
STILL BE STUCK WITH INCREASED
RATES BECAUSE THE RATES WERE A
NEGOTIATED IN THE FALL AND IT
FACT. THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RATE INCREASES OF COURSE WILL BE
COMING OUT WHEN WE'RE DOING OPEN
ENROLLMENT RIGHT BEFORE. LET'S
JUST SAY- WHAT HAPPENED IN
NOVEMBER- MAYBE LATE OCTOBER
NOVEMBER- NOT SURE WHY THAT
PARTICULAR TIME THE YEAR MIGHT
BE REALLY IMPORTANT BUT
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT- SO.
MMHM SO ZIGGY'S TO WHAT YOU
THINK MAY HAPPEN AGAIN I KNOW
YOU HAVEN'T NEGOTIATE BUT YOU
KNOW- I GUESS THE MOST WAS LIKE.
IF THE STATE STEPPED UP AND
PROVIDED. NOT LEAST ONE MORE
YEAR- SOME INCREASE SUBSIDY- FOR
AT LEAST THE NEXT YEAR SO I'VE
BEGIN PREHEAT THE NEXT RACES
PROPOSAL FOR THE FOR DOING THE
ON GOING YOU KNOW PREVIOUS OF
THE PROGRAM AND ONGOING SO AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. BUT I
GUESS I WOULD OPEN THE IDEA
SAYING THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD DO A
LITTLE MORE FOR THE COMING YEAR.
YOU KNOW BUT AGAIN IN THE HOPES
THAT CONGRESS WILL STEP UP AND
THEN OUR VOTERS BUT ALSO TO
ANOTHER TO PUT DOWNWARD PRESSURE
ON PREMIUMS WHILE COVERED
CALIFORNIA NEGOTIATED PREMIUMS
OF THE SUMMER TO MAKE THAT
COMMITMENT IN CASE OUR BUT
DOESN'T GO. SO IS THAT A IS THAT
A VALID. CONCERN I MEAN WHEN
COVERED CALIFORNIA'S NEGOTIATING
WITH THIS PLANTS ESTABLISHED A
RATES FOR NEXT OPEN ENROLLMENT-
WHAT DO YOU THINK'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. AND THIS IS A VERY VALID
CONCERN WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS CONTINGENCY AS BEST AS WE
CAN. I'M NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE'VE BEEN IN THIS POSITION WE
ARE IN THIS POSITION IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. BUT WE HAVE
ASKED OUR CARRIERS TO PREPARE
THEIR RATES ASSUMING THAT
CURRENT LAW- THAT COMES TO PASS
SO A. R. P. AB PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
EXPIRE. SO THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN ASKED TO SUBMIT TO US IS
THEIR INITIAL RATES. WE'VE ALSO
ASKED THEM TO SHARE WITH US
AFFECTED BY WHICH RATES MIGHT
DROP IF A. R. P. SUBSIDIES ARE
CONTINUED SO. AS WE'RE IN THE
COURSE OF THE SUMMER AND AS WE
WORK WITH OUR REGULATOR PARTNERS
AND WE HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
HAVE DIFFERENT SETS OF RATES AND
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER THEM TO
CONSUMERS BASED ON. THE ACTION
THAT THE CONGRESS TAKES BUT I
THINK YOU FLAG THE REALLY
IMPORTANT- INFLECTION POINT IN
THE TIME LINE WHICH IS IF WE GET
INTO OCTOBER. WHEN WE START OUR
RENEWAL PROCESSES WHEN WE
STARTED TELL CONSUMERS WHETHER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE RATES ARE
GOING TO BE. AND AT THAT POINT
WE ARE MUCH MORE LOCKED IN A
LESS ABLE TO PAY THAT AND THEN
TO YOUR POINT WE MAY HAVE LOCKED
IN ARTIFICIALLY HIGH RATES IF
THEY'RE P. SUBSIDIES ARE THEN
EXTENDED IN THE LAME DUCK
SESSION SO. THAT THAT IS NOT A
GOOD CASE SCENARIO BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO IN THAT
SCENARIO OKAY SO I APPRECIATE
THAT SO I GUESS I WOULD SUGGEST
CONSIDERATION AND AGAIN PRECIADO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED I
WOULD SUGGEST CONSIDERATION OF
PERHAPS A- ONE TIME ONE YEAR.
YOU KNOW CROSS OUR FINGERS ON A.
R. P. COMMITMENT FOR SUBSIDIES
FOR ANOTHER YEAR- TO TRY TO PUT
THAT DOWNWARD PRESSURE ON THE
RATES. SIR WHAT WOULD BE A
YOU'RE- OLD. THE PREVIOUS OF.
AND HOW THAT CAN WILL DO RIGHT
THING TURNS OUT AND J. WE CAN DO
A BUDGET LETTER WHAT TURNS OUT
WE DON'T REALLY NEED TO USE THAT
MONEY BUT THAT BUT THEN WHICH IS
WE DON'T LOCK IN THE HIGHER
RATES BECAUSE EVEN IF CONGRESS
ACTS. IN THE LAME DUCK SESSION
WE WERE LOCKED IN THE HIGHER
RATES. SO I JUST WANT YOU KNOW
I'M I THINK ABOUT. OUR
COMMITMENT TO PUT IN SOME
ADDITIONAL MONEY WE MAY ACTUALLY
GET YOU KNOW THE SAID THAT EVERY
DOLLAR COMMITMENT WE ACTUALLY
MAY GET A BIGGER BANG FOR A
BUCK. GOING BACK YOU KNOW IN
RETURN. BECAUSE OF THE DOWNWARD
PRESSURE WE COULD PLAY ON RATES
DURING NEGOTIATION OVER THE
SUMMER. SO SO HOPING I WANT TO.
PUT THAT IDEA OUT THERE. AS WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT OUR OUR
BUDGET AND I BELIEVE IN THIS.
REGIONAL CENTER PROPOSAL WE DID
IT AT SUGGEST PUTTING PERHAPS A
LITTLE MORE- THAN WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED IN THE REVISED. SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DR PAN WE WILL.
CERTAINLY MISS YOUR EXPERTISE-
OKAY NOW WITH A MOVE ON- TO THE
OVERVIEW OF THE MATE REVISION
ITEMS PROPOSED FOR MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PACKAGE IN
THE INVESTMENTS IN THE CARE
COURT PROPOSAL. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE YOU READY TO PROCEED
. YES I JUST BOUGHT JOHNSON
JOHNSON AGAIN FROM FROM FINANCE
ALL BEGIN WITH A BRIEF
INTRODUCTION THAT ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PROPOSAL THAT INCLUDES BOTH AGE
CUNNINGHAM AND CDPH NO HEAD OR
TO MY COLLEAGUES TO SPEAK WITH
MORE DETAIL. SO THE ME REVISION
INCLUDES- GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES GLORIA FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION SUPPORT SAFE AND
ACCESSIBLE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. I'M SPECIFIC TO EACH
CLIENT- THERE IS A SURPRISE
REQUESTING A ONE TIME FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND COST TO
ESTABLISH AN UNCOMPENSATED CARE
FUND TO ASSIST WITH COSTS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. REQUESTED FUNDING
WOULD ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM
TO SUPPORT ABORTION CARE AND
CONTRACEPTION SERVICES FOR THOSE
WITHOUT SUCH HEALTH COVERAGE
THROUGH FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
PROVIDERS OF THESE CRITICAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES. I
MEAN ADDITION- H. CHRIS
REQUESTING PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
SUPPORT AND EDUCATION OF THIS
PROGRAM AT THIS TIME ALL HEADED
OFF TO MY COLLEAGUE NICK MILLS
DISCUSSED. THE CDPH PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU ONE MORNING. THE
MORNING NUMBER SIX OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF. THE MAYOR OF THIS
INCLUDE A TOTAL SEVENTY MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO SUPPORT SAFE AND
ACCESSIBLE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. OF THIS AMOUNT FIFTEEN
MILLION AS REQUESTED TO AWARD
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH RIGHTS AND
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT
MEDICALLY ACCURATE AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT AT REACHED
AS A QUE SON. ON SEXUAL HEALTH
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ISSUES.
ONE MILLION IS REQUESTED TO
DEVELOP AND SUPPORT OF
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS WEBSITES. AND ONE MILLION
IS REQUESTED FOR RESEARCH ON
UNMET REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
NEEDS- WE AND OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- BELIAU MR WELCOME.
THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN KOREA'S
DATA WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE'RE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING- THAT
THE TOTALITY OF THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH PACKAGE BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME INITIAL COMMENTS TO REYES
JUST ON THE PROPOSAL FOR
UNCOMPENSATED CARE FUND FOR
ABORTION SERVICES- WHILE THE
CONCEPT OF THIS PROPOSAL HAS HAS
MERIT- THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH
TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION. HOW
IT ESTIMATED FORTY MILLION TO BE
THE PROPER AMOUNT FOR THIS THIS
PROPOSAL- AND RELATEDLY WHETHER
IT CAN PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION
ON HOW MUCH IS CURRENTLY SPEND
ON UNCOMPENSATED CARE FOR
ABORTION SERVICES. STATEWIDE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR JOHNSON- MISTER MILLS CAN YOU
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. HOW DO WE
COME UP WITH FORTY MILLION HOW
MUCH DO WE SPEND. NOW. I JUST
DON'T SEND IN FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- ACTUAL- HANDS OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM EACH CAR TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAIL. I'M SORRY
THANK YOU HI CAN RISE OUT- WITH
H. HI I'M- THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND- WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF- INVESTIGATING MATH
TO DETERMINE- M. BUT WE ARE
RESEARCHING THAT DATA RIGHT NOW
. SO WE'RE RESEARCHING HOW MUCH
HOW MUCH THE COST CURRENTLY IS
BUT DO WE KNOW HOW TO HOW DID WE
COME UP WITH THAT FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR. PRICE TAG. I'M SORRY I'M
- DATA IS HARD TO COME BY AND SO
WHAT WE'VE- ESTIMATED- IN TERMS
OF THE COST- THAT WE HAVE- SEEN
FOR EXAMPLE THAT- PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HEALTH CENTERS ROAD
OFF ALMOST NINE MILLION IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO COVER COSTS
OF PROVIDING CARE TO PATIENTS-
OUT WHO COULD NOT AFFORD IT SO-
IN TERMS OF THAT THE FUNDING
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS- THIS WAS
ONE ONE BASELINE PIECE OF DATA.
THREE FIGURE OF NINE MILLION WAS
ONE YEAR THAN FORTY MILLION OR
TAKE OVERS. OVER SEVERAL YEARS.
OKAY OKAY WELL WE WILL CERTAINLY
BE INTERESTED IN THE- SEE MORE
THE DATA AFTER YOU ANALYZED IT-
PREPARE. YOU FOLKS SO JUST JUST
TO CLARIFY THE FUNDING FOR
ENCOMPASS THE RIVER ITSELF
DESCRIBED THIS IT'S THE GRANTS
TO HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND- SO
IN TERMS OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE GRANTS THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
IS- BECAUSE THAT'S SO. IT IS A
TIED TO SERVING A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF PEOPLE OR IS IT SIMPLY SAYING
OKAY YOU TAKE THIS GRANT YOU
HAVE TO PROVIDE ABORTION
SERVICES ARE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES TO. ANYONE WHO WHO WHO
WHO. WHO NEEDS IT HE SHOWS SHOWS
UP I MEAN I GUESS WHAT THE
PARAMETERS OF THE PARTICULARS OF
THE GRANT FOR THE FINDINGS I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A GRANT IT'S
NOT A REIMBURSEMENT CORRECT.
CORRECT CORRECT IT'S A GRANT TO-
YOU KNOW WE INTEND TO- TO GRANT
THIS TO A MANAGING AGENCY WHO
HAS EXPERIENCE- WORKING WITH-
YOU KNOW TITLE TEN- AND SERVING
THOSE THAT ARE- THAT ARE-
PROVIDE BEING PROVIDED THIS CARE
TODAY. OKAY ALL RIGHT AND I
WOULD MAKE NOTE BECAUSE- THAT
THE FORTY MILLION ACTUALLY IF
IT'S OVER SIX YEARS SO THAT'S
ROUGHLY IT'S LIKE WHAT FIVE AND
A HALF MILLION PER YEAR. I GET
THAT TO THE MATH RATE. SOMEWHERE
YES IT ACTUALLY AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN- YOU KNOW AWARD MORE- IN THE
IN THERE SOONER IN THE SOONER
YEARS EARLIER YEARS OKAY ALL
RIGHT- YEAH I MEAN I THINK WHAT
WE'RE FACING IS A POTENTIALLY
YOU KNOW POTENTIAL SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT
MORE UNCOMPENSATED CARE
POTENTIALLY SHOWING UP IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK COULD BE
BETTER YOU'LL BE GOOD TO HAVE A
BETTER ANALYSIS- WHAT WHETHER
THIS IS THE RIGHT NUMBER IT
SEEMS TO BE PERHAPS LOWER ON THE
LOW SIDE FOR SIX YEARS- JUST
JUST. GIVEN THE INFORMATION
GIVEN US SO FAR IN THIS HEARING-
THE OTHER I GUESS THE OTHER
ISSUE ISN'T THAT ISN'T STRICTLY
BUDGETARY BUT I THINK IT'S
RELATED TO THE PURPOSE OF THIS
PROPOSAL. IS THAT ALSO. THERE
RESOURCES BEING PROVIDED TO FOR.
I WOULD CALL IT YOU KNOW PRIVACY
OR DATA SECURITY. SO THE
CHALLENGES IS THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE SEEKING THE SERVICES THESE
ARE SENSITIVE SERVICES WELL
CERTAINLY THERE ARE LAWS IN
PLACE FOR HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
RIGHT HIP- WE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY LAW. THOSE LAWS DON'T
APPLY TO NON HEALTHCARE ENTITIES
SO LIKE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
OTHER DATA BROKERS AND SO FORTH.
AND THAT THAT INFORMATION COULD
BE USED TO- BY. OTHERS PERHAPS
EVEN OTHER STATES- TO- TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM. SEEKING
CARE- SO- ARE WE LOOKING INTO
OUR INVESTING ANYTHING INTO
PROVIDING EITHER EDUCATION OR-
TOOLS FOR PEOPLE WHO SEEK
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. WHO MAY BE
AT RISK BECAUSE OF PRIVACY
ISSUES. I'M SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IS- IN OUR PREVIOUS
PROPOSAL- THAT WAS THE- FOR A
FORTY MILLION TWENTY MILLION
FOR. INCREASING ACCESS FOR
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT BY THE
TWENTY MILLION AND SO WE SEE
THAT THAT IS WHERE WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT WE COULD FOCUS ON
SOME OF THOSE AREAS TO PROVIDE
THAT SUPPORT TWO. PROVIDERS FOR
THIS IS THAT SEPARATE PROPOSAL-
FROM THIS ONE OKAY ALL RIGHT AND
THAT YEAH IT'S WELL IT'S NOT
JUST RIGHTS ACTUALLY PATIENTS
WHO NEED THAT HELP- BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE ONES WILL BE AT RISK.
CERTAINLY PROVIDERS MAY BE AT
RISK TO- BUT ALSO PATIENTS MAY
BE AT RISK AS WELL. BUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MS RESULT OKAY. LET'S MOVE ON.
YOUR COURT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BURST
MEANS WE ARE ALMOST LEAD TO
PERMANENT FINANCE I WILL SPEAK
TO THE MEMBER VERSION PROPOSALS
FOR CARE COURT THE MERRY MISSION
INCLUDES INVESTMENTS IN MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL- COURT
THE CITY PROPOSAL WAS DISCUSSED
ON TUESDAY HEARING AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S PROPOSAL WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER THIS WEEK.
ADDITIONALLY THE PURPLE OR
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
THE DH CS TO IMPLEMENT CARE CORD
TO PROVIDE COUNTY TRAINING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AS CARE
CURRENT MOVES TO THE POLICY
PROCESS AND WILL WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE EXTENT THESE
AS MUCH CHANGE. WITH THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
VERY MUCH OF SHE- THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN COREY SHE DALY UP-
WE HAVE SOME INITIAL COMMENTS
REYES ON THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION CARE COURT PROPOSALS
WHICH CUT ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE ACS-
AS THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
ALLUDED TO- IN ADDITION TO BE
ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION- WITH ONE
MILLION ON GOING PROPOSED REACH
THE ASK THE GOVERNOR ALSO
PROPOSES ROUGHLY FORTY MILLION
WITH ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
ON GOING TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
FOR COURT PROCEEDINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH YOUR COURT- AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. TO ADMINISTER THE CARE
COURTS SUPPORTER PROGRAM- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT- THE
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE FOR CARE
COURT IS CURRENTLY AND SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT-
SINCE THE SPILL IS YOU'LL STILL
GOING THROUGH THE POLICY
PROCESS- THERE IS SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT THE FINAL
LANGUAGE WILL BE SENSE- SOME
CHANGES TO THE IMPLEMENTING OF
LANGUAGE ARE POSSIBLE- IN
ADDITION YOU KNOW THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING NEEDED FOR-
BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO INSURE CARE COURT
OPERATES EFFECTIVELY- DEPEND ON
YOU KNOW WHAT THE FINAL
LEGISLATION WILL BE- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS STATED THAT
IT'S STILL WORKING WITH COUNTIES
TO IDENTIFY. POTENTIAL LOCAL
COSTS- WE ALSO FIND THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF KEY
CONSIDERATIONS THAT- WHEN WORKED
OUT THROUGH THE POLICY PROCESS
COULD ALSO IMPACT COSTS OF THESE
INCLUDE HEALTHCARE COURT IS
SUPPOSED TO INTERACT WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICARE
HOW- OR- HOW INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE COMMITTED AN OFFENCE SUCH
AS SOMEONE DOWN TO B. I. S. T.
ON A MISDEMEANOR CHARGE WILL
INTERACT WITH THE CARE COURT
PROCESS- YEAH WITHOUT FULLY
IDENTIFIED STATE AND LOCAL
COSTS- WE FIND THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
WEIGH THIS PROPOSAL AGAINST
OTHER GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES-
AND- THESE REASONS- WE THINK
IT'S PREMATURE TO CONSIDER THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S ME REVISION
PROPOSALS- IN. IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS AT. THIS TIME- THE
THEY'RE ALL OUR COMMENTS ON ON
THE CARE SHE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS A LOT MORE
THE STILL WISH TO WORKING
THROUGH ON THAT- WOODS I WOULD I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- WELL WHY
WON'T TAKE IN AS MUCH INTO THE-
JUDICIAL BRANCH. I I'VE I
BELIEVE THAT TEN MILLION IS TOO
LOW. AFTER THE SUPPORTER PROGRAM
FOR THAT INITIAL. IMPORT BUT- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO- TO WORK ON
THIS AND SEE MORE LIKE MANY
THINGS SPECIFIC HONOR YEAH I'M A
GIVEN THE L. A. S COMMENTS AND-
YOU KNOW IF. WE'RE STILL WORKING
ON THE LEGISLATION I GUESS FROM
FINANCE- BECAUSE I DON'T SEE IN
THE- THE MAY REVISED PROPOSAL
AND THIS CAME UP IN THE-
TESTIMONY REGARDING THE
LEGISLATION WHICH WE HEARD AND
OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE WHICH I
CHAIR- IS THERE A COMMITMENT.
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ACTUAL PROVIDE FUNDING TO
COUNTIES AND COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR THEIR- FOR THE THINGS
THAT THEY'LL BE REQUIRED TO DO-
FOR CARE COURT IS THAT IS IT SO
IT'S NOT IN THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL AS EARLY AS AT FAULT
STILL MAYBE STILL UNCERTAIN BUT
LEASES YOUR COMMITMENT TO-
PERMITTED TO COVER THAT. YOU
KNOW THE COST OF THOSE SERVICES
BY COUNTIES- IT WHAT CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT THE STATE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH COUNTIES ARE IN
REGARDS TO- BE SURE THAT
COUNTIES YEAH COUNTY APRIL
HEALTH AND- OTHER AGENCIES THAT-
THERE CAN BE AN ACT OF CARE
COURT THAT- THAT THOSE ARE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED. CERTAINLY WE
HAVE RECEIVED. FROM THE COUNTY
SONORA WITH REGARDS TO- SOME
ESTIMATES OF WHAT THOSE COUNTY
COST MAY BE. HOWEVER WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE POLICY IS
STILL. IN THE WORKS SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTIES UNTIL WE HAVE A- MORE
SUCCINCT ESTIMATE. OKAY BUT
THERE'S A COMMITMENT I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE STILL TALKING
SO WE DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT
IT IS AND HOW MUCH YOU MIGHT GET
DIVVIED BUT THERE'S A COMMITMENT
FOR ON THE STATE PROVIDE LEAST-
SOME SUPPORT FOR. COUNTY RELATED
EXPENSES INCREASED COUNTY
WORKLOAD OR EXPENSES RELATED TO
CARE COURT. THEY'RE CERTAINLY
DISCUSSIONS ARE BEING HAS
SURROUNDING THE SPECIFIC COUNTY
COSTS. OKAY I HEAR DISCUSSIONS
AND YOUR COMMITMENT. SO WE'RE
WE'RE DEFINITELY LOOKING INTO
THESE I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHETHER
WE HAVE NECESSARILY AGREEMENTS
ON ALL THE COSTS AT THIS TIME
BUT WAS CERTAINLY GOING TO
CONTINUE THOSE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH OUR. I
GET THAT THERE'S VERY ARE IT IS
IN ANY AGREEMENT YET AND I'M
JUST AND I KNOW THERE'S A STILL
A MOVING TARGET SO I APPRECIATE
THAT SO I GUESS I'LL JUST LEAVE
IT AT I HOPE THAT IF WE'RE GONNA
BE SIX- AND COUNTY BEHAVIORAL.
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY AND
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE AN INCREASED
WORKLOAD THAT THAT DOES NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR GRANT. OKAY THEN WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY. THE MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE HON OTHER PROVIDING
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. AGENCY MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS THE FIRST ITEM I WILL
BE GOING OVER IF YOU'VE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH ADDRESSING URGENT NEEDS
AND EMERGING ISSUES IN
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR HEALTH.
DISTRUST AND SOCIAL ISOLATION
CAUSED BY COOPER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS IDENTIFIED ALREADY
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
AMONG CHILDREN AND YOUTH
PARTICULARLY FOR YOUTH OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES LGBTQ
AND OTHER VULNERABLE GROUPS.
EQUALLY CONCERNING IS INCREASE
IN USE SUICIDE RATES OVER THE
LAST DECADE MENTAL HEALTH IS NOW
THE LEADING CAUSE OF
HOSPITALIZATION FOR CHILDREN
UNDER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE AND
HEALTH. MAYBE PROPOSES TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME INVESTMENT
DISTRIBUTED OVER THREE YEARS TO
IMPLEMENT A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH TO ADDRESS- URGENT NEED
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND
ESTABLISH A CENTER FOR RESEARCH
. EVALUATING AND APPLYING AN
INNOVATIVE. KNOWLEDGE TO IMPROVE
YOU KNOW HEALTH OTHERS AN URGENT
AND IMMEDIATE NEED TO CONTINUE
INVEST IN EFFORTS TO ADDRESS.
BEHAVIOR HOW WITH A FOCUS ON
IMMEDIATE THAT INITIATIVE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THERE IS
AN UPDATE THE FINANCE LETTER
SUBMITTED TO REQUEST AN EXTENDER
EXPENDITURE PERIOD FOR FUNDS
THAT ARE IN DEFEAT THAT HAVE
BEEN POSTED. MOVING ONTO THE
NEXT ISSUE DATA EXCHANGE
GOVERNMENTS TO FACILITATE HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE. CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IS
REQUESTING THIRTY THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
BOTH TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR EIGHT
POINT EIGHT MILLION ON GOING TO
FUND EIGHTEEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS AS WELL AS FIFTY
MILLION IN GRANTS OVER TWO YEARS
OF THE FORTY THE HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE. THE
FIFTEEN GRANT PROGRAMS PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SMALLER
UNDER RESOURCE PROVIDERS.
PARTICULARLY SMALL PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES. ROLE HOSPITALS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS
WELL AS EDUCATION AND TECHNICAL
FIFTEENTH REMEDIES NEW TO HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE. THE NEXT
ITEM HAVE IS HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL COMMISSION FOLLOW UP
WORK THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. TO
ALLOW HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
PROGRESS TOWARDS UNIFIED
FINANCING AS IDENTIFIED IN THE
FINAL REPORT OF THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION THIS WILL
PROVIDE LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
STRATEGY FOR ENGAGEMENT WITH
FEDERAL PARTNERS. ON THE
NECESSARY FEDERAL APPROVALS TO
PROCEED WITH UNIFIED FINANCING
AND IDENTIFY THE NEXT STEPS
NEEDED. THERE'S ALSO A TECHNICAL
REQUEST TO APPROPRIATE ONE PLANE
WE APPROPRIATE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
POLICY COUNCIL. OTHER NEIGHBOR
VISION ALSO INCLUDES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH THE
OFFICE OF RESILIENCE IN RESPONSE
THEY'LL COORDINATE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND NATURAL DISASTER
. FUNCTIONS WHICH ARE CURRENTLY
SPREAD ACROSS ALL DEPARTMENTS
AND FIVE OFFICES THIS ONE HAND
OVER SITUATIONAL. IN OUR
DEPARTMENT CORDINATION AND
RESPONSE AND MANAGEMENT OF THESE
CRITICAL PROGRAMS THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSED WAS A PLUS APRIL IN THE
TRAILER BILL IS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THE LEGISLATURE
THAT AFTER YEARS A REPORT BE
PROVIDED ON THE THAT THIS OF
THE- AND WHETHER IT. OFF
THROUGHOUT AMERICAN FEED
MANAGEMENT AND. THANK YOU BYE
OVER. SEVENTY SIX BUT MCCARTY
I'LL BE HAPPY KANSEN QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH L. A. O. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR EGGMAN THIS IS
SONYA WTH THE LAW ANALYST- THE
LATTER GROUP WE ARE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
DETAILS- SOME OF WHICH WERE JUST
RECENTLY POSTED SO WE- WE DON'T
HAVE ANY COMMENTS TODAY ON THOSE
BUT WILL WORK WITH THE- WITH US
. STAFF AS AS WE REVIEW THOSE I
WILL PASS IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CORY HAS TO HOWEVER
FOR COMMENTS ON THE FIRST
PROPOSALS REGARDING YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SHIDA.
THANK YOU. SENATOR EGGMAN HIS
SHEET WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE JUST HAVE
AN OVER ARCHING COMMENT ABOUT
THE FUNDING BEING PROPOSED FOR
VARIOUS- ADDITIONAL CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE GRANT PROGRAMS- WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER HOW EXISTING FUNDING
WITHIN THE- CHILDREN AND YOU CAN
AND SHOULD HAVE COULD BE
LEVERAGED TO ACHIEVE SOME OF THE
GOALS OF THIS NEW FUNDING- MUCH
OF THE EXISTING FUNDING WITHIN
THE INITIATIVE HAS NOT BEEN
DISTRIBUTED YET- AND WITHIN THE
EXISTING INITIATIVE THERE ARE-
SEVERAL GRANT PROGRAMS FOCUSED.
ON TOPICS THAT YOU KNOW SEEM TO
AT LEAST IN PART OVERLAP WITH-
SOME OF THE PRIORITIES THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- FOR EXAMPLE THERE ARE
GRANT PROGRAMS- THAT ARE IN THE
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THE
CURRENT INITIATIVES THAT. ARE
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING SORT OF
SERVICES AND SCHOOLS AND
DEVELOPING OUT WORKFORCE- IF
THOUGH GIVEN THESE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WISHES TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THESE NEW
INVESTMENTS. WE WOULD SUGGEST
DISTRIBUTING'S NEWLY PROPOSED
GRANT DOLLARS THROUGH THE
STRUCTURE OF THE EXISTING
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE PROGRAMS. OF TO HELP
INSURE MORE STREAMLINED
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTATION
AND- MORE SPEEDY DISTRIBUTION OF
FUNDS UP THAT THOSE ARE ALL THE
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH. CAN YOU CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THAT THE RESTAURANT IS IT.
ARE WE ARE THIS IS NEW MONEY
THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT ARE
THESE. NEW PER. OR WE CONTINUE
TO. TO FILL OUT ALL THE ALL THE
OTHER PROGRAMS ALL THE NEW
PROGRAMS THAT WE WISH WE START
SETTING UP LAST YEAR AND THE
YEAR BEFORE. THE FOR ADDITIVE.
THESE ARE ADDED TO THE C. Y. B.
H. I. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO- DEFER
TO MY AGENCY. COUNTERPARTS
THANKS TO FROM THE AGENCY ONE
SPEAK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BRENDAN MCCARTHY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY WE AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WE CVS'S ADDITIVE TO
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE I'M
IS YOU KNOW THE CHILDREN HE
HEALTH BUT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE IS REALLY ABOUT
BUILDING A- STRUCTURE FOR
PROVIDING A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES ALL CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
THAT TAKES A LOT OF TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE WAS VERY GENEROUS
WITH INVESTMENT MADE LAST YEAR.
BUT IT WILL TAKE US TIME TO
BUILD UP THE SYSTEM IN THE
SCHOOLS WITH THE PLATFORM- AND
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS POLICY IS RESPOND TO THE
ISSUES WE HAVE SEEN THE DATA
WE'VE SEEN ABOUT USE SUICIDE
RISK. INCREASES IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS. ACT WE'VE
RECEIVED FROM STAKEHOLDERS- YOU
KNOW TELLING US THAT THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVES ARE CRITICAL BUT IT
WILL TAKE TIME FOR THEM TO WRAP
UP. AND THEIR IMMEDIATE NEEDS
AND SO WHAT WE TRIED TO DO HERE
IS ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS.
THAT WE ARE SEEING. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FINANCE- SAID.
WHILE ALSO- BUT- TACKLING SOME
NEW ISSUES THAT ARE KIND OF
EMERGING THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
FEEDBACK FROM STAKEHOLDERS FOR
EXAMPLE. LEVERAGING EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES IT'S SOMETHING
WHERE WE WANT TO LOOK AT AND
RESEARCH WHAT TECHNOLOGIES ARE
ON THE HORIZON THAT WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO BUILD INTO THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH. THEY HAVE A HEALTH
ISSUE OVER TIME NOT IMMEDIATELY
BUT AS THEY EMERGE HOW CAN WE
BUILD THEM INTO THAT PROCESS-
AND THEN THE PROPOSAL FOR
SUPPORT FOR CULTURALLY DIVERSE.
FUTURE WORK FORCE. BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE PROGRAMS FOR NOW THAT
REALLY REACH DOWN INTO THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL TO ENCOURAGE.
PEOPLE TO GO INTO THE SESSIONS
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO ADD ON AS A KIND OF
WELCOME MORE LONGER TERM
INVESTMENTS SO THAT THERE WILL
BE. A MORE DIVERSE WORKFORCE
THERE I TO MEET OUR NEEDS
THROUGH THE CHILDREN. HAVE FOR.
INSTANCE MY OF THE CRISIS
RESPONSE THE WELLNESS IN MIND
FOR. THESE ARE ALL TO BE GREAT
FUNDED AND IN SO HOW HOW HOW
SOON WOULD WE EXPECT THAT MONEY
TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT AND I'M
THINKING THOSE ARE GOING TO
NONPROFITS THEY'RE GOING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE WHERE ARE
THOSE GRANTS GOING. YES YOUR
YOUR CORRECT MADAM CHAIR SO ON
HE USED TO ASIDE- PILOT PROGRAMS
THOSE ARE MOST LIKELY GO TO
COUNTIES WHO THEN COULD PARTNER
WITH SCHOOLS AND- COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT MONEY
FOR A WELLNESS AND RESILIENCE-
FOR CHILDREN YOUTH AND PARENTS
THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT WOULD BE
DONE THROUGH THE SCHOOLS WE MAY
ALSO WORK WITH CBO'S BUT THE
IDEA IS REALLY TO KIND OF THE
SCHOOL FOCUSED. PROGRAM THAT
WERE IN CONCERT WITH- RESOURCES
THAT WERE PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET
IS THROUGH THE SCHOOL SYSTEM-
AND SO FAR HOPE THERE IS TO GET
THAT MONEY OUT THE DOOR A FAIRLY
QUICKLY- AS AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK THROUGH THE CHILDREN USED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUE OF
MAKING CONNECTIONS WITH THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY AND CBO'S
SO WE THINK WE'VE LAID SOME
GROUNDWORK BUT- WE HOPE THAT.
BECAUSE OF BACKGROUND WORK WE
CAN GET THESE GRANT FUNDS OUT
THE DOOR RELATIVELY QUICK TO
ADDRESS THESE PROJECTS AND THEN
THE VIDEO SERIES THAT WERE IN
DEVELOP FOR PARENTS OF THE
CONTRACT FOR THAT OR HER SECOND
THAT WORK. THE MOST LIKELY WE
WOULD CONTRACT OUT SO THERE IS
MONEY IN THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
- THAT WAS PROVIDED- TO
ANSWERING FOR HIS NATION THAT
HAS DEVELOPED SOME VIDEOS ON
PRIMARILY AIMED AT EDUCATORS. TO
HELP THEM BE AWARE OF IN HOUSE
RESOURCES FOR WHEN THEY SEE
STUDENTS IN CRISIS SO WE'VE
WE'RE THINKING SOMETHING ALONG
THOSE LINES WE WITH CONTRA WITH
AN OUTSIDE ENTITY THAT IS IN
DEVELOPING CONTENT. TO THEN
EXPAND WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE REALLY TO START
TARGETING- PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS AND CHILDREN TO
REFUSE DIRECTLY- TO KIND OF
BUILD A POPUP BASKETS WITH. OKAY
AND OF COURSE SOMEONE WHEN
PARENTS IDENTIFY A PER. WE JUST
. REALLY NEED TO WORK ON MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S SOME THERE TO
REFER THEM TO KEEP ABSOLUTELY
SEEMS ABOUT PARENTS NOT BEING
ABLE TO FIND THERAPISTS- OR HELP
FOR KIDS- WE SEND ON THE CAREER
DEVELOPMENT DO YOU KNOW- WHICH I
HIGHLY SUPPORT ENCOURAGING. THE
KIDS TO GET THE MENTAL HEALTH
THE CAREER TRACK ARE WE GOING TO
WORK WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF APPRENTICESHIPS TO ADDIS.
INTERESTING THE CONVERSE WITH
AGAINST ABOUT WORKING WITH THE-
PHARMACY DEPARTMENT OF
APPRENTICES PROGRAMS AND BEING
ABLE TO GET KIDS BOTH PAID AND
COLLEGE CREDITS. WHILE THEY'RE
IN HIGH SCHOOL WORKING THROUGH
THE EASIEST APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS TO DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
GOING TO BE IN COORDINATION WITH
THAT. THIS IS A GOOD QUESTION
SENATOR I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT THIS FUNDING WILL GO TO
EACH TIME THAT WE CAN GET BACK
TO YOU ON HOW EACH GUY. IN
PRACTICE. OKAY AB AND I BROUGHT
THAT UP WITH THEM AS WELL OKAY
THANK YOU DR GRANT. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE DESCRIPTION ON
THE YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROPOSALS OF COURSE RANGERS DID
AND CONTINUE TO. SEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LARGER.
INITIATIVES YOU SAID- AND-
VERTICAL REALLY IS- YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE THINGS FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE THE PLATFORM- AND WHERE ARE
WE WITH THAT AND HOW. THE FACT
HOW SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS A
LINK TO THE PLATFORM OF THE
PLATFORMS EVENTUALLY BROUGHT UP
AND WHAT'S- THE CURRENT TIMELINE
ON THE PLATFORMS I KNOW WE- HAD
A CHANCE TO TALK A LITTLE ABOUT
THAT EARLIER. AND THAT'S OKAY
BUT I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE AN
ON GOING. YOU KNOW- AREA OF
INTEREST- I DID HAVE A- QUICKLY
. ON HEALTHY CAL FOR ALL
COMMISSION FOLLOW UP SINCE I SIT
ON THE COMMISSION- AND WE ALWAYS
COMPLETED- AT LEAST OUR INITIAL
REPORT. FEES MAYBE SPECIFY LOW
MORE ABOUT WHAT THIS FUNDING IS
ACTUALLY GONNA BE SPENT ON WE
HAD A SO I KNOW PART REPORT
WHERE HE HAD A LEAP ANALYSIS OF-
THE OF THE TERMS OF. FEB THE
FEEL FEDERAL LAW AND SO- CAN YOU
SPEAK TO. WHAT W'RE SPENDING
THE ONE POINT FOUR MILLION AND
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND. ON
SINCE THE COMMISSION HAS IS
ALREADY GOING TO BE ISSUING A
REPORT SOON. SURE I'M HAPPY
RESPONSE CENTER SO YES AS YOU
SAY THE REPORT SHOULD BE OUT
SOON IT'S JUST IN ITS FINAL
PUBLIC. COMMENT RIGHT. THE
INTENTION HERE IS TO FOLLOW UP
ON THE WORK THAT THE COMMISSION
DID PARTICULARLY TO DIRECTLY
ENGAGE WITH FEDERAL PARKER SPOKE
AT THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES R. AS WELL AS
FEDERAL HHS. TO TALK ABOUT PASS
FOR UNIFIED FINANCING SO YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE WAS A LEGAL ANALYSIS
BUT WE THINK THERE'S NOW IT'S
TIME TO START WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
FILL WORKS THROUGH WHAT CAN BE
DONE THROUGH WAIT FOR EXAMPLE
WAIVERS FROM CMS. AS OPPOSED
WHAT THE STATUTE CHANGES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL- AND SO WE WANT TO
START THAT ENGAGEMENT AND
SERVANT THIS FUNDING WOULD BE
FOR SOME LIMITED TERM STAFFING
AGENCY TO DO THAT AS WELL AS
SOME. CONTRACT FUNDING. TO
PROVIDE OUTSIDE EXPERTISE- IN
NETWORK AS WE ENGAGE WITH. OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELL TO THE LEGAL NOW.
I THOUGHT WAS PRETTY THOROUGH.
AND THAT'S WHY I WAS WANTING
WHAT YOU KNOW WAY- AND SAID WE
RECORD THAT'S RIGHT AN
ACCOMPLISHED SO OKAY. ALL RIGHT
WHAT'S THE- JUST WONDERING AS
FAR AS WHAT WE CAN DO ON TOP OF
THAT NEED LEGAL ANALYSIS THAT
WAS ALREADY DONE. ALL RIGHT-
OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S THEN MOVE ON TO.
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY. MORNING
MEMORIES DAN ABOUT THOSE LITTLE
IT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL
SPEAK TO THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSAL FOR CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
WE ARE ALSO JOINED BY DIRECTOR
FRANK MORE WHO WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. AND THEIR VISION
PROPOSES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
EXTEND THE TIME LIMITATION FOR
THE THIRTIES WORKING CAPITAL
FINANCING TO PROVIDE HEALTH
FACILITIES MORE FLEXIBILITY AND
INCREASED UTILIZATION OF THE
AUTHORITIES WORKING CAPITAL
LOANS BETTER ENABLING THEM TO
RESPOND BASED ON NEEDS SUCH AS
DURING THE COLD NINETEEN.
WITHOUT WE'RE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- LA- THANK
YOU SENATOR EGGMAN KOREAN SHEET
WITH THE L. L. WHERE WE'RE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING-
JEFF AS PER PROPOSAL AND- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY INITIAL COMMENTS
TO RACE AT THIS TIME WILL FOLLOW
UP IF WE IF WE FIND ANYTHING
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP AS
VASQUEZ JUST. HOW DO WE COME UP
WITH THE TWO YEARS WORTH OF
INTEREST AND THEN WHAT CHANGING
OF WORK CAPITAL FROM FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. YEAH SO FOR
THE- THE STANDING THAT THE
REPAYMENT TERM. THAT WAS
INITIALLY BASED BASED OFF OF THE
COWBRIDGE- AND BELIEVE IT'S AN
ON DISTRICT HOSPITAL LOAN
PROGRAM- THAT WE IMPLEMENTED
DURING. THE BUDGET OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ON THE REPAYMENT
TERM FOR THAT HAD TO BE ADJUSTED
TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS TO BETTER.
ASSIST IN REPAYMENT- I ALSO
DEFERRED TO- FRANK MOORE WHO IS
ALSO ON THE LINE. THANK YOU YES
FRANK MOORE HERE WITH THE
CHAPLAIN- AS DIANA SAID- BUT WE
MET WITH A NUMBER OF HEALTH
FACILITIES DURING THE BEGINNING
OF THE CODE- NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AND THE NUMBER ONE REQUESTED A
PROGRAM THAT THEY ARE ASKED
ABOUT THIS WAR ADJUSTMENTS TO
WORK WORK CURRENT PROGRAMS LIST
. WORKING CAPITAL LOANS- BUT THE
FIFTY MONTH RESTRICTION CARLINA
ACT WAS PROBLEMATIC TO THEM- AND
SO LOOKING AT AS DAN MENTIONED
THE- THE PUBLIC HOSPITAL LONG
PROGRAM THAT WAS PUT INTO THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR. THAT ALLOWED-
PUBLICADOS TO REPAY THEIR
WORKING CAPITAL LOANS OVER TWO
YEARS AND WE ARE JUST ASKING FOR
THE SAME. THING TO BE ALLOWED
FOR ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS ON A
PERMANENT. BASIS TWO YEARS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOCAL DOCTOR
. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S ON TO MS. GOOD MORNING
MEMBER AND ALL THE TIME WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL BE
PRESENTING ON ONE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL FOR THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY AND
I'M JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE
HOUSEHOLDS RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MIGT COME UP.
QUESTRADE THEIR GENERAL FUND
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY BY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. THE REQUESTED
LEVEL OF REIMBURSEMENT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING PROPOSED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BUDGET. FOR MEDICAL SEARCH
NOTHING FOR KOBE NINETEEN.
AFFECTED APRIL ONE FACILITIES
ARE REQUIRED TO REIMBURSE THE
STATE FOR MEDICAL STAFF THAT ARE
DEPLOYED TO HELP FACILITIES
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN SEARCH.
THAT'S THE REQUESTED FUNDING
WILL ALLOW AND SUCH A WEAK
REIMBURSEMENTS. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LMAO. THIS IS AN EMPHATIC
WITH THE L. A- WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS- LARGELY
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR GRANT
HELP. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON TO- DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION. SURE MANY MENTAL OF
ONCE AGAIN DON'T SIMPLE BY.
INNOVATION THE ITEMS. EACH ON
THE FIRST ITEM WE ALREADY-
BRIEFED ON LATER TO REPEAT.
HEALTH CARE BUT OF THAT BREED.
CARE CLASS ONE TIME FORTY
GENERAL FUND TO ESTABLISH
UNCOMPENSATED CARE FUND TO
ASSIST WITH COST REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE NET
ITEM IS RELATED TO THE HEALTH
AND HOME CARE CON. PROPOSAL A
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ON EACH CAR
REQUEST A REDUCTION OF FIFTY
MILLION OVER THREE YEARS FROM
AGE KAISE INITIATIVES INCLUDED
AND CARE CONTRA COSTA LACK
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS
REDUCTION IS OFFSET BY A NAY
REVISION PROPOSAL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO EXPAND
NONTRADITIONAL. PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL PARTNERSHIP
ACTIVITIES. IN ADDITION H. KYRA
ALSO REQUESTED SHIP TWENTY SIX
MILLION OPIOID SETTLEMENTS FUND
RESOURCES TO DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. IN AMOUNT
OF TWENTY MILLION AND THEN TO
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION FOR
AN AMOUNT OF FOUR MILLION. A
LASTLY EACH CHI PROPOSES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO SUPPORT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CARE
CALLING FOR POSTAL INCLUDED. IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE THIRD
ITEM HELP- PRESENT ON HIS A
SMALL ROLE IMPROVEMENT FOR NEXT
IN. EACH BECAUSE I REQUEST
INCREASE ON DOING FEDERAL
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND TO SUPPORT THE SHIP
PROGRAM THE INCREASE WILL ALLOW
EACH KAIJU WERE ALL AVAILABLE
FEDERAL FUNDS TO SMALL RURAL
HOSPITALS TO SUPPORT
INSTITUTIONS TO IMPROVE THEIR
QUALITY. IN REMAIN SUSTAINABLE.
FINANCE KNOWS THAT THIS
INCREASES IN ADDITION TO THE
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND INCREASE
REQUESTED AT WITH THE APRIL ONE
FINANCE WATER BRINGING THE TOTAL
FOR THE TWO REQUESTS OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
OF THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND.
LASTLY THE PRESENT ON THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
H. CAI REQUEST STATUTORY CHANGES
TO BE ADOPTED TO FIND ROLE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
INCLUDED IN THE CARE CUTTING
PROPOSAL. IN ADDITION THE
REQUESTED STATUTORY CHANGES
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE EACH CHI TO
STAFF WAS STATEWIDE REQUIREMENTS
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS ON. WELCOME TO OUR
WILLING TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE BILLS HAVE REPRESENTS
OR H. CRACKERS WHILE. THANK YOU
. HELLO THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN
COREY SHE TO WITH THE L. A.
WE'RE STILL ON THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING- THE BULK OF H. GUYS-
VISION PROPOSALS AND WE DON'T
HAVE ANY INITIAL COMMENTS TO
RAISE AT THIS TIME BEYOND WHAT
WE ALREADY NOTED ON TE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ITEMS WITHIN
EACH HIGH- BUT WE WILL FOLLOW
UP- IF WE FIND ANYTHING FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I HAVE DOCTOR. I GUESTS- AT MAKE
NOTE THAT- THIS TRAILER BILL.
PULLED ON COMEY HEALTH WORKERS
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WHAT SUPPORT-
COMMITTEE HELL WORKERS. I GUESS.
HOPEFULLY IS WE'RE LOOKING AT
TRAINING CERTIFICATION THAT WE
DON'T CREATE EXCESSIVE BARRIERS
FOR PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
WHILE THE COMMITTEE HEALTH
WORKERS SO I KNOW THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT ATTENTION THERE- IN
TERMS OF. YOU KNOW WANTING TO
OUR PROFESSIONAL IT'S NOT THE
RIGHT WORD BUT YOU KNOW
ESSENTIALLY. AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
STANDARDS FOR COMMITTEE HEALTH
WORKERS WE DONATE THEM SO
ONEROUS THAT IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY ARE OF THE
COMMUNITY AND HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE COMMUNITY TO BECOME TO ME
HEALTH WORKERS. SO SO ALTHOUGH
KEEP THAT MINES WERE DEVELOPING
THESE STANDARDS- FOR COULD BE
HEALTH WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY- IT'S OVER UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS EACH OF A LADY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCE- I
WILL SPEAK TO THE MAYOR VISION
UP I WILL SPEAK TO THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSALS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE
DIANE OF. LUNA WE'RE ALSO JOINED
BY MEDICAID DIRECTOR TO SEEK WHO
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ON THESE PROPOSALS- FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE THEN THE REVISION
PROPOSES A TOTAL OF. ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT AMOUNT
OF ONE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
GOES TO FUND STATE OPERATIONS
WHILE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
SUPPORTS LOCAL ASSISTANCE. IN
TOTAL THE MAYOR VISION REFLECTS
NET COSTS RELATED TO THE CODE
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
OF TWELVE POINT FOUR BILLION
TOTAL FUNDS THE CURRENT YEAR.
AND THAT COST OF ELEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION TOTAL FUNDS IN
BUDGET YEAR. THE BUDGET REFLECTS
THE FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THROUGH JULY FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUT GIVEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID NOT ISSUE
THE SIXTY DAY NOTICE- THAT IT
WILL END ON THAT DATE THE FINAL
BUDGET WILL HAVE TO BE ADJUSTED
TO REFLECT THE ADDITIONAL
EXTENSION. ADDITIONALLY THE
MAYOR VISION PROPOSES FUNDING IN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO MAKE
PERMANENT FOR POLICIES
IMPLEMENTED DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO PROPOSES AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL FUNDS FOR THE
EQUITY IN PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION PAYMENTS PROGRAM
FOR A TOTAL OF SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION IN TOTAL FUNDS OVER FIVE
YEARS. THESE PAYMENTS WILL FOCUS
ON ADVANCING EQUITY ADDRESSING
CODE NINETEEN DRIVEN HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND IMPROVING
QUALITY MEASURES INITIAL
PREVENTATIVE MATERNITY IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE ALONG
WITH INFRASTRUCTURE UPDATES. TO
SUPPORT VALUE BASED PAYMENT
MODELS. THE MAYOR VISION ALSO.
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
FOR HELP AND ALL NAVIGATOR PROD
GROUP THIS YEAR TWO TWENTY
TWENTY- VICE BUDGET PROPOSAL
TAKING. THE PAID FOR TO SERVICE
THANK. THE AVERAGE COST FOR
LABOR FROM FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS TO ONE THOUSAND
AND NINETY FOUR DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF IT
WILL BE SHIFTED FROM JULY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. TO JANUARY. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE MAYOR VISION
ALSO FOR QUITE REFLECTS IN
BECAUSE- IN PROPOSES BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW DCS TO
IMPLEMENT OR REVISE
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY FOR
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS.
AFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IT ALSO PROPOSES
BUNCH OF THE LANGUAGE YOU USE
MONETARY SANCTIONS FOR WORK. TO
QUALIFYING NONPROFIT LEGAL AID
PROGRAMS AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SERVE MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
ENROLLEES. IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND OTHER IMPACTED COUNTIES. THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES
CONSTANT PROPOSES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CONFORM WITH FEDERAL
LAW. THE COVERAGE AND
REIMBURSEMENT OF ROUTINE PATIENT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PARTICIPATION IN QUALIFYING
CLINICAL TRIALS. THERE VICE
MEASURE PROPOSES TO UPDATE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO CODIFY THE
EVENING NINETY SEVEN EXEMPTION
PER SEVEN RECENT BENEFITS. THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PROPOSES TO
UPDATE THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR THE MEDICAL DIRECT CONTRACT
WITH PRIVATE KAISER PERMANENTE.
WITH THAT- ALL TRANSITION OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE DIANA VASQUEZ
MINUTE TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF. THE REMAINING PROPOSITIONS.
THE YOU MISTER OF. LET'S HEARING
MEMBERS STANISLAUS WE KNOW IT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE MAYOR
VISION NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION AND TRAIL BILLING FOR
WHY TIMER PAYMENTS TO WORKERS IN
HOSPITALS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS WHO HAVE BEEN AT THE
FRONT LINES DELIVERING CARE TO
THE MOST ACUTE PATIENTS DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN. THIS PROPOSAL
AS A SEPARATE INVESTMENT FROM
THE ONE RELATED TO STATE WORKERS
WHICH IS SUBJECT TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ARE GETTING
INTERGRADES DISCO NURSING
FACILITY FINANCING REFORM ON THE
AVERAGE 4% ANNUAL INCREASE
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE MAYOR INCLUDES TO AND
EIGHTY MILLION ONGOING TOTAL. OF
WHICH ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION AS GENERAL
FUND AND TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR A NEW WORKFORCE IN QUALITY
PROGRAM PAYMENTS TO FACILITIES
THAT MEET QUALITY BENCHMARKS OR
MAKE SUBSTANTIAL AND- A LONG
TERM FUNDING FRAMEWORK IS THE
LONG TERM FINANCIAL BY OF THESE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS IS PREDICATE
ON ENABLING FOR. CHÁVEZ CALL
PATIENT CARE IN IMPROVE WORK
RETENTION AND EMPOWERING THE
VOICES OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PERSON WHO
PRESIDENT. MAY REVISION COULD
SUPPORT CENTER TRANSFER
INITIATIVE DEFICIENCY WITH
THIRTY POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL
FUND OVER. TWO YEARS. AN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT PROPOSED
THREE MILLION ONE GENERAL FUND
FOR THE FRIENDSHIP THE AMERICAN
IN. TO SUPPORT THE CONSTRUCTION
COST OF THE VILLAGE SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE EUROPE TRAVEL
CALIFORNIA TO ESTABLISH A
REGIONAL WELLNESS CENTER.
ADDITIONALLY THE MAY REVISION
HEALTH SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
INCLUDING ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CAPITAL COST TO
CONSTRUCT. ACQUIRE AND
REHABILITATE TREATMENT AND
HOUSING FACILITIES AS WELL AS
RENTALS. TO SUPPORT PLACEMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL ON MISDEMEANOR CHARGES IN
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS. THE MAYOR
PROPOSES TIME FUNDING TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING HOUSEHOLD
AFTER FEMA FUNDING EXPIRES THIS
MONTH. UNTIL JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR HOUR POINT THERE
WOULD BE A OUT OF THE VEHICLE
HEALTH CRISIS CAN. AND THE
CHILDREN NEED TO BE HERE HEALTH
AND- IN TO. SETTLEMENT FUNDS
STATE DIRECTOR PROGRAM INVEST IN
A RIVER PROPOSES TO AUGMENT
EXISTING PROPOSALS FOR. OF
NALOXONE TO HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROVIDER WORKFORCE
TRAINING. THE MAYOR VISION ALSO
INCLUDES A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
TO SUPPORT THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES LONG TERM
PLANNING FOR THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS CONTINUUM OF CARE
SUCH AS IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
NINETY DAY LIFELINE. IN CRISIS
INTERVENTION. STATEWIDE THERE
ARE BUDGET OF THE THAT WE HAVE
HEALTH RECOUP TIMELY. BY
DELAYING STATE. OF COUNTY FOR TO
OF THE THREE COMPLY BY WAY YEAR.
THE MAYOR OF THE CONTINUES TO
ASSUME RECOUP RELATED TO THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
AUDIT SETTLEMENT WILL RESUME IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE PREVIOUSLY AGREED UPON
RECRUITMENT TIMELINE. LASTLY THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES BUDGET
UPDATES TO VARIOUS PROPOSALS
INCLUDING CHILDREN YOUTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE PROP
FIFTY SIX PAYMENTS UPDATE TO
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
COVERAGE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION. AND CALLIE. AND
THAT CONCLUDES OUR OVERVIEW
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LMAO. THANK YOU LICORICE MORROW
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- WE ARE CONTINUING VIEW
THE YES HOWEVER I DO WANT TO
COME BRIEFLY- ON THE AND FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKER- WERE WAITING
FOR THE D. ON THE STRUCTURE OF
THE BOOK PROGRAM PAYMENTS
INCLUDING THIS SPECIFIC CRITERIA
OF WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE- FIVE
OR- WE WOULDN'T KNOW THAT- THERE
IS A QUESTION OF THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THE PAYMENTS WOULD HAVE AN
EFFECT ON RETENTION WHICH WENT
SENATE ONE OF AND- REASONS
BEHIND THAT POTENTIAL PAYMENTS-
AND THEN. IN ADDITION WE ARE
CURRENTLY EXAMINING WHETHER
THAT- FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOWABLE
UNDER ARTICLE SIXTEEN OF THE
STATE CONSTITUTION REGARDING THE
USE OF POWER FUNDS. THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE REQUEST THE- THANK VERY
MUCH- WHAT JUST SAID ABOUT
ARTICLES THIRD OF SIXTY YEAH I
THINK THIS THAT POINT YES
ARTICLES THE OF THE CONCERT. OF
THE ISN'T PARTY USE PUBLIC- SO
THERE'S A DIFFERENT PROVISIONAL
RELATED TO THAT ONE IS- RELATED
TO PROVIDING- FUNDING FOR THE
BENEFIT OF INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
EXPECTED TO CONTROL THE STATE
INCLUDING. HALL ANOTHER ONE IT
IS REGARDING THE GIFTING OF-
PUBLIC FUNDS AND THEN ANOTHER
ONE IS REGARDING GETTING FUNDS
TO. ENTITIES CONTROLLED BY
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING HOSPITALS AND
UNIVERSITIES OKAY SO WHICH
PROVISIONS ARE YOU CITING THIS
IN REGARD TO. THESE ARE ITS
SECTION THREE FIVE AND SIX OF
ARTICLE SIXTEEN OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION AND ARGUED AS IT
RELATES TO WHICH ISSUE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YEAH WE HAVE
MEANING WHICH ITEMS IN THE
BUDGET FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
THE OPRAH CAN YOU REPEAT THAT
SORRY. THAT YOU MCCARTY THAT
RETENTION CAME FOR TEN OR THE
NIGHT FORTY THREE MILLION OKAY.
OKAY OKAY BUT- WITH THE OF
FINANCE LIKE TO THE WRIST TO
THAT I GOING MR COMMITTEE. I'LL
COMMITTEE BARBARA- WE EXAMINED
AFTER. ONSTED FLOWS YOU ARE
WITHOUT ONLY BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS LAW GOING BACK REMOTE BUT
CENTS ALLOW- HUMAN TO BE MADE
THE SUBSTANCE OF THE THAT THEY
SERVE. PRIMARILY PUBLIC FOR AND
WE STATEMENT BOB YEAH WE BE
DESIGNED. TO SERVE THE PUBLIC
PURPOSE OF RETAINING THE SYSTEM
SOFTWARE WORKERS- AND PROMOTING
A PUBLIC PUBLIC OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVING STABLE.
WORKFORCE. SO WILL THAT THE
PAYMENT PROGRAM CODE TO THE
HEART. CENTER BE PER. TO THE FOR
RETENTION OR DIRECT TO AND-
THROUGH THE STATE. CURRENTLY THE
PROGRAM IS PROPOSED TO BE OFF-
THROUGH- HOSPITALS OR NURSING.
WITH RIVER PAYMENTS FROM THE
STATE AND THEN AND FACILITIES OF
YOUR TO THE THOSE. TO THEIR SO
THAT- STUFF I'M- OKAY- AN AND
HELP OUT WITH IS OUR ON THE ON
THE NINETY EIGHT SAYS. WHERE ARE
ON THAT. IN THE DEVELOPMENT FOR
THIS FUNDING. ALL OF THE FOR ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES. MISS COOPER
THERE. WE ARE ALMOST FINANCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY OUR LIFELINE
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED AND JULY OF
THIS YEAR. IS THERE IS A
SPECIFIC QUESTION WITH REGARDS
TO FUNDING JUST OUR OUR PROCESS
ON IMPLEMENTATION. THE
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTING
ENTITIES WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE
CRISIS- CENTERS. OKAY BUT WE'RE
SET UP IN ALL SYSTEMS TO GO FOR
DEBT FOR JULY. THERE'S BEEN
INVESTMENT IN THE CURRENT YEAR
TO ASSIST THE A CRISIS CENTERS
AND BE ABLE NOT TO HAVE
INCREASED CAPACITY. TO ADDRESS-
ADDITIONAL BECAUSE OF THE MAY BE
THROUGH THE NINE ANY- LIFELINE.
L. WE'VE ALSO WE ALSO HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL HELLO
YES FOR ADDITIONAL. TECH
ASSISTANCE AS WELL. OKAY OKAY
MAYBE WE CAN HERE- MORE ABOUT
THAT ABOUT THAT LATER- HOW ABOUT
AND I AND I KNOW THIS IS THROUGH
LEGISLATION BUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR DOULAS THAT'S
JUST FOR WE'RE JUST DOING BIRTH
DOULAS AT THIS POINT RIGHT. WE
HAVE NOT WE'RE NOT FUNDING DEATH
TO LOSE AT THIS TIME. FORCED TO
LIST SERVICES WIDE REACHING- JP
COOPER- THE STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR THAT IS CORRECT WE ARE
CURRENTLY- ONLY PROPOSING A BIRD
TO DO WAS- VERSES THE END OF
LIFE OR DEATH IT WAS. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DR I THANK YOU
AND- I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
ITEMS HERE AND IN ADDITION-
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS THE MAY REVISE
ON TOP OF A LOT OF OTHER ITEMS-
IF YOU QUESTIONS- SO FIRST OF
ALL AND I KNOW THERE'S A BILL
REGARDING THE KAISER CONTRACTED
BUT DOESN'T REFERENCE MADE IN
THE TESTIMONIES IS THERE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAN THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING ON THE KAISER CONTRACT
SEPARATE FROM THE LEGISLATION.
THAT IS CORRECT SO DH YET HAS
UPDATED THE- PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED
TRAILER BILL- THROUGH THE MAY
REVISION TO ADD ON SOME
PROVISIONS BASED ON FEEDBACK
THAT WE RECEIVED THREE
STAKEHOLDER. ENGAGEMENT AND THAT
TRAILER BILL HAS BEEN POSTED- ON
THE DA'S WEBSITE AND HAPPY TO
HELP YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL WE
DID HAVE A HEARING ON THAT SO I
WON'T GET INTO THAT OBVIOUSLY
YOU'VE- HEARD SOME OF THE
CONCERNS- THAT IN TERMS OF THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
FINANCING REFORM- IS. IS. THE
STORE THIS PURPOSE SO WHAT'S THE
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK ON ON ON
THESE PROPOSAL SO I MEAN
CERTAINLY IN YOUR DESCRIPTION
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS BUT- IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN.
WORKED OUT WITH THE- WITH THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS- THE TERMS
OF THIS PROPOSAL THIS BILL- THE
FINANCING REFORM. SO YOU KNOW WE
JUST ROLLED OUT THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE REVISION WE ARE CONTINUING
TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL OF OUR
KEY PARTNERS- AND WILL CONTINUE
TO DISCUSS WITH THEM THEIR
CONCERNS QUESTIONS AS WELL IS
THEIR UP PROPOSALS IN REGARDS TO
HOW TO ADDRESS AT THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL OKAY SO
BASICALLY- I MEAN AGAIN. ALL
RIGHT SO SOUNDS LIKE TO STILL
WORK TO BE DONE WHAT'S ON THIS
PROPOSAL ALL RIGHT- I GUESS THE
OTHER ONE I JUST ALSO WANT AND
THE CHIN SO I APPRECIATE THAT
WERE ELIMINATING AB NINETY SEVEN
PROVIDER RATE REDUCTIONS WHICH
GO BACK TO THE GREAT RECESSION
IN TWENTY ELEVEN FOR SEVERAL
SERVICES. THEY THOUGHT ABOUT-
WELL OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT IN THE
MAY REVISED PROPOSAL BUT- YOU
KNOW. COMMUNITIES WERE- IN SOME
WAYS THESE AGAIN THESE ARE STILL
RATE REDUCTIONS THEY HAVE GONE
BACK TO THE GREAT RECESSION AND
THEY'LL AND I. THAT WHEN I CAME
IN WITH A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT IT'S GREAT TO SEE WE
HAVE A- NINETY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS EFFECTIVE FIGURE
SURPLUS IS LARGER THAN THE TOTAL
STATE BUDGET WHEN I FIRST CAME
IN- IS THERE ANY THOUGHT TO
TRYING. TO LIMIT RATE REDUCTIONS
FOR SOME OF THE OTHER. THINGS
THAT STILL APPLIES TO- SINCE
THIS THESE ARE CUTS MADE DUE TO
THE BUDGET STRESSES IN THE GREAT
RECESSION. SURE I MEAN THE
DEPARTMENT PUT FORWARD IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A LIST OF WHAT
WE CONSIDERED SOME OF THE TOP
PRIORITIES IN REGARDS TO AB
NINETY SEVEN- OF- AND THEN
THROUGH THE MAY REVISION THE
ADDITIONAL ONES ADDED REALLY
WORK TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE NOT
ARE MOVING FORWARD FUTURE
REDUCTIONS ON AB NINETY SEVEN
FOR NEW BENEFITS THAT HAD BEEN
ADDED LAST YEAR. UNDER PROPOSED
THIS YEAR- WE STILL HAVE A
PRETTY LONG LIST JUST TO BE
FRANK IN REGARDS TO THE NUMBER
OF SERVICES THAT I'M STILL HAVE
THE AB NINETY SEVEN REDUCTION
APPLY TO THEM I'M SO MUCH I
MORE. IN REGARDS TO HOW THAT
WOULD BE SUPPORT FOR ONGOING
COSTS AT THIS TIME THE IT. HAS
PUT FORWARD THE PER FOR THE-
COVERS BUDGET ITEMS THEN I
ENSURING THAT NEW ITEMS ARE NOT
A MAINTAINING THAT THOSE CUTS
MOVING FORWARD AS WELL- ALL
RIGHT. I JUST CAN BY MAKING THAT
. WORKS NOW THERE. WE STILL HAVE
REIMBURSEMENT OR PAYMENT WHICH
LEAD TO. ISSUES AND APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE BUT
THIS IS NOW. ELEVEN YEARS LATER
WITH A- LITTLE LUCK NO THE MUCH
BETTER BUDGET. I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE IS ALSO- IT'S
NOT REALLY IN THE MAY REVISE
ALTHOUGH AGAIN THERE'S NO
FUNDING THROUGH THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM WITHOUT PROTECTION SOME
OF THIS WE GET TO SEE PH AS WELL
SO IN TERMS OF COVERT RESPONSE.
I WE KNOW I KNOW OUR SCHOOLS
ARE. HAVING TO SPEND A LOT OF
FUNDING ON CODE RESPONSE RIGHT
TO TRY TO KEEP SCHOOLS SAFE KEEP
THEM OPEN AND SO FORTH. WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO HELP THEM MAXIMO.
MEDIC CAL L. E. A. F. MA FUNDING
THAT THEY CAN GET THROUGH MEDIC
CAL- TO HELP THEM. SUPPORT AND-
FINANCE- SENSUALLY- HEALTH
MEASURES THAT THE NEED TO TAKE
IN SCHOOLS TO KEEP COVERED UNDER
CONTROL CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT-
SO THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT WE
DID DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. DIFFICULT TO ENSURE
THAT WE HELP OUR SCHOOLS AND BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE ALL THE SERVICES
NEEDED ON SITE OF FOR EXAMPLE WE
WERE ABLE TO GET HIM ASKED TO
APPROVE THE CARVING OUT OF ALL
OF THE TESTING ONSITE AT SCHOOL
TO BE REIMBURSED DIRECTLY TO
MEDIC HOW. ON THE FOR SERVICE SO
THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT CONTRACTING WITH MANAGED
CARE PLANS ANOTHER HE SAYS- BUT
AS LONG AS THE INDIVIDUAL WAS
MEDIC HOW ELIGIBLE THAT THEY CAN
BILL AND BE REIMBURSED FOR ALL
OF THE ON SITE SCHOOL TESTING I
THAT IS STILL IN PLACE IN
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET TO
CONTINUE- I'M ALSO WAS INCLUDED
IN OUR- UNWINDING PLAN THAT WAS
RELEASED. ON TUESDAY OF THIS
WEEK- ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING A NUMBER OF ITEMS IN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR ONLY
EIGHT IN REGARDS TO HOW TO
MAXIMIZE VARIOUS FUNDING AND
WE'VE MADE A NUMBER OF
MODIFICATIONS AND GUIDANCE
CONTINUE TO PART WITH PARTNER
WITH THEM IN REGARDS TO HOW THEY
CAN BE MAXIMIZING. OF THAT
FUNDING AND OR NEW INDIVIDUALS
JOINING THAT FUNDING STREAM I TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES I'M
SO HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO PARTNER
WITH THEM. OKAY YEAH BECAUSE I
THINK TRAIL PRIOR TO COPE WITH
THE REPORTS ABOUT HOW ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW
TRYING TO FEDERAL FUNDS RALLY A
WE WILL ACTUALLY. SOME WAYS
SIMILAR TO OUR PER PUPIL
SPENDING WE ARE ALSO VERY LOW
AND COMPARED TO OTHER STATES IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE PULL DOWN ON L.
EA NUMBER GARCIA THE TESTING-
NOW IF I RECALL CORRECTLY
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF ALL
CHILDREN. ARE COVERED BY
MEDICARE ALL SO DOES THAT MEAN
THAT ROUGHLY HALF OF ALL THAT
MEDIC CAL'S ACTUALLY FUNDING THE
TESTING IN SCHOOLS FOR ROUGHLY
HALF OF ALL THE STUDENTS I MEAN
I DON'T KNOW YOU HAVE AN
ESTIMATE- IN TERMS OF HOW IS
YOUR DOING YOU KNOW AS AS- IT IS
YOUR- CUT YOUR COVERING TESTING
COSTS FOR. FOR SCHOOL STUDENTS.
ARE IT IS A MORE THAN THAT ARE
IS IT IS IT SERVE AND WHY WITH
THE PERCENTAGES OF CHILDREN. WHO
ARE COVERED BY MEDICARE ALL.
THAT'S A YORKER WE CURRENT
COVER- APPROX. 5255% ON WHO. A
IN THAT. TOTAL OF CHOI. IN
MEDIKAL CROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK DOMINANTLY
ONE THING THAT WOULD NOTICES
THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDS
PROVIDED IN REGARDS TO TESTING
AFFECTS THE ON SITE FOR SCHOOLS.
AS WELL AS OTHER FUNDS. HOWEVER
WE HAVE HAD- CLAIMS COMING INTO
US WITH MAINTAINED- THAT WITHIN
THE BUDGET FOR. ALLOWING FOR
THAT REIMBURSEMENT- AND WE DO
KNOW THAT AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STARTS YOU AND SOME
THEIR FINANCING. IT WILL BE
CRITICAL THAT WE KEEP THAT
AVAILABLE FOR ON THE SCHOOLS TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TESTING AT
THAT SO. WHAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHOOSE A AND TO BE ABLE TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR THOSE SERVICES
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET TO
CONTINUE THAT. ONSITE SCHOOL
TESTING FOR MEDIC CAL AT THE END
OF THIS YEAR OKAY I AM GRATEFUL
FOR THAT AND THIS THIS- COVERAGE
WILL CONTINUE PASSED THE FEDERAL
STATE OF EMERGENCY. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY EXCELLENT ALL
RIGHT- THANK YOU- OKAY. WELL I
MEAN- WE CAN FOLLOW UP ON SOME
OTHER. LATER ON THAT DAY AND- I
KNOW OF DIFFERENT ITEMS HERE-
AND- ALSO- AND- PUTTING LIKE A
CALLIONYMUS. SELF ALL RIGHT WHAT
JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU HAVE TO YEAH. WE SEE
BILLIONS NOW EASILY HUNDREDS OF
THEM OKAY. MOVING ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT'S NOT TO TELL AGAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL
BE PRESENTING ON THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
WITH MY COLLEAGUE NICK MILLS-
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH WHO ARE
AVAILABLE TO RESPOND. I HAVE FOR
A BROAD OVERVIEW FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THE MAIN
REVISION PROPOSES A TOTAL OF SIX
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDING ONE POINT ONE BILLION
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT CD PH
AS PROGRAMS AND SERVICES OF THAT
AMOUNT THREE POINT NINE BILLION
FUND STATE OPERATIONS AND THE
REMAINING AMOUNT OF TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION IS TO SUPPORT
LOCAL. I'LL START WITH THE CODE.
PANDEMIC CDPH REQUEST ALMOST ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUND TO
CONTINUE EXISTING. RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. IN TO IMPLEMENT THE
STATE'S SMARTER PLAN. FUNDS WILL
BE USED TO A CARBON NINETEEN
WITH. ACTIVITIES INCLUDING.
MEDICAL SEARCH STAFFING.
VACCINATIONS THERAPEUTICS
SURVEILLANCE AND BORDER AND
OPERATIONS RESPONSE. THE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION INCLUDES AN
INCREMENTAL INCREASE OF ONE
POINT ONE MILLION COMPARED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF ALL THE
SHIPS OF SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND THAT WAS
ALSO INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY REALLY FIND
. C. P. ALSO REQUEST TO INCREASE
THEIR GENERAL FUND REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY I ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME SIMILAR TO AND SEND
BUDGET REQUEST CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEVEL OF FUNDING INCLUDED
FOR MEDICAL SEARCH STAFFING.
FINALLY I'LL JUST MENTION BUT
THE MAIN REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ZERO FUN FOR THE
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
AND STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING CODE
NINETEEN THAT SEEM RELATED
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
IMPLEMENTED BY SPEAKING. TOTAL
FUNDING FOR THE NEW OFFICE
REFLECTS A SHIFT TO ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
CPA'S IDLE INCREMENTAL OF ONE
HUNDRED MILLION OUT ME REVISIONS
YOU CONTINUE SPECIFIED CAMPAIGNS. NOW HEADED OFF MY COLLEAGUES
MOST PROVIDE OUR MEETING
PROPOSAL. ORANGE HER MEMBERS
THANK MALES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. CDPH REQUESTED
ASSISTANCE AID DRUG ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THE GENETIC DISEASE
SCREENING PROGRAM AND WOMEN
INFANTS AND CHILDREN PROGRAM
ESTIMATES BASED ON OUR UPLOAD
ARE UPDATED KEESLER PROJECTIONS
FOR THE AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THE MAY REVISION
REFLECTS AN INCREASE OF THIRTY
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION THE
LOCAL ASSISTANCE COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROJECTS. AND THAT
INCREASES PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY
LOWER THAN PREVIOUSLY ESTIMATED
SAVINGS FROM THE MEDIC CAL
EXPANSIONS INDIVIDUALS AGE FIFTY
YEARS AND OLDER. FOR THE GENETIC
DISEASE SCREENING PROGRAM THE
MAYOR VISION REFLECTS A DECREASE
OF ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND GENETIC DISEASE
TESTING PINE STATE OPERATIONS
THE DECREASE OF THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND GENETIC
DISEASE TESTING FIND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGETS. THE DECREASE
IN STATE OPERATIONS IS TREATED
TO A ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR BASED ON ADJUSTMENTS THE
DECREASE IN LOCAL ASSISTANCE IS
ATTRIBUTED TO MOVING THE LAUNCH
DATES FOR CELL FREE DNA
SCREENING FROM JULY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO SEPTEMBER TWENTY
UNTIL. FOR THE SPECIAL
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION PROGRAM
FOR WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
ALSO KNOWN AS WHERE THE MAYOR OF
IS AN REFLECTS AN INCREASE OF
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE TOTAL NET INCREASE
IS DRIVEN BY THE EXTENSION OF
THE TEMPORARY FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE BENEFIT INCREASE
THROUGH THE END OF SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AN INCREASE
IN THE FOOD INFLATION RATE AND A
NEW REBATE ESTIMATION METHOD
METHODOLOGY. NEXT ISSUE
EUSTATHIOS BENSON CDPH REQUEST A
ONE TIME INCREASE OF FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO DEVELOP
A TARGETED COMMUNITY BASED YOUTH
SUICIDE PREVENTION PROGRAM FOR
USE THAT INCREASED RISK OF
SUICIDE. CORRESPONDING
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IS PROPOSED
TO ALLOW FOR INCUMBENTS ARE
EXPENDITURE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE PROPOSAL
HAS TO MAIN COMPONENTS THE FIRST
IS DEVELOPMENT OF THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN TO FOCUS ON USED
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
SUICIDE. SECOND IS AWARDING F
GRANTS TO YOUTH SERVING
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
DISSEMINATE THE MESSAGES AND
TOOLS DEVELOPED FOR THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN AS EMPLOYMENT OTHER
EVIDENCE BASED SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRATEGY. OUR NEXT
ISSUES EXTREME HEATS. PART OF
THE ADDRESSING EXTREME HE
PROPOSAL FEEDING HERE IT'S
REQUEST A ONE TIME INCREASE OF
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY TO SUPPORT OUR REACH
OVERSIGHT EDUCATION AND TRAINING
TO SURVEYORS OF LONG TERM
FACILITIES ABOUT EXTREME HEAT.
HOW IT AFFECTS A CENTER RESIDENT
CARE. A ONE TIME INCREASE OF ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR
THE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH
BRANCH WAS ALSO REQUESTED.
SUPPORT OUTRAGE SIMPLER SOME
FORM THEM ABOUT EXTREME HEAT
RISKS AND INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
SETTINGS APPLICABLES REGULATIONS
AND RESOURCES FOR ASSISTANCE AND
MINIMIZING RESTS- FOR BOTH
COMPONENTS OF THE EXTREME HE
PROPOSAL PROVISIONAL LANGUAGES
PROPOSAL OUT FOR A CONFERENCE OR
EXPENDITURE. UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
OUR NEXT TOPIC IS STAFFING
AUDITS- PUBLIC HEALTH REQUEST A
ONE TIME INCREASE OF FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE THE FUNDING
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD FOR THE
STAFFING ARTIFACTS AND TO AUDIT
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
MINIMUM STAFFING REQUIREMENTS.
OUR DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS PROPOSING STATUTORY
LANGUAGE FOR A NEW META CAL
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY QUALITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT SYSTEM BE IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THAT'S THE FOR A
PROPOSED ONE TIME FUNDS WELL
SUPPORT STAFFING AUDIT SECTIONS
EXISTING WORKLOADS THROUGH THE
BUDGET YEAR. I'M NEXT ISSUES
LGBTQ GRANTS OTHER PARMA PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUESTED A ONE TIME
INCREASE OF FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO AWARD GRANTS TO COUNTIES
THAT EXPERIENCED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO DEMONSTRATE
IMPROVED CAPACITY TRAINING AND
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE CARE FOR
THE UNIQUE NEEDS. OF LGBTQ PLUS
FOSTER YOUTH- NEXT ISSUE A
SICKLE CELL- FEE PAID C. PH
REQUEST ONE TIME INCREASE OF
FIVE NINE IN GENERAL FUND THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE TO
SUPPORT NETWORKING CALIFORNIA
FOR SICKLE CELL CARE INITIATIVE.
THIS PROPOSAL BUILDS UPON
RESOURCES APPROPRIATED AND-
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTS FOR THE
SICKLE CELL DISEASE FOUNDATIONS
OF ABOUT THE NETWORK OF SICKLE
CELL DISEASE TREATMENT STATUS.
OUR NEXT TOPIC IS PUBLIC HEALTH
LIKE CHRONIC LICENSING PROGRAM
FOR TISSUE BANKS AND BIOLOGIC
FACILITIES- PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUEST AN ADJUSTMENT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE PUBLIC HEALTH ELECTRONIC
LICENSING PROGRAM FOR TISSUE
BANKS THE BIOLOGIC FACILITIES.
JUST HAVE TWO POSITIONS AND TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY ON
THE CLINICAL LABORATORY
IMPROVEMENT FUNDS TO THAT ISSUE
BANK LICENSE FUNDS. OKAY OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ONE ENTRY OF TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE OPIOID SETTLEMENTS FIND IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THE FUND
TO PROPOSED PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS FOCUSED ON USED OPIOID
EDUCATION AND FEDERAL RISK
EDUCATION. THIS BRINGS TOTAL
FUNDING FOR THE PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS FORTY POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS DEPARTMENT ALSO
PROPOSED TO AMEND CORRESPONDING
. LANGUAGE AUTHORIZING THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO BE
ENCUMBERED OR EXPANDED UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH. PRICE. FIVE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO
REQUEST REAPPROPRIATION OF FUNDS
INCLUDED IN PREVIOUS BUDGET
ACTS. FOR THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS TO RE
APPROPRIATE FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACTS DEVELOP PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN
THAT APPROVED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
LITERACY. TO NORMALIZE HEALTH
SEEKING BEHAVIOR AS PART OF THE
CHILDREN AND USE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE. PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGES PROPOSED THAT ALLOWS
FOR EXPENDITURE OUR CONFERENCE
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH. TWENTY
TWENTY FOR MORE. FOR THE
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS EFFORT FUND
- FORMER QUESTION RE APPROACH
AND TRANSFER THIRTEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTS WITH TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION INSTEAD
OPERATIONS AND TEN POINT THREE
MILLION. THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE TRANSGENDER WELLNESS AND
EQUITY FUNDS TO AWARD GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ADDRESS THE HEALTH NEEDS OF
TRANSGENDER GENDER NON
CONFORMING OR INTERSEX
INDIVIDUALS. PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGES PROPOSED ALLOWS
SPANISH OUR INCUMBENCY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IT ALSO
MAINTAINS HIS ABSENCE INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACTS RELATED TO CONTRACTING. FOR
THE US SURVEILLANCE HEALTH
INTERVENTION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
LEAD DATABASE YOU'RE AFTER FOR
TWO S. SHIELD- DEPARTMENT
REQUEST TO RE APPROPRIATE FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING
PREVENTION FINDS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTS-
CONTINUE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SHIELD IT
PROJECTS. FOR THE ALL CHILDREN
THRIVE PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT
REQUEST TO RE APPROPRIATE TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FIND INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACTS
PROCESS UNPAID INVOICES SO SAID
WITH THE EVALUATION ACTIVITIES.
FOR THE PILOT PHASE OF THE ALL
CHILDREN THRIVE PROGRAM. OF
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES A
COUPLE OF TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
THERE ARE ADJUSTMENTS TO PROP
NINETY NINE EXPENDITURES AND
FUNDING TO TWENTY THREE. BASED
ON UPDATED REVENUE PROJECTIONS.
AND THERE IS A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT CONSISTENT WITH THE
APRIL ONE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
FOR A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM PROPOSAL.
TO SHIFT TEN POSITIONS FROM THE
HEALTH STATISTICS SPECIAL FUNDS
THE GENERAL FUND AND TO DECREASE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY AND THE
HEALTH STATISTICS SPECIAL FUND
BY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. WE AND OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HELLO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L.
A. O. I'M WE ARE STILL REVIEWING
MANY OF THESE PROPOSALS AND THE
VARIOUS DETAILS FOR TODAY I'M
GOING TO LIMIT MY COMMENTS TO-
THE FIRST ITEM CONCERNING COBIT
SPENDING AND IN PARTICULAR ONE
COMPONENT OF THAT PROPOSAL- AS-
AS OF MY FINANCE COLLEAGUES
NOTED THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO SHIFT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO A
NEW OFFICE. WITHIN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO SUPPORT
KOBE NINETEEN VACCINE RELATED
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND OUTREACH.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS
APPROACH. WE BELIEVE THAT
SHIFTING THIS RESPONSIBILITY-
PARTICULARLY WHILE THE PANDEMIC
REMAINS ONGOING COULD DELAY THE
DISSEMINATION OF IMPORTANT
INFORMATION ON VACCINES AND
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES.
AND MOREOVER- WE HAVE CONCERNS
THAT THE SHIFT COULD RESULT IN
SORT OF DUPLICATION AND- MIXED
MESSAGING AND AVOIDING THESE
KINDS OF OUTCOMES BEEN- WE THINK
ONE OF THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE MISSED
MISTER MIL MISTER TELL AND THAT
ARE THAT ARE AVAILABLE BE ABLE
ANSWER THAT QUESTION ABOUT THE-
THE WISDOM OF THAT AT THE NEW
AGE DOING THIS FIRST. THE
PROGRAMS ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE.
CERTAINLY I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND.
THE REGARD THE FIRST CAN- A
DELAY OF INFORMATION SHARING SO
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ASSEMBLING
TRANSITION TEAM THAT INCLUDES
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING RESEARCH CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO SUPPORT THIS
MAY TRANSFER OF THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF CODE
NINETEEN OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS IN
ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION IS
FINALIZING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE STATUTORY
GUIDELINES FOR ACTUATING THE
TRANSFER OR CURRENT CONTRACTING
DUTIES FROM CITY PAGE OVER TO
THE NEW OFFICE. I'M IN REGARDS
TO THE SECOND QUESTION- IN TERMS
OF DUPLICATION OF ACTIVITIES ON
WE WILL KNOW THAT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN AND I WOULD JUST MENTION
THAT THE OFFICE IS BEING CREATED
TO ADDRESS INEFFICIENCIES
INCLUDING DUPLICATION OF EFFORTS
WITHIN STATEWIDE OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS- ON THE ADMINISTRATION
ANTICIPATES THAT OFFICIALLY
BEGINS WILL BE REALIZED THROUGH
INCREASED COORDINATION ACROSS
DIFFERENT STATE ENTITIES AND
HAVING ONE ORGANIZING. TO
OVERSEE COMPLEX AND MULTI
FACETED PROJECTS LIKE KOBE
NINETEEN OUT REACH PROGRAM WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL TO THE OVERALL
EFFICIENCIES OF OUR OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS- AND IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON THE
OFFICE ITSELF I WOULD TAKE THOSE
BACK AND COORDINATE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH ASSIGNMENTS
THANK YOU AND SO WITH THIS. THIS
THIS NEW TO AND WHAT IT ALL. DO
THE DECEMBER ON LIKE THE ON THE
NEXT PAGE MORE TALK ABOUT-
SUICIDE OUTREACH PUBLIC WHERE
OPIOID CAMPAIGNS LIKE ALL THE
ALL THE CAMPAIGNS WE DO IS.
BIGGER BROADER MULTI FACETED
CONTAINS THAT OFTEN HAVE TOUCHES
AND DEPARTMENTS SO AT THIS AT
LEAST WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH BROWN THE PRIMARY
CAMPAIGN THAT WOULD BE SHIFTING
OVER WOULD BE RELATED TO COVER
NINETEEN VACCINATIONS. OKAY SO
THEN COULD YOU ALSO SPEAK TO
THE- BECAUSE WE ALREADY WENT
OVER SOME THINGS UNDER HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
BEHAVIOR YOUTH INITIATIVES.
SUICIDE OUT REACH SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT FEEL LIKE THEY WERE
THEY ALSO LIVE IN DIFFERENT-
DIFFERENT APARTMENTS AND I
UNDERSTAND DIFFERENT AGENCIES DO
DIFFERENT THINGS. BUT ARE WE ARE
WE ASSURED OF THAT THAT LEVEL OF
COORDINATION. ARE YOU SPEAKING
IN REGARDS TO SORT OF LIKE BROAD
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROPOSALS
CORRECT THAT THIS ONE THE
SUICIDE ONE. HE WAS ONE OF THE
ONE THAT WE JUST CAN'T FOR YOUTH
- I THINK YOU KNOW I WOULD STATE
THAT A HIGH LEVEL THAT IS THE
ROLE THAT THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY HAS
TAKEN ON BUT WOULD ALSO DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUES. EITHER AT AGENCY
OR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH YOU ADD ON TO THAT. AND I
THINK I SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE CHILDREN YOUTH SUICIDE
PREVENTION OF FORTY MILLION. I
THINK I'M WAITING FOR THAT ONE I
WOULD WANT TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD. REGARDING
THE SUICIDE- GRANT PROGRAMS.
APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T BRING ENOUGH
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO CLARIFY ON THE FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM.
READ IT WHEN YOU'RE WITH US WITH
THE DEPARTMENT RITA. I
UNDERSTANDING THAT FAR- HADN'T
CLARIFIED WHETHER THAT. WORK
WOULD BE HAPPENING WITH BECAME
ACTED. OUT LEVEL DON'T WE DON'T
HAVE ANY. CAN YOU REPEAT THAT
ARE IN HERE YOU. OKAY NOW I CAN
. ARE GENERALLY FOR OUR CAMPAIGN
REVIEW COORDINATE ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS AND THEN CONTINUE I
WOULD BE FIVE HUNDRED WHILE AND
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY FURTHER
INSTRUCTION THAT IT MIGHT BE
MOVING OUT OF CDPH SO WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING UNDER THE ASSUMPTION
THAT. SIDE CAMPAIGN WOULD BE
LOOKING EACH. OKAY OKAY LET'S
LET'S JUST LET'S JUST MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE COORDINATING AND THEN
ON THE ON THE A DEBT PROGRAM ARE
WE SAYING THAT THE COST WENT UP
BECAUSE OF THE OVER FIFTY
MEDICAL EXPANSION. THAT WOULD I
HEARD. SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT NOTHING BECAUSE
WHEN UP BECAUSE OF THE OVERHEAD
THE EXPANSION IT'S THAT PATENT
OWNERS BUDGET WE OVER PROJECTED
POTENTIAL SAVINGS AS A RESULT
THE BECAUSE SAVINGS HAVE GONE
DOWN OUR COSTS WITH THEREFORE GO
UP A LITTLE BIT. OKAY BUT
BECAUSE OF THE OVER FIFTY.
EXPANSION IT IN THIS PROGRAM AND
SPECIFICALLY A DEATH. RIGHT AND
I THINK JUST BROKE TO CLARIFY
OVERALL WE'RE SEEING A REDUCTION
IT'S JUST COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AT THAT POINT
IN TIME MEASURE WE'RE SEEING A
SLIGHT INCREASE THAT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. I THINK MIKE PENCE.
THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL SIR TO GO
BACK A LITTLE BIT ON THE- I
GUESS NEED THIS AT THE MOMENT
THE OFFICE AND SO FORTH- THAT
DOES OUTREACH- AND CERTAINLY
HERE THE L. A. AS CONCERNS BUT
AT IF I RECALL CORRECTLY AND
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG-
WE I AND I KNOW THAT I BROUGHT
IT UP BEFORE EARLIER ON IN THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE WE HAD INVESTED
ACTUALLY IN A LOT OF. A
COMMUNITY OUTREACH FOR THE
CENSUS FOR TWENTY TWENTY RIGHT.
AND THE CENSUS OUTREACH AND I
AND I KNOW THAT I HAD. MADE
MENTION AND- SOUNDS AND I
BELIEVE THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
CAME TO THE SAME CONCLUSION THAT
WELL AFTER WE BUILT THIS NETWORK
FOR OUTREACH. TO COMMUNITIES AND
WE HAVE THIS PANDEMIC GOING ON
WE NEED TO REACH OUT TO
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SHOULD TAKE
THE SKILLS THAT WE LEARNED OF
THE CAPACITY THAT WE BUILD AND
USE THAT TO HELP. ADDRESS THE
PANDEMIC CAN COMMUNICATE ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS NATIONS
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS. SO IS
THIS IS THIS THE SORT OF THE
TEAM AND CAPACITY I SHOULD SAY
THAT WE'RE NOW. TALKING ABOUT
MOVING TO IS IT IS AT THE OFFICE
OF RESEARCH OR SOMETHING CAN- SO
THAT THE IS IT IS THAT CORRECT.
SO- YOUR POINT OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
JUST A COMMUNICATION ART OKAY.
YEAH A LITTLE BIT OF A MOUTHFUL
- I THINK I THINK YOU'RE SORT OF
DIRECTION IS CORRECT YOU KNOW
THE INTENT IS TO REALLY START
LEVERAGING A LOT OF THE LESSONS
WE'VE ALREADY LEARNED WHAT
COMMUNITY. I'M REALLY MOBILIZING
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WE ALREADY
DEVELOPED OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT IN
THE- I APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE-
I THINK IN TERMS OF. WORK WITH
COMMUNITY GROUPS WANTED
CHALLENGES YOU KNOW WE'RE VERY
BIG STATE GOVERNMENT RIGHT WE
HAVE A LOT OF AGENCIES AND THEN
WHAT HAPPENS IS LIKE ONE AGENCY
TRIES TO TALK TO YOU ANOTHER
AGENCY AND- THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE OTHER AGENCY SAID RIGHT AND-
AND SO FORTH AND- ESPECIALLY
WE'RE TRYING TO. DELVE MORE
DEEPLY INTO BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS- WE IT'S GOOD NOT
TO HAVE TO ESSENTIALLY REBUILD
RELATIONSHIP OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WITH DIFFERENT PEOPLE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES DIFFERENT PURPOSES AND
THAT TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT YOU
KNOW. BEING ABLE TO. HAVE A
GROUP THAT. RAY HAS EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS HAS ONGOING
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ALSO MIGHT
EVEN HELP WITH THE COMMUNITY
GROUPS. TO SAY THIS BUT
PRIORITIZE- ARE AT LEAST BE
PROVIDE REAL PRICEY BACK AS TO
WHICH MESSAGES SO FORTH ARE
RESONATING WITH PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES. I THINK DOES IT CAN
BE HELPFUL SO AND SO TO ME THE I
THINK THERE'S- SENSUALLY SOME
ADVANTAGES BUT I DO APPRECIATE
ALEJO'S POINT THAT WHAT WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IS BECOME SO
SEPARATED FROM. THE GROUPS THAT
NEED TO DO THE WORK FOR EXAMPLE
CERTAINLY WITH CALVIN THE
PANDEMIC AND CDPH. TO MEET NOT
BE SO SEPARATED THAT BASICALLY
WE START PUTTING BUREAUCRATIC
BARRIERS TO AGENCIES YOU NEED TO
DO CAN BEOUT REACH. AT THE END
BECAUSE IT'S IN A DIFFERENT. BOX
IN THE- YOU KNOW IN THE
ORGANIZATION CHART THAT- THAT IT
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO. TO USE THIS
CAPACITY THAT WERE WERE TRYING
TO REFINE- IN THIS NEW OFFICE.
SO COULDN'T CAN YOU PERHAPS
SPEAK TO- WHAT STEPS ARE BEING
TAKEN TO ENSURE THAT AS THIS. A
NEW ORGANIZATION WHICH I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND LEAST.
HOPEFULLY MY DESCRIPTIONS
CORRECT IN TERMS OF THE PURPOSE
REASON YOU MIGHT BE WANTING TO
DO THIS- WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
ENSURE THAT THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES IN PARTICULAR PUBLIC
HEALTH BECAUSE I KNOW PUBLIC
HEALTH AS A YOU KNOW A LOT OF
THAT WORK HAS TO HAPPEN ON THE
GROUND. IS GOING TO BE SURE
TODAY HAVE SUFFICIENT. ACCESS TO
THIS CAPACITY THAT WE'RE NOW
MOVING OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCY
WHICH OTHER AGENCIES CAN ALSO
USE. IT INTO A SEPARATE OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK- SO I
WOULD JUST REITERATE AGAIN THAT
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL TRANSFER
THE ADMINISTRATION IS FINALIZING
TRAILER BILL. THAT WOULD REALLY
PROVIDE THE STATUTORY GUIDELINES
FOR A FUNCTIONING THE TRANSFER-
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK JUST TO
KIND OF REITERATE SOME OF YOUR
COMMENTS. DR PAN THE INTENT OF
THE OFFICE IS TO FORMALIZE A LOT
OF THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
STATE LIKE OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. TO
HARD TO REACH POPULATIONS SUCH
AS A COVERT NINETEEN CAMPAIGN
ESPECIALLY AROUND VACCINATIONS-
WE- YOU KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTS THERE TO BE MULTIPLE
PROGRAMMATIC EFFICIENCIES WITHIN
THE OFFICE AND REALLY THE GOAL
IS TO. PROVIDE BETTER SERVICE
DELIVERY BETTER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. I DON'T OVERALL
GREATER CAPACITY TO GET
INFORMATION TO REALLY WHO AND
WHERE IT'S NEEDED THE MOST. IN
TERMS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE OFFICE AND CDPH
THEIR OFFICE- INTENDS TO
CONTINUE COLLABORATION WITH CD.
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS. TO
DEVELOP MATERIALS WORK WITH
LOCAL COUNTY AND VIDEOS. AND
REALLY FOCUS ON STRENGTHENING
THE CAMPAIGNS AS LOCAL NEED
SHIFT DURING THE PANDEMIC SO I
THINK THERE'S STILL. THE
EXPECTATION THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME LEVEL OF ONGOING
COLLABORATION GIVING ON. THE
TIME TO TRANSITION AND SORT OF
STAND UP THE OFFICE WILL
CONTINUE ENSURING THERE'S
CONTINUITY OF THE CAMPAIGN OKAY.
SO HOPEFULLY SOME MEANS HIGH
LEVEL OF COOPERATION. AND THAT.
OKAY THANK NOT. BUT YEAH. SO
IT'S- I DID HAVE SOME QUESTION
REGARDING THE- COBA DIREC
SPONSOR X. BECAUSE JUST SAID ONE
POINT BILLION AND- LIST SOME
THINGS UNDER THERE SO DID DELVE
INTO. A FEW MORE DETAILS I KNOW
IN PAST BUDGET HEARINGS I'VE-
MENTIONED AND BABY CAN. SPEAK
WELL MORE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT THE
VACCINATION RATES AND
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN IS STILL
FAIRLY LOW I THINK IT'S ONLY 36%
FOR FIVE TO ELEVEN. FOR
TEENAGERS IT'S AROUND TWO THIRDS
WHICH IS BELOW THE SERVE EIGHTY
PLUS PERCENT THAT WE HAVE FOR
THE- OVERALL. FOR THE ADULT
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA. AS A
PEDIATRICIAN I KNOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE USED TO GETTING THEIR
VACCINES FROM THEIR DOCTOR. AND
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE. SO IF I
CALL AND- AND WE LEARNED THIS
LESSON BY THE WAY WITH PRIOR
VACCINES RIGHT SO BEFORE YOU
KNOW BACK IN. THE LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES- WE HAD A LARGE MEASLES
OUTBREAK IN LOS ANGELES- WHERE
BECAUSE A LOT OF BECAUSE-
SENSUALLY LAW THE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WERE NOT ACTUALLY
PROVIDING VACCINES IN THE OFFICE
THEY WOULD RECOMMEND THEMSELVES
GO TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT GO SOMEWHERE ELSE
HERE TO GET THE VACCINE. YOU
KNOW MEDICAL COVERAGE BUT- IT
WASN'T DELIVERED AT THE OFFICE
THE VERY PLACE YOU GO NUTS YOU
DON'T GET SENT TO A PHARMACY
DON'T GET THE VACCINATIONS. YOU
KNOW IT'S LIKE I MEAN JUST IN I
GET THE VACCINE- OKAY LANCE
QUESTIONS I WILL GIVE TO YOU
RIGHT NOW WELL YOU'RE IN THE-
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO HAVE-
DOING. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF. I AM
A CARE. PARTICULARLY
PEDIATRICIANS FOUND THE CARE OF
CHILDREN CAN ACTUALLY DELIVER
THE VACCINE IN THEIR OFFICE AT
THE VERY TIME TO TALK TO THE
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES. NOT
SEND THEM OFF TO A PHARMACY NOT
OFF THE MASS VACCINATION NIGHTS
AND THE MANY WHERE ELSE THEY CAN
GIVE IT IN THE OFFICE. FOR THAT
WHEN I WENT OUT THEM IF WHEN HE
- COLLEAGUES OKAY. I DR GRANT
THE DOCTOR COUNTY DIRECTOR AND
HE WE DO A SIX. AMOUNT OF MONEY
FOCUS ON PROVIDING SMALL GRANTS
TO PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS WE
CONCLUDE AGREE WITH YOU IT'S AND
LESS THAN FIVE IT'S GOING TO BE
ABOUT ENGAGING- PEDIATRICIAN
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE IN THE
LOW INCOME SAID THE MARK OR ARE
STATE NET SHOULD IS THAT IS
ACTUALLY PART OF OURS OUR
STRATEGY TO CLOSE- INCREASE
INCREASE. IN THAT AGE GROUP OKAY
SO I I'VE BEEN I THINK THE
PRAYER TIME OF ALSO HEARD THE
ANSWERS THAT WE HAVE GRANTS I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE UPTAKE IS
FOR THE GRANTS AND SO FORTH SO-
HOPING YEAH SO WHAT WE CAN DO IS
I DON'T HAVE THOSE. STATISTICS
WITH ME RIGHT NOW BUT WE CAN GET
YOU THOSE STATISTICS AND FALL
OPEN OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I WOULD LET
ME JUST PUT IT THIS WAY FROM THE
TIME LINE. ISSUE- WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO. WHO ARE SHOWING UP IN
THEIR DOCK OFFICE. IS JULY AND
AUGUST BECAUSE THE KIDS ARE
STARTING SCHOOL IN AUGUST
SEPTEMBER. AND THEY'RE GOING TO
COME IN AND THEY NEED TO GET
THEIR VACCINATIONS FOR SCHOOLS.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT
THERE IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEIR DOCTOR OR NURSE
PRACTITIONER PA IS A BY THE WAY
IN ADDITION YOU SHOULD GET YOUR
CHILD THE COVER VACCINES.
PARALEGAL OKAY YOU. AND SO- CAN
I GET IT WITH THE OTHER VACCINES
IT OF THE ANSWER IS WELL
ACTUALLY WE CAN GIVE YOU THE
OTHER ONES BUT YOU HAVE TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE RECOVERED BAXEEN.
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
GET IT JUST BECAUSE OF THE
HASSLE NOT THAT THEY DON'T AGREE
NOT THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO IT
CETERA. SO WE HAVE THAT WINDOW
OF OPPORTUNITY THAT WE GOT IT
YOU KNOW BETWEEN THE SENSUALLY
JULY AND AUGUST AND IT'S READY
AND OF. GETTING MID MAY. THAT WE
ASK THE TEE IT UP BECAUSE THAT'S
GOING TO BE YOU KNOW WE ARE BOTH
SIDES OF PETERSON WE KNOW THAT'S
THE SEASON IN WHICH PEOPLE COME
IN AND GET THEIR VACCINES CAUGHT
UP. AND SO- SO AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE- GETTING THAT
INFORMATION BUT ALSO SOME
URGENCY- IN IN TERMS OF BEING.
GOT TO GETTING THOSE TEED UP- I
GUESS THE NEXT QUESTION I HAVE
IS- IN RELATION TO A LONG CO
BID- AND THE L- I THINK AND
AGAIN WE DID A HEARING IN THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH ON THIS-
WHAT IS. CDPH DOING. IN TERMS
OF- TRACKING LANCO BID- THE
STUDIES THAT HAVE COME OUT SHOW
THAT ACTUALLY EVEN PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOSPITALIZED WITH MILDER
ASYMPTOMATIC. WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGES OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LONG COVETED.
THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ESTIMATE THAT ONE MILLION
AMERICANS ARE OUT OF THE WORK
FORCE BECAUSE ALONG CO THAT
SYMPTOMS AT LEAST- YOU KNOW IN
ENGLAND THEY'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT A THIRD OF THEIR WORK
FORCE. AT IS OUT BECAUSE OF SOME
DISABILITY AND THAT THAT SPIKE
BECAUSE A LONG KOVITZ THIS IS A
MAJOR ACT. ISSUE AS WELL AS- A
HEALTHY- SO WHAT IS C. N. AND I
REALISED SOME CHALLENGES BECAUSE
WE HAD OUR HEARING IN TERMS OF
DEFINITIONS AND SO FORTH. BUT
WHAT A CD FOR YEAH INVESTING IN
TRYING TO TRACK LONG COATED- YES
I YOU FOR THAT SO THERE'S
SEVERAL AREAS THAT WERE FOR ON
THE EURO. AND IT'S REALLY IT'S A
IT'S EVEN BROADER IN THE IN
THOSE YOU THINK OF JUST LONG
KOBE RIGHT THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHERS CALL I FROM CO ORANGE
BEGINNING LEARN ABOUT. SO ONE IS
THAT WE ARE PURCHASING WITH THE
CDC AND FOR TO STUDY PERSONS
WITH LONG COVE THE SECOND THING
THEY WERE DOING IS THAT WORSE
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER UNIVERSITIES SUCH AS
STANFORD. AND IN REALLY BUILDING
OUT OUR ABILITY TO COLLABORATE
ON NEW RESEARCH PROJECTS THAT
ALSO EXISTING RESEARCH PROJECTS
COULD WE KNOW ACROSS CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING RESEARCH
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
HARNESS ALL THAT A RESEARCH
FINDINGS THAT ARE COMING OUT SO
WE DO WE DO HAVE A MONEY IN THE
BUDGET TO COORDINATE WITH YOU
SEE TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER TO
SHARE AND TO LEARN. AND THEN THE
OTHER COMPONENT IS GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH HEALTH ECONOMISTS
SAY YOU A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HELPING OF THE
PROJECT OVER THE AND THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT OF- ALL THESE
CODED OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE ANTICIPATING. GETTING
THINGS LIKE TRYING TO SOME OF
THE BE MENTAL HEALTH IMPACT-
INTO THE FUTURE OF KOBE SO- YOUR
TRYING TO WE'RE GOING TO BE WE
ARE GOOD I'M GOING TO BE
BUILDING A STRONG COLLABORATION
TO REALLY HARNESS ALL THIS
INFORMATION. OKAY AND- SINCE
THIS IS A BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HOW MUCH MONEY I KNOW IT'S I
DON'T SEE THIS IN THE REVISED
PRODUCTION THERE MIGHT BEEN
SOMETHING AND- SO HOW WHAT SO
GREAT PEOPLE DOING THIS
EVERYBODY. OUT HOW MUCH MONEY
WE'RE PUTTING INTO IT. INTO THIS
AND IS THAT ENOUGH. YEAH I
BELIEVE THE COMPOSED ON TOP
ABOUT PART IS IN THE CASE THEN
LOOKED. OF LOOKS IT HERE SURVEIL
. PART OF IT IS ALL. JUST
MEASURING THE OUTCOME SO.
IMPROVING OR OR EVERY EMAIL OF
THE DAY NOW ARE MORE. HOLD HOLD
YOU KNOW SEQUENCE. WAIT WHILE
WASTEWATER SURVEIL. AND SO MANY
IN THERE ALSO TO DO THE CLUB.
WITH OF. OKAY PART OF THE THAT'S
PART OF IT IT WOULDN'T PACKAGE
WHOLE PACKAGE. IS SIXTEEN
MILLION. OKAY ARE WELL- SB GOOD
IF WE CAN BREAK OUT THE LONG
CODE PORTION BUT IT'S A FRACTION
THAT SIXTEEN MILLION I WONDER
WHETHER THAT'S ENOUGH- WE- NO WE
AGREE WITH YOU ARE THE WAY THEY
WERE THINKING ABOUT IT IS REALLY
SITUATING- OURSELVES. TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. WE
ANTICIPATE MORE FUNDING WILL BE
COMING DOWN- TO DO READ JUST SO
WE'RE WE'RE WE WANT TO BE IN A
GOOD POSITION TO GO AFTER- THOSE
GRANT FUNDS WHEN THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE. OKAY AND THEN AGAIN
AS I SAID WE KNOW THERE IS
RESEARCH HAPPENING. CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO NATIONALLY AND BEING
BEING ABLE TO BEING ABLE TO
TAKE. MY NEEDS AND INTEGRATED
INTO POLICYMAKING ALL RIGHT WELL
MIKE MY CONCERN IS. WHY
APPRECIATE THEIR MAYBE CAN'T
FUNDING COMING. WERE RIGHT NOW
IN THE MIDDLE OF ANOTHER SPIKE
THAT'S HAPPENING MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE GET INFECTED AND RE
INFECTED. AND THAT WE DON'T
START COLLECTING. THE DATA NOW.
AND HAVE THE RE TO DO THAT-
WE'RE GONNA BE MISSING. HELLO OF
IT. NOW WE ALWAYS GET TRIED GET
TO LAY BUT RIGHT. WE HAVE PEOPLE
GETTING WITH LOTS OF RE
INFECTIONS AS WE'RE LEARNING
MORE ABOUT OUR CRIMES GET
INFECTED DEMOCRAT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU WON'T GET RE INFECTED.
APPARENTLY DOESN'T PROVIDE MUCH
PROTECTION GETTING INFECTED FROM
ACROSS AND GETTING RE INFECTED-
AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT'S ON THE
DATA CURRENTLY DATA SHOWING- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE GET MORE
INFECTIOUS OF VARIANTS. AND WE
NEED TO BE CAPTURING- WHO'S
INFECTED AND THEN IF THEY
DEVELOP LONG COVE IT SOMETIME SO
WE GET AT MORE ACCURATE DATA-
LONG COBIT ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW
AND WITH EACH VARIANT THERE MAY
BE DIFFERENT YOU KNOW IMPACTS IN
TERMS OF- ON LONG COAT AND IT OF
COURSE. THE IMPACT OF
VACCINATION ALLOW CODED WILL
CERTAINLY- STUDIES SHOW THAT IT
REDUCES LONG COVERED PRIVATE
ABOUT HALF BUT WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE. SO SO I I'M JUST SAYING
THAT WHILE THERE MAY BE GRANT ON
THE WAY WE SHOULD BE PUTTING
SOME FUNDING TO BE SURE WE CAN
GET AHEAD OF THOSE THAT BECOMES
PILE I GET THAT BECOMES DATA
THAT CAN BE FOLDED INTO FUTURE
GRANT PROJECTS BUT- I DON'T BE
SITTING HERE A YEAR LATER GOING-
WELL WE JUST GOT A GREAT AND NOW
. TO COLLECT THE DAY WE HAD A
WHOLE YEAR'S OF P. GET HUNG CO
AND AN WE'RE BY. YEAH SO- I
THINK TO- JUST IN. SO ABOUT THAT
SAY IS. WITH US BUT THE BUDGET
BUT JUST. THE EXPENDITURE
OVERSEE. FOR SO WE HAVE WITH
CALLED THE SEEK. OKAY SO IS
THERE ARE A LOT OF. HAS BEEN IN
THAT. IN COLLABORATIVE OR- WITH
THE CAR. OF UC HEALTH- THERE'S
THAT THERE ISN'T TO REALLY BIG.
ALL RIGHT THE EXAM AND I D. SO.
THAT IN INDIA WHAT YOU'RE- AND
SO THE BEES. ADDITIONAL I MEANT
SIXTY MILLION IS THAT ADDITION
TO. THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
WERE ALREADY EXPANDING ON COVERT
. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I'D TO BE
HELPFUL TO HAVE A- PICTURE OF
THAT- EXACTLY WHAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE AND WHAT
RESOURCES WE'RE PUTTING INTO IT
SO. I APPRECIATE THAT. YEAH
DON'T WE CAN GO TO. WOULD BE IT
WOULD BE BE ON WHAT THE BUDGET
HEARING IS ABOUT LEADERSHIP WEEK
WE CAN SUMMARIZE THOSE OKAY
RIGHT. OBVIOUSLY YOU BUDGET WILL
BE SURE WE ENOUGH RESOURCES
STATE RESOURCE OF PUTTING IT
OKAY. AND THEN THE ISSUE I KNOW
YOU TALK TO DEEDS. OF CAL ELSE.
AND HOW MANY OKAY LEAST COVER
PROBABLY OF THE TEST- GIVEN THAT
HAVE TO SEE. ARE FOOT THE FIFTY
FIFTH FIVE PER BUT WE HAVE THE
OTHER HALF. AND YOU KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT PARENTS KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT LOVE COVET PARENTS PARENTS
WANT TO KNOW IF THE KIDS MIGHT
GET INFECTED OR EXPOSED THEY MAY
HAVE. AT RISK FAMILY MEMBERS AT
HOME WITH THEIR CHILD NOT AT
RISK. AND US SO WE CAN ADD THAT
ONE POINT ONE BILLION. ARE WE
LOOKING AT- BE ABLE CONTINUE
FIND TESTING- PROGRAMS AND
SCHOOLS TO BE SURE WE DON'T
HAVE. TO LIMIT OUTBREAKS ARE-
INFECTIONS OF CHILDREN. AND
YOUTH IN SCHOOLS- YES. ARE
TESTING. VERY REAL BUS A BIGGER
DIFFERENCE. HAS BEEN AWAY FOR PC
. TEST AND- AT THE GENTILE.
AVAIL AND- MADE ME IT REALLY
IMPACTS RAINBOWS. OF AND
FAMILIES TO HAVE A- TO INTO.
TEST WELL- SO YEAH THERE'S OF.
THE CHALLENGE BEEN THAT SOME OF
THE SCHOOL TO FROM OPERATIONAL
PERSON- ARE. ARE YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT ON THEM. YEAH AND
SO WE'RE BUILT WHAT WE ARE.
COMPLETED WITH A TESTING THEY
NEED OKAY WELL I JUST KNOW HOW
MY MONEY OUT THAT WAY POINT.
BILL THAT WE'RE COMMITTING TO
HELPING SUPPORT SCHOOLS SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT WRITING. OUT OF
THEIR EDUCATIONAL FUNDS. FOR
TESTING. YES SO THE TOTAL FOR
THE- TEMPTING TO FIVE THIRTY. WE
HAVE TO BREAK WITH TO BREAK HOW
MY OF IT IS FOR SCHOOL OKAY AND
YES DOCTOR BAND THIS BRIGHTNESS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AGAIN- OF
THAT FIVE. A PORTION IS GOING TO
SCHOOL AT IS EIGHTY MILLION AND
THEN OF COURSE THE DOCTOR GUNN
MENTIONED THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR GO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TOWARD
SPENDING ON THOSE. HAS KICKED IN
GENERAL AS WELL. OKAY DAN CLEWS
CASKETS AND IT MAY GO TO SCHOOLS
. CORRECT OKAY SO THE EIGHTY
MILLION IS- TO SCHOOLS DIRECTLY
. TO SUPPORT THEIR VENDOR
PERSONNEL NEEDS OKAY ALL RIGHT
THE OTHER PERSON NEEDS IN THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION POLICE
PORTION THAT CAN GO TO ACTUALLY
PAYING FOR THE TESTS THEMSELVES.
OKAY CORRECT ALL RIGHT OKAY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN- AND
AGAIN FREESHEET THE DOES HAVE IS
LAST UP UNTIL HEALTH- THE THING
I ACTUALLY JUST WANT TO MENTION
I KNOW IT'S NOT IN THERE MAY
REVISED BUT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS BEFORE THE END OF PRECIADO
THE GOVERNOR KEEPING ITS
COMMITMENT TO. HERE FOR THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION TO HELP
SUPPORT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- BUT ALSO YOU KNOW
WE HAVE WE HAVE A WORK ISSUE
WHAT WE HAVE LEFT THE WORKFORCE
ISSUES BUT WE ALSO A PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE ISSUE. AND AND-
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN PROPOSALS- TO TRY
TO PROVIDE- MORE SUPPORT FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSONNEL- BOTH
LOCALLY AND AT THE STATE. AND
YOU KNOW THEN FORTUNATELY WE
KNOW THAT- PUBLIC AID. I MEAN
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE IS
SUFFERING FROM PTSD T. EVEN
GREATER AND GREATER RATES THAN
OUR FRONT LINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. WHO A RATE OF FOUR
SEPARATE HIGH RATES BECAUSE OF
THE STRESS OF TAKING CARE OF SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO ACTION FORTY
HAVE DIED MILLION DEATHS IN THIS
COUNTRY READY- BUT OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS HAVE BEEN YOU
KNOW HARASSED AND THREATENED AN-
ATTACKED AND- OVERSTRETCHED AND
SO FORTH. AND SO- I'M HOPING
THAT WE WOULD CONSULT THAT
ADMINISTRATION WOULD. CONSIDER
US SUPPORTING MORE SUPPORT SO
PRE SHEET THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR. BUILDING OUR
WORKFORCE BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
RETAIN OUR WORK FORCE. AND NOT
LOSE THE EXPERTISE THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE. AND SO. IT'S
PERHAPS CAN YOU JUST BRIEFLY
COMMENT ON THAT- YEAH THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS UP
YEAH WE REALLY APPRECIATE- WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE HAVE BEEN HAVE
BEEN TRAUMATIZED. AND THAT IS
THAT IS THAT THAT IS PART OF OUR
STRATEGIC APPROACH WITH THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH YOU KNOW
BUILDING THE SYSTEM WE DESCRIBE
IT IS BECOMING A HEALING
ORGANIZATION. ARE REALLY- TAKING
IT VERY SERIOUSLY OF HOW WE
DESIGN OUR WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MINIMIZE CHRONIC CHRONIC
TOXIC STRESS AND TRAUMA TO OUR
OUR WORKFORCE. AND WORKING
ACROSS ACROSS ACROSS OUR WITH
OUR PARTNERS A CALIFORNIA TO
REALLY. TO REALLY DESIGN SYSTEMS
THAT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. M. M. M.
APPLY IT WE WILL BE APPLYING
FOR- WHATEVER RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO REALLY ALSO BUILD
OUT OF WORK FOR SISTERS TOOK
THEIR THE NUMBERS ISSUE. YOU
KNOW RETREAT RECRUITING A
DIVERSE WORKFORCE KEEPING THEM
AND THEN AND THEN CREATING THE
WORKING CONDITIONS. THERE ARE
HEALING AND LESS DRAMATIC SO WE
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
OKAY THANK YOU ARE CERTAINLY- I
HOPE THAT THERE'S A PUBLIC
HEROES. WHICH I'M SUPPORT- THAT
I HOPE WE CAN FIND A WAY TO HELP
FIND- AND THEN FINALLY EXT IS
WORK- THE I GUESS IT'S TAKING.
THE A TECHNIQUE JUST BUT THE
POSITION. THAT ARE BEING
REDUCED- BUT EXPENDITURES VERY
FROM THE HEALTH OF THE SPECIAL
FUNDS AND IT'S IS THAT JUSTICE
FROM SPECIAL FUND THE GENERAL
FUND AND BUT THE BUT. WE'RE
STILL FUNDING THESE POSITIONS.
THAT'S CORRECT SENATOR PER HIGH
. BEAT THEIR WAS A CABLE ONE FOR
THE FIRST. PUBLIC HEALTH AND I
JUST. AND PART OF THAT WAS.
FUNDING TEN TO. FROM THE SPECIAL
FUNDS IN GENERAL FUND SO THEY
OKAY SORT OF COMPLETE THAT BUT
WE'VE ALREADY INCLUDED. GENERAL
PLAN FOR THOSE POSITIONS AND THE
EVIL ONE OKAY SO THERE'S NO
REDUCTION IN THE ACTUAL-
STAFFING FOR THE CURRENT THAT
THE PROPOSAL WOULD JUST SHIFTING
THE SOURCE OF FUNDING OKAY ALL
RIGHT JUST. CLARIFY THAT- SIGNED
UNDERSTAND OKAY- SO AS A LOT
MORE QUESTIONS BUT I'LL STOP
THERE FOR RIGHT NOW AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH MANAGER. THANK YOU
DON'T PAN AM THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOU'VE DONE FOR. PUBLIC HEALTH
ESPECIALLY TO THIS PANDEMIC.
LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NEED A WHOLE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I WILL BE PROVIDING A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE FED MAY
REVISION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS THESE ARE ONLY
HIGHLIGHTING SIGNIFICANT
ADJUSTMENT- ARE NOT INCLUSIVE OF
ALL THE REVISION PROPOSAL. THE
FIRST ITEM IS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL SOLUTION THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
FUNDING AT THE FRONT OF THE
DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESS THE WAIT LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS RETIREMENT TO BE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ON
FELONY CHARGES. WHO NEED
COMPANIES TWENTY RESTORATION AND
TREATMENT. THIS INCLUDED
IMPLEMENTING EARLY STABILIZATION
SERVICES TO PROMOTE
STABILIZATION OF I. FIFTY
DEFENDANTS TO INCREASE COMMUNITY
BASED. TREATMENT PLACEMENT.
EIGHTEEN CARE COORDINATION AND
INCREASED WEIGHT LIFT MANAGEMENT
. EXPANDING DIVERSION AND
COMMITTEE BASED REST FOR.
ESTABLISHING A NEW IN THE
PLACEMENT TERMINATION PANEL TO
FACILITATE TRANS TO FOR STATE
HOSPITAL PATIENTS. IMPLEMENTING
A COW I'VE YOU WERE. GROWTH CAP
AND AFFECTING PANEL OF THE
THIRTY LABOR FOR. THE MAIN. OUR
FLEX THIS ITEM THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSED BUDGET IS REPRESENTED
IN IN THE- BUDGET OF FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE POINT THREE.
GENERAL AND SEVENTY SIX VISION
AND TWO TWENTY THREE INCREASING
TO FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE
POINT NINE MILLION AND NINETY
FIVE POSITIONS AND. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX AND ON BUILDING.
OVERALL STRUCK WITH IN OF SIXTY
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION ON
BILLING AND THE TOTAL FOR THE
HIGHEST DEFLATION OVER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE NAY
REVISION UPDATES TO THIS
PROPOSAL ARE BASED UPON
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND NEEDS
IDENTIFIED DURING IMPLEMENTATION
PLANNING AND ALSO ADDS TO
ADDITIONAL IT SOLUTIONS. SOME OF
THE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
PREVIOUS PROPOSED SOLUTIONS
INCLUDE. FUNDING FOR SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY COSTS TO SUPPORT
PROVIDING EARLY STABILIZATION
SERVICES FOR AYE. UPDATES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. SCHEDULE
FROM THREE FOUR YEARS.
INCREASING THE FUND FOR AND-
FROM AN AVERAGE OF THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PER UNIT TWO
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PER UNIT. ADDING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT COUNTY A MINISTER
CONSISTENT WITH OVERHEAD RATE
ALLOWED BY NOT ACCOUNT. ADDING
FUNDING FOR COURT LIAISON
POSITIONS RECORDED WITH THE
COURTS TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS IN THE
COMMUNITY. INCREASING THE
REIMBURSEMENTS PAID TO SHERIFF
OR THEIR COST FOR AN ICED TEA WE
HAVE THE- FROM FIVE TO ONE
THOUSAND RATIONS. UPTICKS IN THE
EYES GROWTH ALSO INCLUDES A THE
BASELINE CHAIN TO THE STRUCTURE
AND ADDITIONAL MOTIVES ACCOUNT
ON THE STATUS OF IT TERMINATE.
THE TWO NEW SOLUTION SOMEWHERE
ADDED OUR WE SOURCES TO SUPPORT
I THINK THIS PLANNING ACCORDING
. WITH COUNTY TO ENABLE TO PLAN
CONTENT OF TREATMENT WHEN THE
AYE IF YOU THROW FROM JAIL. HI
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. PARTNER JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO PROVIDE TREATING
FAILING TO PROVE THE QUALITY OF
THE VALUE. USED FOR ICD. AND
DECISIONS REGARDING. THE NEED
FOR MEDICATION. THE NEXT ISSUE
IS MISSION BASED REVIEW.
DEVELOPMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSING. HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINETY AND TO TWO THREE DEFINE A
TERM. TO SUPPORT PLAN EFFORTS
BUILD EACH APARTMENT YOU EXPAND
FOR. RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO STATE
. RECURRENTLY HAS A RESIDENT
PROGRAM AT THAT STARTED IN TWO
ONE WITHOUT RESIDENTS AND SEVEN
ADDITIONAL RATHER WILL BE IN
THIS. THE NEXT ITEM IS MISSION
BASED FUTURE TEAM THE BUTTERFLY
WANT MULTI YOUR SEATS. ASSOCIATE
THE ACTION OF THE HIGHER PLAN OF
TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE POSITION
UNDER THIS FOR. THAT WERE
PRETTY. ON AUTHORIZED AND THE BY
. YEAR ON AND THIS IS DUE TO
TELL. THE PROPOSAL OFFERING AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN POINT
MILLION FOR A TOTAL OF EIGHTY
THREE MILLION FOR KOBE NINETEEN
DIRECT RESPONSE EXPENDITURES.
THE FUNDING ADJUSTMENT REFLECTS
INCREASED PERSONNEL SERVICES
OPERATING EXPENSES TESTING BASED
ON ACTUAL COSTS AND THE
CONTINUED USE OF THE NORWALK
ALTERNATE CARE FACILITY FOR
ADDITIONAL SIX MONTH. THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO PROPOSING
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND TWENTY SEVEN POINT
THREE. GEN IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING TO FUND THE CONVERSION OF
ONE EXISTING. RECOVERY UNIT AT
JUST CALLING GOT TO AN
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY FOR
DRAFT THE HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE
NEEDED FOR ITS AGING POP. ALL
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
RELATED KEY FOR. PROGRAM OPERATE
INCREASED COSTS FOR STAFFING AND
CON FOR THE CONDITIONAL RELIEF
AND EIGHTY P. PROGRAM. THE NEXT
LINE ARE A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
THE PRO INCLUDE. A RE
APPROPRIATIONS OF UNSPENT FUNDS
FOR FIVE ITEMS THAT- CONTINUE
FUNDING AVAILABLE THROUGH JUNE
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE
FIRST ITEM IS FOR FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION FOR THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER NETWORK TO CONTINUE
WITH THE PATIENT. OF A NETWORK
PROVIDER. TWELVE TWELVE POINT
ONE MILLION FOR THE MISSION
BASED REVIEW TREATMENT TEAM TO
COMPLETE PLANNING PROCUREMENT
AND INSTALLATION OF TRAILERS AND
MODULAR OFFICE FURNISHINGS FOR
OFFICE SPACE FOR THE TREATMENT
TEAM. FOUR POINT ONE MILLION
PRICEY REEVALUATION TO CONTINUE
REEVALUATION OF LIFE DEFENDANT
ACCORDING SERVICE DELIVERY AND
REIMBURSE DELCATH. FIVE MILLION
FOR IT DIVERSION TO CONTINUE
FUNDING FOR DIVERSE PROGRAM WHAT
. AND FIFTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION FIVE FIFTHS LISTENS TO
SUPPORT FURTHER IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE EYES SOLUTIONS PROPOSED
THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL
BUDGET. DIRECTOR KALINDA AND I
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SHIDA. THANK YOU SENATOR
ACCORD TO SHEILA ALLEGE
ANALYST'S- WE ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH REVIEWING THE
DEPARTMENT'S ME REVISION
PROPOSALS IN PARTICULAR THE
PROPOSED TO JUDGE I JUST TO THE-
I TEA SO PACKAGE BUT WE WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH WE IDENTIFY
ISSUES FLAG THE- OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ON. THE ISTC THAT TO
FOUR HUNDRED SO ONE. AND IS THAT
GOING TO BE THE EXPERT. WITH THE
MONEY TO PAY FOR THE ACTUAL
EXPANSION OF BREAD BEDS BRICK
AND MORTAR- INCLUDING CHRISSY BY
FIVE THOUSAND OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS OR IS THAT ALSO. FOR
STAFFING AND NEW SERVICES-
COMBINATION. IT WOULD BE A
COMBINATION IT DOES PROVIDE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS US
COSTS. IN THE IN THE BEING AND
PER- THE IN BEING AN EXPANSION
OF PER AND MORTAR BEDS. OF IT
WOULD BE A- PROVIDING UNIT-
WOULD BE IT WOULD HAVE EIGHT
BEDS FOR HOME THAT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PER UNIT- THE
SEVEN FIFTY DOLLARS PER UNIT OF
INVESTMENT. OKAY IN THEN CAN YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
TIMELINE WITH AT- MANAGE THAT
BACKLOG IS THIS PREDICTED THEN
TO ACTUALLY ALLOW THE BACKLOG.
THIS IS A OF PROJECTED TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT BACKLOG- I
WILL DEFER TO OTHER CLINTON OR
FOR THE- WELCOME DIRECTOR. YOUR
IMMEDIATE. YEAH STEPHANIE AND
THAT AND FOR DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITALS AND WITH RESPECT TO
THE QUESTION- ABOUT AND HOW THIS
MIGHT ADDRESS THE BACKLOG THIS
AND THEN I USED TO SOLUTION YOU
KNOW WAS- IN OUT OF THE- THE-
GROUP THAT WE DID LAST. WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WHICH REALLY LOOK
OUTSIDE AND RECALL AND TALK
ABOUT AND DISCUSSED DIFFERENT-
IDEAS ON HOW WE COULD FURTHER
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES RELATED
TO THE I. S. T. I'M- CHUCK A
BACKLOG AND ULTIMATELY THAT
PROPOSAL REALLY- IN TOTAL IT
DOES A NUMBER OF THINGS AND- IT
REALLY LOOKS TO. ADDRESS THE-
THAT THE WAITING. AND TO ENJOY
THAT WE'RE BILL. ACCESS TO SIR-
AND WITH THE GOAL OF IT MEETING
THE TWENTY EIGHT DAY TIMELINE
THAT THE COURT HAS- HAS SET FOR
US TO BEGIN- SUBSTANTIVE
TREATMENT SERVICES BUT IT ALSO
IN ADDITION TO THE BALLOT.
REALLY IT'S THROUGH THE
EXPANSION OF THE COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION AND DIVERSION I'M
PORTION OF. THE OF THE PROPOSAL
REALLY IS FOCUSED ON GIVING
PROVIDING TREATMENT IN A VERY
MEANINGFUL WAY DIFFERENT THAN
DOING RESTORATION OF COMPETENCY
PRETEND RETURNING SOMEONE BACK
TO COURT SO THAT THEY CAN BASE
OTHER CHARGES THAT ME. SB OF
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
DIVERSION REALLY IS AROUND. AND
JEAN THE ARK OF THE OF THE THAT
WE- THERE WAS- IN REALLY
ALLOWING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECEIVE COMMUNITY BASED
TREATMENT GET CONNECTED TO
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT LONG
TERM COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT
SO THAT- WE CAN PREVENT THEM
FROM CYCLING IN AND OUT OF. JAIL
THANK YOU I KNOW THIS. IMPORTANT
WORK AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR A COUPLE
YEARS NOW IT'S NICE TO SEE
THINGS FINALLY START TO COME
TOGETHER AT. WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT THE YOU'RE RIGHT RESPONSE TO
COVERT NINETEEN CAN YOU JUST
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THE
AYE AND I HAD A CHANCE TO VISIT
NAPA HOW WAS I GOING WITH YOUR
OUTBREAKS AND CONTAINMENT AND-
AND I KNOW IT'S A- HUGE TASK TO
KEEP YOUR- RESIDENTS. AS WELL AS
- STAFF SAFE. THANK YOU YES
INDEPENDENT MAKES CERTAINLY HAS
PRESENTED A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
FOR US THAT THE DEPARTMENT- AND
THE DEPARTMENTS AKE AND NUMBER
OF ACTIONS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS YOU KNOW IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH THEY PROVIDED A
LOT OF GUIDANCE AND I'M TO US AS
ME IMPLEMENTED R. AND COMING
NINETEEN KIND OF INFECTION
CONTROL PROTOCOLS AND- REALLY
IMPROVED- THE COPING. NOT ONLY
BEEN WE HAVE TO IMPLEMENT
INFECTION CONTROL PROTOCOLS THAT
REALLY CHANGE THE OPERATIONS OF
THE DEPARTMENT QUITE A BAD IN
AND AS WE SEEING ITS IMPACT ON
OUR INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
SOLUTIONS WAIT LIST AS WELL- BUT
IT IS- ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW I WAS
B. AS THE PANDEMIC SURGES IN THE
COMMUNITY WE CERTAINLY. FEEL
THAT SURGE WITHIN OUR HOSPITALS
AS WELL BUT WE HAD- AS SEEN THAT
LESSON OVER TRYING AS FAR AS
KIND OF. THAT REALLY- THE HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT WERE SEEN AS FAR
OUT AS YOU KNOW AS SIGNIFICANT-
ILLNESS AS A RESULT O THE OVE
AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE DO. HAVE A
HAVING A HIGH RATE OF
VACCINATION WITHIN BOTH OF OUR
PATIENTS AND STAFF OVER 80% FOR
BOTH PATIENTS AND STAFF. AND WE
HAVE- YOU KNOW WE HAVE ACCESS TO
THERAPEUTICS- WE HAVE YOU KNOW-
STRONG INFECTION CONTROL
PROTOCOLS SO. IT CERTAINLY IS A
VERY DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE
SOMEWHAT WE EXPERIENCE EARLY ON
IN THE PANDEMIC BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY WITH EACH VARIANT
THAT COMES THROUGH I KNOW AND
EXPERIENCE AND REQUIRES
ADJUSTMENTS TO WHAT WE'RE DOING
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO- THE NEW.
CHANGING CIRCUMSTANCES. THANK
YOU FOR W. NOW I THINK THAT KIND
OF THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU MUCH
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TOBY YOU IN ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMISSION- WE HAVE IN THE
MAY REVISE ONE ITEM. THAT IS
REALLY TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT A
TECHNICAL ISSUE IN THE WAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
STATE TRACKS POSITIONS AND SO
THAT ITEM IS TO REDUCE BY SIX
POSITIONS JUST TO ADDRESS AN
OVERSIGHT IN TERMS OF HOW WE
TRACK POSITIONS. IN ADDITION TO
THAT ITEM THE COMMISSION ALSO
HAS FIVE PROPOSALS THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISE THAT
WITH YOUR PERMISSION I WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT TO YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. PLEASE THANK YOU.
SO FIRST THE COMMISSION WOULD
LIKE TO PURSUE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO MODIFY THE
PROVISIONS OF SB EIGHTY TWO SB
TEACH YOU YOU MAY RECALL. IS A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR YOUR GRANT
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
CRISIS RESPONSE FUNDING TO
COUNTIES. THAT THE PARAMETERS OF
THAT PROGRAM AT THE MOMENT
RESTRICT OUR ABILITY TO USE
THOSE FUNDS SIMPLY TO PROVIDE
PERSONNEL GRANTS TO COUNTY'S.
AGAIN PRIMARILY FOR CRISIS
RESPONSE OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
IN OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTIES WE'VE LEARNED. THAT
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AROUND CRISIS
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. AND AS PART OF
THAT WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND THE USE OF THOSE DOLLARS
TO FOCUS ON MORE UPSTREAM
OPPORTUNITIES. TO EXPAND THE USE
OF THOSE DOLLARS TO WORK WITH A
BROADER ARRAY OF PARTNERS
CURRENTLY THE FUNDING CAN ONLY
BE GRANTED THE COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN CRISIS PREVENTION
AND INTERVENTION OPPORTUNITIES
AS WELL. EXPANSIONS USE THOSE
FUNDS FOR THINGS OTHER THAN
PERSONALITY RANTS AND AS PART OF
THAT TO BE ABLE TO USE THESE
DOLLARS MORE FLEXIBLY IN SOME
INSTANCES. I REQUIREMENTS IN
GRANTS WHICH IS NOT CURRENTLY
ALLOWED AND IN VERY LIMITED
INSTANCES TO BE ABLE TO RELEASE
THESE DOLLARS THROUGH NON
COMPETITIVE PROCUREMENTS
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING WITH VERY
SMALL COUNTIES AND SMALL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT QUITE FRANKLY REALLY
STRUGGLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
COMPETITIVE PROCUREMENT
PROCESSES. SO THAT'S OUR FIRST
REQUEST IS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THE TRAIN OF A
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW
MODIFICATIONS OF THE SPD TO
YOUR- PROGRAM IN THOSE WAYS.
MEDITATE QUESTIONS OR JUST GO TO
THE OTHER REMAINING ITEMS- HIS
CLEAR THE REMAINING ITEMS I
THINK. THANK YOU. AS AS YOU I
THINK YOU KNOW HOW OVER THE
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR HAVE AUTHORIZED THE
COMMISSION TO. RELEASE FUNDS FOR
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY FOR TO
SUPPORT THE ABILITY OF OUR
PARTNERS AS PEERS. FOR AT. TO
GET THREE INCH OR TO ADDRESS
THIS AROUND THE- SERVETTE
FORENSICS. I'M COMMISSION IS
ASKING A NEW FIVE. FIRST TO
STRENGTHEN OUR OB. TO THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS OF EMMA
AND- TO ADVOCATES. HELLO YOU
KNOW SEEN IN. OF BOTH INTO. IN
OUR IMMIGRANT IF YOU COMMUNITIES
BUT ALSO AN ESCALATION OF NEEDS
PARTICULARLY WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AFGHANISTAN AND
UKRAINE AND SO THE COMMISSION
WOULD LIKE TO DOUBLE FUNDING FOR
IT TO SUPPORT OUR ABILITY TO
ENGAGE WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT ARE DOING
OUTREACH EDUCATION TRAINING AND
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES. SIMILARLY WITH THE
TREMENDOUS INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH WE SEE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ELEVATE THE
VOICES YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS WERE MAKING. AROUND
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH ACTUALLY
ARE FORMED BY YOUNG PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO SERVE. THERE'S THAT
EVIDENCE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND OTHER COUNTIES WHERE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE COMING TOGETHER TO
REALLY INFORM THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN THESE
LOCAL AGENCIES IN THE COMMISSION
SEES AN OPPORTUNITY. TO FURTHER
THOSE THOSE PATHWAYS OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
TO BEST RESPOND TO THEIR NEEDS.
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
AGAIN THAT'S THE STANDARD LEVEL
OF FINDING THE COMMISSION LEASES
THROUGH THESE GRANT PROGRAMS.
AND THAT WOULD FOCUS ON
STAKEHOLDER SUPPORTER OUR
PARTNER SUPPORT- WITH EMPHASIS
ON WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH AND THEN A
POSITION ONE POSITION TO HELP
IMPLEMENT THOSE. PROGRAMS OVER
TIME. OUR OUR THIRD RECORD. IS
REALLY TIGHT THE PRIME THAT
STATE MADE IN TERMS OF WORKING
WITH PEERS. I IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS THE STATE HAS IT IS
WORKING TO CERTIFY THE ROLE OF
PEERS IN OUR COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM WE'RE SEEING. A
GREAT ACCEPTANCE AND EXPANSION
OF THE ROLE OF PEERS ON THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SIDE. WE ALSO
SEE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE
TO EMBRACE THE ROLE OF PEERS IN
TERMS OF. BRINGING MENTAL HEALTH
CONSUMERS INTO CONVERSATIONS
AROUND HOW WE DESIGN SHAPE FUND
AND DELIVER PROGRAMS. AND SO
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR HIS
SUPPORT TO WORK WITH THE
CALENDAR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HUMAN RESOURCES. TO REALLY
EXPLORE HOW THE STATE COULD
EMBRACE A LEADERSHIP ROLE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CONSUMERS AS PART
OF OUR STATE GOVERNMENT SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT STATE
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES ALSO HAVE
THE BENEFIT. OF THE KINDS OF
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR. LANGUAGE TO
DIRECT THAT WORK AS WELL AS SOME
STAFF AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
SPEND THE NEXT FEW YEARS REALLY
FIGURING OUT HOW CALIFORNIA CAN.
TRULY EMBRACE APPEARS AS PART OF
OUR STRATEGY TO ADDRESS NO
HEALTH NEEDS IN CALIFORNIA. OUR
OUR FOURTH PROPOSAL IN. IS
SIMILAR TO A LITTLE BIT THERE
BUT SIMILAR. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS I'VE BEEN FOR YOU MANY
TIMES YOU WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW
WE USE DATA. HOW WE ARE TRYING
TO TRANSITION FUNDING AWAY FROM
AUGMENTING KIND OF CLASSIC
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TOWARDS
INCENTIVE FUNDS. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO BUILD OUT LEARNING
COMMUNITIES AROUND EARLY
PSYCHOSIS AROUND USED PROPERTY
AROUND SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH-
WE'RE WE'RE SUPPORTING
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO THINGS
LIKE PSYCHIATRIC ADVANCE
DIRECTIVES. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE FIND IS MUCH OF
THIS WORK IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
IT FOR A LOCAL PARTNERS TO
ENGAGE WITH- QUITE OFTEN OUR
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE SHARING WITH
US. THAT THEY THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR TRAINING AND GUIDANCE AMOUNT
AROUND HOW THEY TOO CAN BE MORE
PERFORMANCE ORIENTED- WHAT KINDS
OF RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE AND
SO SOME OF THE FINE THAT YOU
PROVIDED US IN THE PAST HAVE
ALLOWED US. TO PROVIDE THAT KIND
OF TRAINING WE'RE ASKING FOR
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING TO ACTUALLY LAUNCH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PERFORMANCE
FELLOWSHIP. IT WOULD BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
COUNTY AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
BUILDING OFF OF WORK AT THE
STATE HAS DONE IN THE PAST THAT
LOOKS MORE BROADLY AT PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION BUT IN THIS
INSTANCE REALLY FOCUSES ON THE
CORE CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE IN
OUR HERO HEALTH COMMUNITY. AT SO
THAT WE CAN STRENGTHEN THE
CAPACITY OF OUR LOCAL PARTNERS.
TO REALLY DO THE DATA WORK TO DO
THE ANALYSIS TO RECOGNIZE COST
DRIVERS TO MAKE MORE EFFECTIVE
USE OF IMAGES INNOVATION FINDS.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AS LAUNCH
FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN CREATE A
FELLOWSHIP WORK WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS. AND IT AS WELL THIS
WOULD BE FOUND IN A UNIVERSITY
THAT HAS A- HISTORY THESE ARE
INTENT. I WORKING IN THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION SPACE AND THE
IDEAS THAT OVER THE NEXT FIVE OR
SIX YEARS. THAT FUNDING WOULD
ACTUALLY SHIP FROM THIS ONE
TIME- DOLLARS THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR TOWARDS REVENUE BASED- I
REVENUE THAT THAT THAT THE
PROBLEM GENERATED THROUGH
CHARGING TUITION FOR PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE FELLOWSHIP.
AND ALLOW. IS INCREASE THE COME
IS THAT TO COME. ON FOR. AND
WHEREAS FOR POSITION TO ALLOW US
TO ADD A LEGISLATIVE LIAISON WHO
CAN HELP US SUPPORT THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING CONVERSATION
HAVING THE LEGISLATURE. IN JUST
A STRENGTHENED OUR ABILITY
OVERALL TO ENGAGE IN SUPPORT
POLICY DSCUSSIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE CHANCE TO
OBSERVE THOSE FIVE. TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU'RE STEALING. HELLO. THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN- CORY
THIS YEAR WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS TO RAISE WITH- THE
OASES ME REVISION PROPOSAL- SEE
THIS AS LARGELY A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT THAT IS THAT IS
REASONABLE- REGARDING THE OTHER-
PROPOSALS AT THE L. A. C.
PRESENTED- ONCE WITH YOUR DEALS
BECOME AVAILABLE RELATED TO
THOSE PROPOSALS WE'D BE HAPPY TO
REVIEW AND- FOLLOW UP THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON THEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I AND OUR- MISTER
ORBITZ WAS TAKING NOTES DURING
YOUR PRESENTATION- DR OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON TO OUR FINAL ISSUE FOR THE
DAY- CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE. AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS NICK OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL
SPEAK TO THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR REGENERATIVE
MEDICINE I'M JOINED TODAY BY
FIRMS GENERAL COUNSEL KEVIN
MARKS WILL BE AVAILABLE AS WELL
TO ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ON THIS PROPOSAL.
CALIFORNIANS ARE TWO VERY
MEDICINE REQUESTS SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. TWO MILLION IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR THREE
MILLION AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND FIVE MILLION AND TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN. FROM LIFE. AND
ROYALTIES FUND FOUR TOTAL OF
FIFTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS. TO
DEVELOP AND ESTABLISH AN
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS WHO LACK THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
TO PARTICIPATE AND CIRM FUNDED
CLINICAL TRIALS. IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE STAFF WORK A
PROPOSED A PROGRAM SCOPING
REQUIREMENTS DISCERNS GOVERNING
BOARD. THE INDEPENDENT CITIZENS
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE FOR APPROVAL
DISCOVERING GAP ANALYSIS WILL BE
CONDUCTED TO DETERMINE PATIENT
NEEDS ALGAL SERVICES AND
EXPENSES AND AVOID DUPLICATION
OF OTHER PROGRAMS- BASIC SERVICE
WITH THEN BE LAUNCH IN TWENTY
THREE TO FOUR AND THEN WILL BE
EXPANDED IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
SERVICES WILL BE PROVIDED BY AN
EXISTING PATIENT SUPPORTS
ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD BE
CHOSEN THROUGH A COMPETITIVE
FACT. THE PROPOSAL MADE THOSE
THAT REQUIREMENTS TOP OF THE
FORTY WHICH ALLOWS ARMS USED BY
AND- REVENUE. TO REIMBURSE COST
PARTICIPATING IN CM FUNDED
CLINICAL TRIALS. ARE LESLIE ONE
THING I WANT TO KNOW VERY
QUICKLY AND EARLIER VERSION OF
THIS PROPOSAL HAD A TYPO IT
SAID. THREE MILLION PROPOSED IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND FIVE
MILLION AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
THAT IT SHOULD READ AS THREE
MILLION AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND FIVE MILLION AND TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN. THIS HAS BEEN
CORRECTED AN UPDATED ON THE
OFFICE WEBSITE AS OF TODAY- SO
WITHOUT THE DEPARTMENT I
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CLARIFICATION- RESPECT ANYTHING
ON THIS. OKAY FOR ANY PARTICULAR
THE LARGEST PANEL OFFICE. AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSAL- IT'S INTEND TO AND
- PROVISIONS OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN FROM TWENTY TWENTY AND-
AS REPAIRS TO BE MAKING GOOD
FAITH EFFORTS IN IMPLEMENTING
THAT REQUIREMENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT I WOULD
AGREE. WITH A PATH. HI SIR AND
AGREE WITH THE WITH THE
PROPOSAL'S IT'S A GOOD YOU OF
THE FUNDS I AM CURIOUS- GIVEN
RESEARCH PRODUCED BY ACE NOW
THAT CIRM HELP SUPPORT AND WE'RE
ALSO WORKING TOWARD BUILDING
CAPACITY IN THE STATE TO.
PRODUCE MEDICATIONS SPECIFIC
MORE SPECIFICALLY GENERIC
MEDICATIONS BUT PRODUCE MORE
MEDICATIONS. DO YOU SEE SOMETIME
IN THE FUTURE THAT- THE
LICENSING FOR DISCOVERIES TO
RELATE THE SERMON THAT RESULT IN
THERAPEUTICS THAT THE STATE
WOULD THEREFORE HAVE ACCESS OR
THE LICENSE. TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE. THAT COST MEDICATIONS
FOR CALIFORNIA- READ. I WOULD
DEFER TO MY CALLING ON THIS-
THANK YOU HAVE A MARGINAL
COUNSEL SERVED. YOU KNOW IT'S
INTEREST PROPER AND WHAT WE'VE
YET TO CONSIDER ITS THOSE
DOWNSTREAM- OPPORTUNITIES FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO GENERATE A COST
EFFECTIVE. FOR THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WILL DEFINITELY
TAKE THAT INTO. OKAY NOW I JUST
THAT I MEAN OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT
THERE YET WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD
THAT CAPACITY BUT AS WE LOOK AT
INVESTMENTS TOGETHER- CERTAINLY
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE
LIKE YOU'RE PROPOSING IS VERY
IMPORTANT VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT- BUT HOW FAR THAT SYSTEMS
GO DEPENDS ON THE COST OF THE
ACTUAL TREATMENT AND WE ALSO
WILL BE SURELY- TRY TO. MAKE AT
LEAST FOR CALIFORNIA- TAXPAYER
TO THE TO WHO'S ACTUALLY
INVESTED IN THESE DISCOVERIES
THAT THEY ALSO ACCESS THESE
TREATMENTS SO- AGAIN APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU. YOU'RE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY FROM THAT
CONCLUDES THE PRESENTATIONS FOR
TODAY- WE THINK THE DEPARTMENTS
AND EVERYBODY FOR THEIR-
PREPARATIONS- AND WE NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS WE WILL START
HERE AND MEETING ROOMS TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED I SEE OUR FIRST
PERSON IS UP. PLEASE PROCEED
FURTHER GOOD AFTERNOON AND
MICROBES IN HERE ON THE HAVE
QUEST DIAGNOSTICS A CLINICAL LAB
PROVIDER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND JUST REALLY WANT
TO- ALIGNED MY COMMENTS WITH
DOCTOR PAN HE HE STATED THE
BEST- THE AB NINETY CATS HAPEN
IN TWENTY ELEVEN- ALL THE NET
ALL THE PROVIDERS TOOK TOOK THE
HAIR CUT AND TOOK THE HIT AND-
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME AND WE YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO A SPOT
WHERE. YOU TO YOU TWO ARE GOING
TO BE GONE AND NOBODY SITTING IN
YOUR SEATS WILL EVEN REMEMBER
THESE TOOK PLACE WE REALLY NEED
TAKE CARE OF THIS FOR PROVIDE
AND WILL INDUSTRY WORLDWIDE
YOU'RE HERE SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS ROBSON. NEXT
PERSON PLEASE HI GOOD AFTERNOON
BETH AS GOOD AS A STATE COUNCIL
PRETTY MUCH ARE BY KNOWLEDGE A
US IN- PANDER MARC HAS REAL TO
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE AS PART
OF THE COMPANY CAN'T WAIT
COALITION LOOKING FORWARD TO
SING THE NATIONAL TEST MENTAL
EIGHTY SIX MILLION TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION- AS RELATES TO THE
CHARACTER PULLS ALL WE CONTINUE
TO REVIEW THE PROPOSAL- AND I'M
PARTICULAR WANT TO KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF SEEING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO SUPPORT. OUR COUNTY
IS- THEY WORKED COMMENT HER
COURT PROJECT MISSION SURE
THERE'S- SIGNIFICANT OF THOSE
REFERENCES TO HOW WE ARE BECAUSE
PUBLIC DOCUMENTATION OF ALL OF
THE HEARINGS A PROCESS T. AS
UNLESS IT'S A SKILLED NURSING
FINANCING FIRST OF ALL I THINK
CASTANER EGGMAN AND THE SENATE
FOR INCLUDING- SCHOOL NURSE
FINANCING BOARD AS PART OF US IN
A PRIORITY IS A WEEK BEFORE TWO.
PAGE NOT PUT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE. JENNIFER HAAS I'LL
BE HAPPY TO. THIS I HOPE SALUKIS
. AND LIKE TO COME IN A ON OF
THE ASSIST ON TO ITEMS- THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL.
TO NURSING FIND REFER AND ALL
THE INTERMEDIATE CARE FOR.
DEVELOPED LATEST. REMEMBER A
PROPOSED. AT FIRST I CAN'T IS
EXTRA. I JUST. AND UNFORTUNATE
MOST OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR SENATE
. REPORT REFORM PROPOSALS
OUTLINED BY THE DEPARTMENT. AS A
REPRESENTS A 6% MEDICARE RATE
CUTS TO NURSING HOMES. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL RESPECTFULLY
DOES LITTLE TO REFORM NURSING
HOMES AND THAT IT FAILS TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY.
FOR HOMES TO REMAIN VIABLE LET
ALONE MOVE BEYOND THE PAST YOU
KNOW PASSED DEVASTATING COBIT
PANDEMIC. THE PROPOSAL RENAMES
WHAT'S CURRENTLY CALLED THE
QUALITY BONUS PROGRAM. AND THEN
A RATHER THAN REFORM IT A
PROPOSES TO PENALIZE FACILITIES
ARE UNABLE TO MEET CERTAIN
BENCHMARKS- THAT A RELATIVE TO
POSSIBLY THE SAME QUALITY
BENCHMARKS THAT WILL BE IN THIS
NEW. RENAMED PROGRAM ESPECIALLY
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES TO
EFFECTIVELY MEET THOSE NEW
BENCHMARKS- CALF IS PROPOSED
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE MEDICAL
FUNDING FOR- FORMULA
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO LABOR
COSTS. WE HOPE THE CHAIR AND THE
SUB COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
ENCOURAGE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
RETHINK. THEIR PROPOSAL TO
BETTER ADDRESS THE SIGNIFICANT
LABOR COSTS. AND LASTLY KAPPA
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE CURRENT
10% RATE INCREASE FOR ICF. DD
AGES AND ENDS UP FOR ONE MORE
YEAR- WERE ALSO HAPPY TO SEE
THAT THE FACILITIES INTEGRATION
INTO THE CAL IN PROGRAM IS
PROPOSED TO BE PROPOSED- TO BE
POSTPONED BY SIX MONTHS. WE AND
OUR ASKED HOPING THAT COULD BE A
FULL YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MAKE PERSON. PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT WAS A- AS
YOU CAL. I THINK YOU'VE LOCKED
TO COMMENT TODAY- JUST WANNA-
FIRST RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROUND
RETENTION PAY FOR HOSPITAL AND
NURSING HOME WORKERS. I'M REALLY
. TO MAKE SURE THAT RETAIN
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE AS YOU SEE
A NUMBER OF. PROPOSAL ROUND
WORKFORCE THAT WE THINK ARE
CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
CONTINUE DELIVER CARE. AND LOOK
FOR A FOR THE CONVERSATIONS ON A
PROPOSAL. AND THEN ALSO I JUST
WANT TO ENCOURAGE ALTHOUGH NOT
ACCRUED IN THE MAY REVISE
ENCOURAGED INVESTMENT IN THE
PRIMARY CARE WORKFORCE. THROUGH
OUR PROPOSAL AROUND ENHANCE.
CLINICALLY INTEGRATED PROGRAM
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKC ELSE TO SPEAK HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATORYOU THERE. YES I AM
OKAY HOW MANY PEOPLE DO WE HAVE
IN THE FALL AND THE QUEUE. AT
THIS POINT TWENTY ONE OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S HAVE THE
FIRST CALLER PLEASE. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
ASK. AND MAKE A COMMENT- PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND FIRST
WE'LL TAKE A COMMENT FROM LINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE BORNEMANN
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP WE THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR RICK MEDICAID
RECRUITING TRAINING CERTIFYING
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND NEW
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
ALSO REQUEST THAT CHILD HEALTH
AND DEVELOPMENT. WHAT THE
INVESTMENT IN THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE LAST YEAR HOWEVER
WITHOUT A CLEAR PLAN OR
DEDICATED FUNDING IT WILL NOT
FOR BEING CRITICAL NEED FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS. WE
RECOMMEND EXPANDING INFANT AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
AND TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
INVESTMENT WITH NO LESS THAN TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND AND- WE
APPRECIATE THE FACTS INCLUSION
OF CONTINUOUS MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO FIVE
IN YOUR PRIORITIES. AND WE
ENCOURAGE RETENTION OF THE
POLICY IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
FINALLY THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL SERVICES
PROGRAM BUDGET REQUEST TO ENSURE
THAT MEDIC CALPERS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH SERVICES.
BREASTFEEDING SUPPORT AND OTHER
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THROUGHOUT
THE NEW TWELVE MONTH POST
PREGNANCY PERIOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THAT'S BECAUSE
HE'S ACTUALLY A MINUTE SO AGAIN
REMINDER- ONE MINUTE TESTIMONY
IF YOU WISH TO READ MORE
TESTIMONY FEEL FREE TO USE
PLEASE SEND YOUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE-
MODERATE PLEASE BRING ON THE
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU. NEXT
HEADLINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON WENT AWAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON MON PARTY
WE SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE
DELIVERY IMPERSONATE READ AFTER
STEP POLITICAL COVERAGE MEDICARE
NAVIGATOR FUNDING PERMANENTLY
EXTENDING PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY AND GRANT FROM
FICTION TO LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MUST THE POST
CARE COURT BINDING AND ALONG
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP OPPOSED TO REDIRECTING
FUNDS FROM HELPING LEAD PLACING
CHILDREN TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
NEW COMPUTER SYSTEM WE ALSO KNOW
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS MISSING
FROM THE NEIGHBOR VISION TO
REQUEST FUNDING TO UPDATE. THE
MEDIC HOW SHARE COST PROGRAM
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES WITH INCOMES LIKELY
ABOUT THE FREE MEDICARE ELEMENTS
ARE EXPECTED TO LIVE ON SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
HIGHLIGHTING THE URGENT NEED TO
INCREASE THE MAINTENANCE NEEDS
INCOME LEVEL WE ALSO REQUEST FOR
THE SIXTY FIVE FUNDING
IMPLEMENTING MEDICAID EXPANSION
TO ALL. INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS.
ASSEMBLY PREVENTING AGE OUT. THE
SHARES AND WE ARE LETTER THANK
YOU THANK. PASS IT BACK TO WE
HAVE. THANK NEXT CARPENTER. AND
HELP LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE AHEAD. I'M FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI SORRY HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GET IN PILOT
ON BEHALF JUSTICE IN AGING WELL
WE APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL TO
IMPROVE ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY
OF MEDICAL PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A KEY PIECE MISSING FOR
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. WE WOULD URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE SENATE TO
PRIORITIZE REFORMING THE MEDICAL
SURE POP PROGRAMS BY RAISING THE
MAINTENANCE NEED INCOME LEVEL
210038% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL THE RULES FOR THE PROGRAM
AND UP AND UPDATED SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND THERE
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES BEING FORCED TO
LIVE ON SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH ORDERED ACCESS AND MEDICAL
CARE. UNDER YES THE PROPOSED TBL
ANDERSON SO THE FINANCING REFORM
WITH YOUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL WHICH FOR THE TO
INCREASE PAYMENT THE SAUDIS
WITHOUT HAVING A PLAN IN PLACE
TO IMPROVE QUALITY OR EQUITY OF
CARE ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR CONTINUED
OPPOSITION TO CARE COURT AND THE
FUNDING BECAUSE THE NAY REVISION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK HAVE
LINED. ONE PLACE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SENATOR EGGMAN AND DOCTOR
PANTAGES AND JDS ON BEHALF OF
KAISER PERMANENTE HEY WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE HTS THE
PROPOSED AND NEWLY UPDATED MAY
BE VICE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
PRIMARY PERMITTING THE
DEPARTMENT TO ENTER INTO DIRECT
CONTACT WITH HAD THEIR PERMANENT
GIFT FROM MEDICAID HEALTH
SERVICES. ALTHOUGH IT A
CAREFULLY BALANCED APPROACH WILL
ALLOW K<c.cyan> TO ADVANCE HEALTH</c>
EQUITY AND INCREASE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY CARE FOR A BROADER
NUMBER OF BENEFICIARIES. IN A
WAY THAT REDUCES ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY AND IS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT AND COMPLEMENT THE LOCAL
DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE ASK THAT
THIS PROPOSAL BE INCLUDED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
WE APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION ON THE CAR CAR
MOBILE TODAY WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
TWO KEY POINTS REGARDING
RESOURCES AND FINING FIRST FOR
CARE FOR TO BE SUCCESSFUL MODEL
AND ISSUE THE GOLD MORE ACCESS
TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
THE PROPOSAL MIGHT GET COMPANIES
I COUNTY RESOURCE THAT. ADEQUATE
AND SUSTAINABLE FUNDING WILL BE
NEEDED PROP MULTIPLE COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS WILL HAVE NEW AN
EXPANDED ROLE FOR PROPOSED
APPROACH SECONDLY GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS PARADIGM SHIFT
IN THE FAR REACHING CONSEQUENCES
OF THE CHARACTER ALTHOUGH WE
BELIEVE THE PAST EXCEPT FOR
IMPLEMENTERS MORE IMPORTANTLY
FOR THOSE WHO FEEL THE BENEFIT
FROM HER COURT PURPOSES. MUST BE
GROUNDED IN A COUPLE TRANSPARENT
AND INCREMENTAL PIZZA MODEL
PARTLY COUNTIES RECOMMEND THAT
THESE AND STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CARE
PROGRAM WITHIN A NATIONAL COHORT
COHORT. OF WILLING HOW YOU
SELECTED FOR EARLY ADOPTION. I
THINK THAT'S BECAUSE PARKOUR AND
THE OFFICE. RECORD THAT HEALTH
DEVELOP AND THAT THE OF THE-
IMPACT REMAIN OR IN PROGRESS.
FINALLY URBAN COUNTY APPRECIATE
OF COMMERCE STAMP HEALTH. WITH
THE POOREST OF HERE. HERO IN.
THANK YOU TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR ALL YOU COUPLE HEALTH ISSUES
. WERE ACTUALLY GREAT FOR DR CAN
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL GRATEFUL TO DR PLAN TO
WORK ON THIS. AT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE SIX THREE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
DARLIN HALF BREAK WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES AT THE
STATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT I JUST WANT TO START
OFF BY THANKING DR PAN MARK IS
THE PORT OF THE HERO INITIATIVE
AND WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND PROVIDING THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR STATE AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND TRAINING PROPOSAL
AS A KEY COMPONENT OF CALIFORNIA
SMARTER AND ENSURE THAT WE
MAINTAIN A WORKFORCE PREPARED
RESPONSE THE KOBE NINETEEN AND
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT- ALSO
CONTINUES TO OPPOSE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
FIND THAT FIFTY H. T. P. PROGRAM
ENOUGH CONCERNS ABOUT THE GAPWEB
CARE RICK SERVICE PRODUCTION. IN
ADDITION TO CONCERNS AROUND UP
IN THE NATION OF CRITICAL LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT POSITION. AS
OUR RESULT THE PROPOSAL. BLACK
WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR-
FOR THE NINETEEN OUT REACH AND
AWARE PROPOSED TO SHOW THE TWO
HUNDRED. THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH THE
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
AND STRATEGIC COMMUNICATION WE
UNDERSCORE THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE LA YA REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL FOR ABOUT A LACK OF
COORDINATION AND DUPLICATION. A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT OUR KEY
PARTNERS AND LEADING
COMMUNICATION OUTREACH EFFORT-
THING SURE LOCAL MESSAGING AND
RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED. THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX COURT PLEASE. NINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS HER
AGAIN THE EVENING ON BEHALF OF
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE HHS
RIGHT THE PLANNING PROCESS AND
THE FUNDING FOR- YEAH TO
IMPLEMENT THE NECESSARY
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE NINETY CRISIS
LINE. HOWEVER WITH THE NUMBER
GOING LIVE IN JULY ALL OF THE
REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME IN GAP
FUNDING FOR CALL CENTERS FOR THE
FIRST YEAR NINE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT NINE EIGHT EIGHT FOCUSED
PLANNING AFTER TO COMPLEMENT THE
HHS CRISIS PLANNING PROCESS AND
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A SMALL
PHONE P. TO SUSTAINABLY FARMED
THE NINE EIGHT THIS TO MOVING
FORWARD. WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR HEALTH WORKFORCE
INITIATIVE AND ALSO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE PACKAGE KNOWN AS
FOCUSED B. H. WE HAVE FIVE
SENATORS EGGMAN AND I'M BURKE
AND GOVERNOR AND USE THEM FOR
YOUR TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP ON
KERR CORE AND SUPPORT THE ITEMS
IN THE MAYBE FIVE. FORTY
CONTINUING TO PARTNER WITH YOU
AND THE ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. I'M FORTY NOW PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DIANA
DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH ACT OF
CALIFORNIA REGARDING COVER
CALIFORNIA PORTABILITY
ASSISTANCE WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT FROM THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON THE NEED TO KEEP
COVERAGE AFFORDABLE HEALTH ACT
THAT URGES THE SENATE TO SUPPORT
A COMMITMENT FOR MUCH NEEDED
COST SHARING ASSISTANCE TO
COVERED CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES IF
THE FEDERAL AIR PIECE OF THESE
ARE CONTINUED. IF THE FEDERAL OF
THESE ARE NOT CONTINUE THE THREE
HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION
INCLUDED IN THE REVISED FALL
DRASTICALLY SHORT OF COVERING
THE CURRENT ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION THE FEDERAL INVESTMENT
AND IS IN FACT ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN THE
ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
NEEDED TO EVEN REINSTATE OUR
PREVIOUS STATE OF THE PROGRAM.
WITH COST OF LIVING HIGHER THAN
EVER WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LET OUR
COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE
MARKETPLACE LAST WEEK OR THE
COMMITTEE PROMISED THE WIDE
REAHING EFFECTS OF UNCERTAINTY
ON THE R. P. SUBSIDIES AND
WORKING HARD TO ENCOURAGE THE
STATE TO INVEST AS NEEDED TO
PREVENT ANY INCREASE. WE ALSO
WANT TO KNOW OUR B. STATION FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION OF
EXTENDING HEALTH PROBLEMATIC
HEALTH COVERAGE TO PEOPLE AGE
TWENTY SIX TO FORTY NINE HOWEVER
WE CONTINUE TO SEEK AN EARLIER
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND MEASURES
TO ENSURE NO YOUNG ADULT AGE
OUT. ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO FUND MEDICAL HEALTH
AND ROMAN NAVIGATORS PROJECT TO
HELP MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES AND
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF REFORMING
THE MEDIC HEALTHCARE COSTS
PROGRAM FINALLY WE SUPPORT THAT
MAKE REVISIONS INCLUSION OF
REACH RESOURCES FOR THE
CONTINUED WORK OF THE HEALTH
HELP CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
COMMISSION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HER COMMENTS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND COLOR PLEASE. NINE SIX FOUR.
GO A- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
RIGHT SPEND ON BEHALF THE
AMERICAN CALL OF OBG IS JUST
NINE THE GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL
INCREASE THE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
DOOR SERVICES NEAR THE SAME
LEVEL OF PHYSICIAN REIMBURSEMENT
JUST FOR THE HIGHLIGHTS HELP LOW
REIMBURSEMENT IS FOR OBSTETRIC
MEDICAL SERVICES AND THIS IS NOT
WITHSTANDING THE ABSENCE OF
REVERSING THE EIGHTY NINETY
SEVEN REDUCTIONS FOR ALL
PROVIDER SERVICES. CURRENTLY
SERVICES COVERED BY THE GLOBAL
PROTECTOR CODE IN MEDIC CAL
REIMBURSED AT A RATE JUST OVER
52% OF THE SAME SERVICES COVERED
BY MEDICARE ANY GLOBAL PAYMENT
POLICIES CAN END UP DRIVING
PROVIDERS OUT OF THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM ULTIMATELY ULTIMATELY
LEADING TO A SMALLER POOL OF
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS CARING
FOR LOWER INCOME PATIENTS. IF
WE'RE ONLY LOOKING IMPROVING
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR SOCIAL
SUPPORT SERVICES ABOUT MEDICAL
SERVICES WE CANNOT FULLY ADDRESS
THE CURRENT MATERNAL MORTALITY
MORBIDITY CRISIS HE CALLED AFTER
YOU ALSO CONSIDER PROPOSAL NOT
INCLUDED IN A REVISED AND ALIGN
THE MEDI CAL PUBLIC SECTOR GREAT
WITH THE RATE PROVIDED MEDICARE
SO THAT MEDICAL PROVIDERS CAN BE
JUSTLY COMPENSATED FOR THE
SERVICES YOU PROVIDE CARE FOR
THE MOST FORMAL POPULATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE COLOR PLEASE.
NINE THIRTY PLEASE AHEAD. THE
HILLARY ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
MEDIC ASSISTING FROM JANUARY AND
APRIL SUPPORT FUNDING FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN ON THE NATION OF
PREMIUMS AND MEDIC HOW EQUITY IN
PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION PROVIDER
PAYMENTS AND THE ALLOCATION OF
OPIOID COMMENT ON BERMAN A
REVISION CMA PUT SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ACCESS
INCLUDING UNCOMPENSATED CARE
RETENTION PAYMENTS FOR HOSPITAL
STAFF GENERAL FUND ACT OF FOR
PROFIT DEFECT. MORE OPIOID
BATTLEMENT FUNDING ADDITIONAL
PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION GRANT
FUNDING FUNDING FOR HIV AND
ACTIVITY I LIMITATION OF CERTAIN
A. B. PROVIDER RATE REDUCTIONS
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO INCLUDE
PHYSICIAN AND SPECIALTY PHARMACY
SERVICES IN NOT LESS AND NINETY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS OKAY I'M
CHILDREN MEANS THE SENSE BUT
IT'S JUST NOT FOCUSED ON BLADES
CHILDREN BACK NATION RATE THAT
ARE WELL BELOW PRE PANDEMIC
LEVEL IS NEEDED AT DOC AND
ALLEGEDLY. YOU MAY CONTINUE BOB
HERTZBERG REGARDING THE
COMPONENT OF CALLING
IMPLEMENTATION CHANGING THE
COVERAGE FOR DUAL ELIGIBLE AND
URGES THELEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER AT THE WAY FINALLY CMH
URGES THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE INCLUDING
GME AND THE PLANNING PHASE OF
THE PROJECT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE A SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
FELIX MANAGED MEDIC EIGHT PUBLIC
ORGANIZATION AND SPEAKING OF THE
STATE UPDATED SHARING EQUITY
COALITION. ACTUALLY THE REFI NOT
FOR ARM CRITICAL AND FOR RBC
BANK THE HEALTH AND WITH OF
CALIFORNIANS TO CALAIS OTHER
PRIORITIES WE'RE GLAD YOU DID
MINISTRATION I TAKES STEPS TO
ADDRESS- TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
GRANTS FOR DATA EXCHANGE. THERE
IS NO AMOUNT TO SUPPORT THE
ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR DATA
EXCHANGE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
NETWORK OF H. IONS IN FEBRUARY
OUR COALITION REQUESTED NINETY
FIVE MILLION FOR THIS EFFORT I
WHICH WAS RIGHT ON ANYTHING HAVE
FEDERAL FUNDS. AND WE APPRECIATE
AGAIN TO MEET WITH YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND DR PANDA PLUS OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
DISCUSS THIS TRANSFORMATIVE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THANK YOU IS ROBBIE FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CONNECTING FOR
BETTER- COALITION WE'RE A MULTI
STAKEHOLDER COALITION DEDICATED
TO ADVANCING DATA SHARING
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA- WHILE WE
SUPPORT THAT THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE EACH AYE YOU TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION GRANT. WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT THE FUNDS ALONE DON'T
GO FAR ENOUGH TO REALLY BUILD
OUT THAT THE DATA SHARING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO NOT ONLY COME OUT OF
THE HOPE IT CRISIS BUT ALSO
TENDED TO SUPPORT COUNTY IN
ANOTHER STATE EFFORTS AS WELL
AND- MORE THAN NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO BOTH
FIND. PERFORMANCE PAYMENT AND
HEALTH INFORMATION ORGANIZATION
INFRASTRUCTURE- OUR COALITION IS
SIMPLE DID THAT LAST PART THE
GREATER PART OF THE LAST YEAR
THE MOTHER STATE THAT HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF REALLY GENERATE
FEDERAL MATCH AND HELP FUND THAT
HAD BEEN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA REALLY
IS THE SAME. THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN'T GET. OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM FOR MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE AT THE CENTER LINK OUT
ALL OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THE DEED
YES THE THINKING AND WORKING
WITH THE WBA AND COUNTIES TO
DEVELOP PROPERTIES FOR THE
UPCOMING YEAR THE UNWINDING
WHICH WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
WORKLOAD FOR COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCIES. WELL THERE IS
THAT IF YOU HAVE FUNDING FOR THE
PHD LEFT THE UNDERLYING COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY OPERATIONS ARE NOT
FULLY FUNDED BUT IF I CAN PLAY
FOR THE SPRING OCCURRING
NATIONWIDE. HERE'S A QUESTION
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FORTY SIX MILLION
TOTAL FUN HE ADDED TO THE COUNTY
MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY OPERATE AND
BUDGET SO THE COUNTY FOR THE
MEDICAL BUT THE SIGNIFICANT RISK
TO INCREASE THE REMAIN
COMPETITIVE IN THE EXTREMELY
TIGHT LABOR MARKET WE'RE
OPERATING WITH THAT. WE WILL BE
REACHING OUT YOUR STAFF EXPLAIN
THE REASON FOR THE REQUEST AND
WHY THE REGULAR PROCESS WHICH
THE ADMINISTRATION DID FOLLOW
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE VERY THE COST
BY THE FACT THAT IT'S NOT
UPDATING AS GAINES FOR THE
COMING YEAR THIS IS PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL AT AS WE IMPLEMENT A
MULTITUDE OF NEW CHANGES
IMPACTING THE ELIGIBILITY STATE
BUT AS- THE OLDER ADULT
EXPERIENCING POSTPARTUM EXPENSE
AND- AN INCREASE IN THE ASSET
LIMIT AS WELL AS HEALTH OF MY
GREAT THEN. AND A DISTANCE OF
THE AFOREMENTIONED PHD LESS WORK
BUT BY MANY I ALSO KNOWS THE CPB
A WITH A COMMENT YEAH AND NONE
OF THEIR OPPOSITION TO ELIMINATE
THE CCP WITH MENTALLY WITH CREAM
OCCURRENCE NEGATIVELY AFFECT
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN INCLUDING CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE I THINK THERE'S
ALWAYS THE OPPORTUNITY ON THE
AND FOR THE HARD WORK OF ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF HERE THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I KNOW. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NINETY NINE OPEN- THIS
IS JENNIFER AND CAN YOU HEAR ME
GO AHEAD PLEASE. OKAY HI THIS IS
JENNIFER FIELD- AND I AM AN
ADULT WHO LEFT BECAUSE OF THESE-
AND IN RESPONSE THE SICKLE CELL
DISEASE TREATMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
MAY REVIVED WHICH INCLUDES THE
GENERAL FUND- I THIRTY FIVE
MILLION- TO SUPPORT IT AND THAT
IT WAS OUT OF THE TREATMENT AND
THE STRUCTURE- I THOUGHT THE
SUPPORT INCREASING A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION FROM FIVE MILLION
TO THIRTY MILLION TO COMPLETE
BUILDING A NETWORK. PRINT OUT
SOME OF THESE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. NINE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. JEREMY ANYTHING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES THAT ONE ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE PREVIOUS COMMENT
ABOUT URBAN COUNTIES ON THE CARE
COURTS PROPOSAL WE APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL COMMENTARY AN
EXPLORATION OF THE PROPOSAL IN
THE COMMITTEE- WE DO KNOW
EVERYBODY'S WORKING ON WITH THE
PHONE POLICY QUESTIONS RELATED
TO IMPLEMENTING CARE KERR. WE DO
SUGGEST- A RAMP UP PROFITS FOR
ENSURING THAT THE FAT CARE
FOURTH AND WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION IN
THE MAY REVIVE OF THE KNOWLEDGE
OF THE COMPANIES WILL REQUIRE
FUNDING TO GET STARTED AND TWO
THIRDS OF THESE FOLKS ARE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATION. LASTLY WE WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE CAMPUS IS COMMON
AND- THANK YOU SHARE EGGMAN FOR
YOUR DEDICATION TO THIS ISSUE
WITH A FOUR TO WORKING WITH YOU
AS THE PROSTITUTES FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY NAME EIGHT
PLEASE AHEAD. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR TELEMATICS
EGGMAN IN THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR GREAT WORK ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US TO CREATING
AT TO PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS MANDATE FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OF THE EQUITY
WERETO DOING AND ALSO THE
GOVERNOR'S JAMES MY NAME'S LAURA
O'CONNOR I'M HONORED TO SERVE ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA.
WHICH AS YOU KNOW HOSTED THE
ENTRIES THE LEAST POLICY
INSTITUTE WE TRAIN WOMEN AND ALL
OF THEM IDENTIFIED LEADERS
ANNUALLY- AND I ALSO SERVE ON
THE ADVISORY COUNCIL FOR
FRIENDSHIP HOUSE IN THE WOMEN'S
LOGIC BUNCH OF HOUSE AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR FRIENDSHIP. HOUSE
WHICH- WE WANT TO REALLY- HIS
MAKE WE REALLY WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THAT'S A VERY UNIQUE
PROPOSAL AND THAT THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DONE THAT YOU ALL
HAVE BEEN DOING AROUND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE SETTINGS ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND ACROSS THE SENATE
THAT THIS INVESTMENT WOULD
REALLY COMPLEMENT THOSE EFFORTS
SO WE ARE REALLY HOPING THAT YOU
WILL STRONGLY CONSIDER AND
APPROVE WHICH THE NATIVE
CAUCUSES ALSO CONSIDERING AT THE
ASSEMBLY WITH THAT NAY ACOSTA
SAID ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS WAS
VERY. STRONGLY SUPPORTED EARLIER
THIS WEEK WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH BUT WITH THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND OTHER MEMBERS
ACROSS THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
SUMMER HOPING THAT YOU WILL
REALLY APPROVED DEATH AND ALSO
AS WELL THE FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
THE AMAZING YOUR YUROK TRIBAL
WORK AND NOT ON THIS PARTICULAR
GENDER BUT I WANTED TO FIND OUT
THERE'S ALSO IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA A PROPOSAL THAT WAS
SUBMITTED WHICH WILL CIRCULATE-
BY THE ON HER BACK AS THE
MANAGER AN INDIGENOUS CENTER OF
RESURGENT I WANT THEM OR NOT TO
TAKE YOUR TIME ON THIS CALL BUT
IT WILL BE RECIRCULATED THAT IS
TO CREATE A- INDIGENOUS
RESURGENCE LANGUAGE AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTE IN LOS ANGELES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL SUPPORT FRIENDSHIP
HEALTH PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE OH
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER
GRATEFUL FROM THE OF A HELL
STATEWIDE I MEAN IF THEY
COALITION JUST ONE INTO
REITERATE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC
HEALTH HOWEVER WE CONTINUE TO
MAKE TE CASE THAT ADDITIONAL
TARGETED PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING
IF NEEDED. TO SUPPORT LIFESAVING
HARM REDUCTION PROGRAMS ADDRESS
AYE ROCKETING RATES OF SYPHILIS
AND CONGENITAL SYPHILIS AND
EXPAND PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES
FOR HIV AND HEPATITIS. IN
PARTICULAR JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT FUNDING FOR THE STATE'S
HARM REDUCTION PROGRAMS WILL
EXPIRE NEXT YEAR SO IT'S
IMPERATIVE FUNDING IS INCLUDED
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS NO GAP SERVICES
FOR THESE LFESAVING PROGRAMS WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THE SIX PROPOSALS FROM THE MBF
DEMICHELIS SAM. AS WELL AS THE
PROPOSAL FROM AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION TECH BAND OPT OUT
SCREENING HOSPITAL ER'S THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE HI
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN COMMITTEE THIRTY CAT ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONAL
CARE COURT WHICH INCLUDES NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES AND OBLIGATIONS
IMPOSED ON COUNTY THAT WILL NEED
TO BE COUPLED WITH ADEQUATE AND
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF CARE PROPOSAL WE
BELIEVE THE PATH TO SUCCESS
SHOULD BE GROUNDED IN THOUGHTFUL
TRANSPARENT AND INCREMENTAL
PHASED IN MODEL THE RAMP UP
APPROACH ALLOWED THE DIGITAL
TIME FOR THE- LATER COHORTS
ACCOUNTED IN COURT TO PREPARE
AND FURTHER REFINE THE LONG TERM
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT AND AFFORD
STAKEHOLDERS AT ALL LEVELS
GOVERNMENT OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
THEIRIMPLEMENTATION HURDLES AND
DEVELOP A ROBUST AND SUCCESSFUL
pAPPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION ON
THE GOVERNOR SMARTER PLANTS
SENATOR PAN COMMENTS ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE. BUT
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT HERE
UNDERSTAND WHICH WOULD ADD AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX MILLION
ONE TIME INVESTMENT RESERVE AND
BOLSTER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE COLOR PLEASE. LINE
ONE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
WITH THAT APRIL ELLIOTT LEWIS
FROM SAN FRANCISCO- CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE KALPOE- EXTENSION
WHICH WILL- COVER FINDING THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE A SHORTFALL
BOARD BE OUT. CALIFORNIA HERE
RUN ONE LINE THIS IS AN
EMOTIONAL TELEPHONE SUPPORT
BOTTOM LINE RUN BY PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS THAT OF
OTHERS- IN A ROUND THE CLOCK
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A THREE ACCEPTABLE HOPE
FRIEDMAN A LINE IT HAS HELPED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. FEEL WOULD BE
QUITE DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES IT'S A
GREAT SERVICE THAT THAT REALLY
NEEDS YOUR SUPPORT AND I HOPE
YOU WILL SUPPORT THE R. X. CAL
EXTENSION OTHERWISE FUNDS WILL
EXPIRE AND THEY WILL GET THE
FUNDING THEY NEED. AGAIN DAVID
ELLIOTT LEWIS AFTER DISPELLED
LIFELONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NICE COLOR PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
UNBEARABLY WELL I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY AND I PUT THE
CONTINUE FUNDING OF THE CAL
HOPELINE- RECOMMENDED BY THE
MENTAL HEALTH ASSOCIATION OF SAN
FRANCISCO UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE ONE
LINE AT THE HELP LINE PROVIDES A
SAFE FROM JUDGMENTAL IT EASILY
ACCESSIBLE SERVICE FOR ANYONE
WHO NEEDS. NONPARTISAN MOTIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT ESPECIALLY
WITH THE GAPS IN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM REVEALED IN THE LIGHT OF
THE PANDEMIC THAT'S WHY THIS
RESOURCE IS SO IMPORTANT.
OFTENTIMES MANY CALLERS ARE
COMPLETELY DISTRAUGHT UNABLE TO
SLEEP- IF ANYTHING CHALLENGES IN
VARIOUS DOMAINS IN THEIR LIFE
AND ARE COMPLETELY ISOLATED IN
THIS LINE PROVIDE A LIFELINE FOR
THEM OFTENTIMES AT A VERY AT THE
COMPLETELY. FREE OF CHARGE
COMPLETELY FREE OF CHARGE AT NO
COST TO THEM- TROUBLING COURAGE
NOTHING IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND URGING THE
SENATE TO MEDIATE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ADD THE RECOMMENDED FUNDING
OF THE CALIFORNIA. PAIR OF THE-
HOPELINE ORGANIZED MANAGED THE
MISSILE THIS IS A OF SAN PRINTER
. BUDGET THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COURT. NINE ONE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ADRIAN'S OPEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE F CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF A NUMBER OF ITEMS
TODAY FIRST OF TWENTY NINE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE BUDGET ON THE F. B. TWO TWO
ONE IMPLEMENTATION TO ENSURE
THAT TIMELY FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
HAPPEN IDENTITY SEVENTY H. THE
F. BUDGET REGARDING THE SUICIDE
PREVENTIONVOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FUND- WE BELIEVE
THIS IS IN LINE WITH THAT NINE
EIGHT EIGHT DESPITE PREVENTION
LIFELINE IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION'S
REQUEST TO MODIFY SB EIGHTY Q.
ABOUT THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
ACTIVE TWENTY THIRTEEN. THREE
TRAILER BILL TO BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE FIELD AND FINALLY
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FAVORITISM TO
ADDRESS THE CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS YOUR AVERAGE TO
ADDRESS THE ADDRESS IS TO ASIDE
AND COULD NOT WELL THAT'S FOR
YOU BUT I THINK THE ONLY THING
INCREASES AND OF NEED IN THE
FIELD. OF OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SERVING FORTY
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN OUR
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND
ONE OF. PLEASE GO. YEAH NEWMAN
FINISH VOTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIFTY OF COUNTIES IT
FOR BY COM ON A FOR FOUR ZERO IN
REGARDS TO THE AYE P. WEIGHTLESS
SOLUTION PROPOSAL WE EXPRESS OUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT WHICH IS
INCREASING THE MAY REVISE THE
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE EARLY
ACCESS TO TREATMENT. IMPROVE
STATE AND LOCAL COLLABORATION
AND INCREASE COMMUNITY CAPACITY
TO ADDRESS THE FELONY I WAIT.
ADDITIONALLY WE ACKNOWLEDGE
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDED IN THE
MAIN REVISED TO IMPROVE
DISCHARGE PLANNING AND
RESEARCHING THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AS WELL AS THE
FOCUS ON IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE YOU DETERMINATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND IRON OUT
THE DETAILS OF THESE PROVISIONS.
WELL WE APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
ATHLETES MAY REVISION AS IT
RELATES TO THE GROWTH CAP ON THE
TOTAL NUMBER AYE THE REFERRAL
AND THE POTENTIAL FOR COUNTY
COST SHARING WITH THE CAP IS
EXCEEDED REMAIN FUNDAMENTALLY
OPPOSED TO JUSTIN CANNOT FOCUS
ON UPSTREAM EFFORTS. TO REDUCE
THE I. P. POPULATION. ALTHOUGH
WE RECOGNIZE. THAT THE FUNDING
FOR. ANYTHING ALL THE WOULD BE
A- BACK TO COUNTY. WHAT MAINLY
THIS NO WAY. THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
. INVEST AT THE LOCAL. TO
ADDRESS THE GROW NEEDS OF
INCREASING I THREE POPULATION
AND THOSE SUFFERING FROM SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS. FINALLY THE
SECTOR PRESHEAF DEMONSTRATION
ONGOING INVESTMENT. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE HOSPITAL.
AND THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX COLOR
PLEASE. I AM TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND-
ESPECIALLY TO THE CHAIR DR PAN
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF I'M
DIANE NUGENT FROM THE CENTER OF
INHERITED BLOOD DISORDERS THE
COMMUNITY BASED SAFETY NET
CLINIC IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND I'M
THE CO FOUNDER ALONG WITH MERRY
BROWN FROM THE SICKLE CELL
DISEASE FOUNDATION OF THE NEWLY
FORMED NETWORKING CALIFORNIA
SICKLE CELL CARE I'M HERE TO
THANK THE STATE THANKS COMMITTEE
FOR THE INITIAL FUNDING TO BEGIN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR FIVE CLINICS
. A. B. C. AND TRACKING
CALIFORNIA DEMONSTRATED THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE 30% MORE ADULTS
WITH SICKLE CELL THAN ORIGINALLY
THOUGHT SO IN THE LAST TWO AND A
HALF YEARS WE HAVE INITIATED. AT
TEN CLINICS FOR ADULTS- WITH THE
CO FELL IN AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THE VERY SHORT LIFESPAN OF
SICKLE CELL PATIENTS IN OUR
STATE. WE HAVE SOME WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND WE CAN NOW BRING
IN ON OUR LAST FEW CLINIC. WE
ACTED IN THE MAY REVISED- THE
FUNDING BE INCREASED TO THIRTY
MILLION IN ORDER FOR US TO
COMPLETE THIS. PROJECT WHICH IS
ALREADY DEMONSTRATING A SHORTER
LENGTH OF STAY DECREASED
HOSPITALIZATION AND DECREASE E.
R. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IMPROVE
QUALITY OF LIFE. THANKS AGAIN
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND FOR THE
STATE FOR THEIR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CAITLYN
JOHN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LINE FOURTEEN GIRLS CLUB THE LAN
PORTS INCLUDING THE ONE TIME%
FUNDING IN THE MAYBE BASINGER
DRESSED URGENT CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS TYPICALLY
THE FORTY MILLION PROPOSED FOR
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH SUICIDE
MENTION AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
TO SUPPORT GRANT FOR WELLNESS
AND MINDFULNESS PROGRAMS IN
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES. ALIKE
PREDICT THE FUNDING A LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ESTABLISHED THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE WITH FUNDING
NOT EXPECTED TO BE AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDERS YOUR LEAST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO HELP
OUR YOUTH WHO ARE EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS NOW AND
NEED IMMEDIATE SUPPORT. LINE BUT
ALSO ENCOURAGED AT LEAST A
PORTION OF THIS MONEY GO
DIRECTLY UP COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OFTENTIMES THE
COMMUNITY THE SURFING COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE AMONG
THE FIRST STEP UP TO PROVIDE
HELP AND SERVICES THE RESIDENTS
IN THE DEBATE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
THE TRUST RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY
CAN RELY ON TO HELP ADDRESS
MENTAL HEALTH. AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL IMPACT OF PANDEMIC ON
OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH FOR
EXAMPLE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB
HEADED BY THE VARIETY OF DO THAT
SACRAMENTO RESOURCES TO THE
YOUTH THEY SERVE INCLUDING FREE
VIRTUAL THERAPY FOR YOUTH AND
FAMILIES SPEAKING IF YOU MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES CRISIS SUPPORT
AND TRAINING TEAM THE TEAM
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID TO
INCREASE AWARENESS AN ABILITY
FOR THE PAST YEARS IT WAS SIDE.
LINED URGES APPROVAL OF THE
FUNDING AND ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THE
FUNDING GOES OUT QUICKLY HI
CAPACITY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN ORDER TO MEET
THE URGENCY OF THE SITUATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX CODE PLEASE. WHEN A FOUR
PLEASE AHEAD. IT WOULD BE QUITE
ON BEHALF OF THE TERM AND CHILD
HEALTH BACK TO. WE SIX TO KEEP
MET COMPREHEND TERRY SIR PROGRAM
BENEFIT THROUGHOUT THE NEW
TWELVE MONTH POST PARTUM PERIOD
INSTEAD OF JUST THE INITIAL
SIXTY DAYS THIS WOULD ALIGN WITH
AB NINETEEN THIRTY AND IS
NECESSARY FOR BREAST FEEDING
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THAT FIRST
YEAR WARM HANDOFFS TO EARLY
INTERVENTION MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND TO PROVIDE OTHER
NONCLINICAL SERVICES TO HELP. TO
HELP ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
AND RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
MATERNAL AND NEWBORN HEALTH- WE
ARE ALSO VERY HAPPY TO SEE
SUPPORT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED MAY REVISE FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATORS AND
FUTURE ACCESS LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING
AMOUNT FOR THE NAVIGATORS AND TO
ESTABLISH THE MOST EFFECTIVE
CRITERIA AND PARAMETERS. FOR
THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. VERY MUCH DOES COLOR
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOTHING IN MY AND HER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION CVA SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ACA'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
LAST PROCESS CROWN BENEFIT AS
THIS HAS BEEN A LONGSTANDING GAP
IN MEDICAL DENTAL COVERAGE
HOWEVER CBO NOTES WITH CONCERN
THAT THE PROPOSED RATE IS WELL
BELOW OTHER PARENTS OR SAYS AND
WILL LEAD TO INSUFFICIENT ACCESS
FOR BENEFICIARIES. IT BENEFIT
EXPANSION IS APPROVED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET CDAC CAN INCREASE
IN THE SCHEDULE MAXIMUM.
ALLOWANCE WHICH WOULD ROUGHLY
EQUATE. AN ADDITIONAL THIRD
MILLION. YES THE PROPOSAL VIDEO
THREE FIFTY THAT'S THIRTY ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DEFICIT AND
DENTAL TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVE
BEING BACKFILLED THIS MEANS THAT
THE DENTIST TO PROVIDE SERVICES
UNDER DTR DOMAIN THREE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHAT THE FULL
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS FOR SERVICES
ALREADY RENDERED THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT IN PRESERVING
THE TRUST BETWEEN PROVIDERS AND
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM THE DEAL
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE USE OF
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT PROP
FIFTY SIX SACRAMENTO PROVIDER
PAYMENTS. AND TO SUPPORT THE
PHYSICIAN IDENTIIED LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM THERE HAS BEEN
A 25% INCREASE IN DENTAL
PROVIDERS ENROLLED IN MEDI CAL
FIVE FIFTY SIX TRIPS AFFECT YOU
THE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO
MAINTAIN THE FUNDING LEVEL TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED STABILITY
FOR THE PROGRAM WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE COMING
WEEKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE AHEAD. SO YEAH
MADAM CHAIR MARKET FUTURE
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE COMPANY'S
FAVORITE VISION PROPOSAL OF ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS INTERNAL
FUNDS. THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
FIRST WHEN IT WILL GREATLY
AFFECT THE COUNTY SEPARATE FROM
THE CORNER FUNDING CAPITOLINA
VISIONS AND WILL SUPPORT THE
COUNTY'S BROUGHT INNOVATIVE
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
PROGRAMS. I THINK WITH BY
BURNING THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
OFTEN DOES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AWAY FROM JAIL AND INTO
TREATMENT. AND ULTIMATELY
PREVENTING INDIVIDUALS FROM
ENTERING THE POTENTIAL PIPELINE
INTO THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM.
ACTUALLY URGES THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE THIS FUNDING AND POURED
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL. BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENOUGH
LET'S ON FOR MINUTE. WE HAVE
SOMEBODY BACK IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WANTS TO MAKE SOME
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND WHILE
THEY'RE COMING TO THE MIKE HOW
MANY- HOW MANY. COLORS DO WE
HAVE LEFT IN THE QUEUE. FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY PLEASE. HI MY NAME'S MICHELLE AND THIS
IS WHAT MY DAUGHTER MARIE AND-
I'M CHAIR OF LET CALIFORNIA KIDS
HERE- I WANTED TO THANK YOU AND
SENATOR PAM FOR AND CHAMPIONING
OUR EFFORTS TO LETTER CHILDREN
HERE AND CONNECT TO THEIR WORLD-
WE WERE INCREDIBLY DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S MAY
REVISE EXCLUDED CHILDREN WITH
PARTIAL COVERAGE OF HIGH
DEDUCTIBLES. ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED CHILDREN ARE IN NEED OF
HEARING AIDS AND STILL BEING
LEFT OUT OF THE PROGRAM. OUR
FAMILIES ARE DIRECTLY STRUGGLING
WITH THE COST OF HEALTH CARE AND
IF YOU NEEDING REALLY FOR YEARS.
IT'S DISAPPOINTING THAT THE
GOVERNOR CHAMPIONS ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY RELIEF FOR SO
MANY- BUT LEAVES CHILDREN WHO
NEED HEARING AIDS AND SILENCE-
THEY HELP CHILDREN CONNECT. HERE
AND CONNECT WITH OUR WORLD AND
WE HOPE THAT- THIS IS INCLUDED
IN THE FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS. YES ALL
CHILDREN SHOULD HERE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY OPERATOR BIRDS GO
BACK TO THE PHONE LINE. ALL
RIGHT I KNOW ONE OH SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN DR PAN EIGHTY ONE BURKE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
CCHA APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUE COMMITMENTS EXPANDING
THE CARICOM OF THE WORKFORCE
WITH A ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT. CCHA ALSO
PLUG THAT IN AND NAY SOME
HEIGHTENED FOCUS ON THE USE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS WE ARE
EXPERIENCING WITH A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND CRISIS
RESPONSE PROGRAMS ON A VARIETY
OF HEALTH AND WELLNESS PROGRAMS. FOR CHILDREN YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES. EPHA CAN ARE JUST FOR
VERSION OF TO BUDGET REQUEST NOT
THE NAY REVISION. ONE INCREASE
IN BETTER HEALTH HE FOR SURE
RIGHT HOSPITAL. IS RIGHT FOR THE
PRESENT OVER A- R. EIGHT
NONPROFIT PRIVATE FREESTANDING
HOSPITALS ARE STAKING HOSPITALS
ARE 62% LET CAL AND CARE FOR
SOME OF THE SICKEST CHILDREN IN
THE STATE. ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND MORE THAN 45% AND A RETURN
REPORT SHOWS THAT OVER 50% OF
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE ARE
OPERATING IN THE RED. MEDICARE
FEE FOR SERVICE RIGHT NEEDS TO
BE INCREASED WITH OUR HOSPITAL
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CARE TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THESE
RATE INCREASES ARE CRITICAL IT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED NOW. OUR
SECOND REQUESTED THAT YOUR
MARKETING MILLION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION BUDGET FOR WORK
FOR FUNDING FOR CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL. BUILDING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROPOSAL AND THEY REVISED
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THE STATE
INVESTMENT PEDIATRIC WORK WORK
FORCE. AND THE INVESTMENTS
INCLUDE PEDIATRIC SPECIALISTS AS
WELL AS CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND PSYCHIATRISTS.
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION HAVE A
SEVERE SHORTAGE OF CHILD
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND PSYCHIATRISTS
AND INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED NOW
CAN SURE THAT CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN CRISIS CAN RECEIVE CARE IN A
TIMELY MANNER. THEY'RE ONLY
THIRTEEN PRACTICING BOARD
CERTIFIED IN ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRISTS FOR EVERY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN. WHILE
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
ESTIMATES. THE NEED OF THREE
TIMES THAT NUMBER. CHILDREN ARE
HAVING WAIT WEEKS OR EVEN. TO
RECEIVE CARE. CARE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO BE BETTER AND MAKE
CRITICAL AND- NOW. ALSO WITHOUT
THE EARMARKED FUNDING FOR
WORKFORCE FOR CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL. THE SEVENTEEN
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA EIGHT OF WHICH ARE
PROVIDED IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE FEEDBACK HOSPITALS WILL
RECEIVE VERY LITTLE FUNDING FOR
THEIR TRAINING PROGRAM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
GETTING CORDON REQUEST. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE OH NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF VERTEX PHARMACEUTICALS WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THE DIFFICULT OF EACH
TREATMENT INFRASTRUCTURE ABOUT
MANY GO TOWARDS CONNECTING
PATIENTS EARLY AND OFTEN WITH
SPECIALIZED CLINIC WHICH REDUCES
THE NEED AND COST OF EMERGENCY
CARE HOWEVER WE DO BELIEVE THAT
CREAKING- TO ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATION WOULD
MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
NEED- OF THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIM TALIBAN
AND I AM AN ADVOCATE
REPRESENTING THAT STATIC LEGAL
SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES I WORK
WITH OLDER AND DISABLED AT ALL.
WE SUPPORT REFORMING THE
MEDICARE SHARED COST PROGRAMS TO
RAISE THE MAINTENANCE NEED
INCOME LEVEL TO A HUNDRED AND
38% OF FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES SHOULD NOT BE
FORCED TO LIVE ON SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS  MONTH IN INCOME. IN
ORDER TO ACCESS THEIR MEDICAL
CARE. I NEVER WANT TO TELL
ANOTHER OLDER ADULTS THAT
MEDICARE RULES STATE THEY ONLY
NEED SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
TO PAY ALL THEIR BILLS. AND
ANYTHING OVER THAT MUST BE USED
TO PAY FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE AS
THEIR SHARE OF COST. THIS SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR A MONTH
MAINTENANCE NEED LEFT FILE HAS
NOT BEEN RAISED NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. DISABLED AND OLDER ADULTS
SHOULD NOT BE FORCED TO LIVE
BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL ACCESS
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE
INCREASE IN THE MEDICAL
MAINTENANCE NEW LEVEL SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED INCLUDED IN THE
FINAL STATE BUDGET. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON OF THAT
GROUP NUMBER MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO ADULT THE GOAL FROM
PROGRAM. OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT ONE
OF THE FIRST BECOME PART OF THE
NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA AT THE
KOKOMO CARE INITIATED. AN
INABILITY- RELATIVELY SHOCKING
TO FIND WE'VE SEEN A HUGE IMPACT
IN THE QUALITY OF CARE FOR
ADULTS LIVING WITH SICKLE CELL
DISEASE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND THE
ECHO. WITH THE PROCESS FOR
INCLUDING CHARACTER THE
OUTPATIENT SETTING AND- ALL WHO
DECREASING HEALTHCARE
UTILIZATION IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM AND INPATIENT SETTINGS OUR
PROGRAM HAS- GREATLY HELP
ADDRESS HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
IMPROVE HEALTH EQUITY IN OUR
REGION- WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK- APART
FROM THE STATE AND- WE-
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER APPROVING OUR FULL
BUDGET OF- THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE NETWORK. I
REQUEST YOU TO CONTINUE. TO
BUILD OUR ALL PROGRAMS. THE YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS FOR PLEASE. I
AM SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PETER
MURPHY- WITH THE- MENTAL HEALTH
ASSOCIATION OF SAN FRANCISCO
CALL YOU TODAY- TO APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR- INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
TENSION IN THE NAY REVISION- BUT
I WANT TO BRING ATTENTION TO
THE- THE CALIFORNIA SURE RUN
WARM LINE. WHICH IS ADMINISTERED
BY OUR AGENCY- THE BALLOT
SITUATION OBJECTIVES WHICH GOT
MORE MONEY IT'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN
ARE ARE AT STAKE FUNDING WE
NINETEEN THAT MONEY TO THE RUN
OUT AT THE END OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR AND AT THE END OF. JUNE
WE'RE WE'RE ASKING FOR A- OF THE
FUNDING AN EXTENSION OF THE
FUNDING. OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD
OFF WITH FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS- A ONE TIME ALLOCATION
WHICH WOULD BE. DISPERSED OVER
FIVE YEARS AND WILL ALLOW YOU.
TO CONTINUE THE SERVICES AND
EXPAND THEM- BY CREATING
COSTNER'S DRAFTED A CALIFORNIA
ONE NINETEEN STATEWIDE- AND IT'S
A PREVENTATIVE RESOURCE- STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT ONE DOLLAR OF
PREVENTIVE CARE FROM THE- FIVE
TO SIX DOLLARS- THAT DATING AND-
THE WARM WIND SPEEDS- THIS IS A
IS A- A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THAT.
AND PUBLISHED A DISCUSSION TODAY
ABOUT NINE EIGHTY EIGHT ONE LINE
WOULD BE A COMPLIMENT TO NINETY
EIGHT IT'S- HERE RYAN IT WOULD
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR COOKBOOKS
THAT- BEFORE THEY GET INTO
CRISIS AND HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THAT AND VITAL ROLE- THE STATE'S
NON JUDGMENTAL AND LEGALLY
ACCEPTABLE SERVICE FOR ANYONE
WHO NEEDS CRISIS. A GOOD DID NOT
A CRISIS- SUPPORT AND I FEEL
LIKE THAT THE- IT WAS VERY- THE
TIGHTENING OF THE WARM WHY-
BECOMING A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
SERVICE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
OVER. THE PANDEMIC IS DEFINING
ITS WORST AND- REALLY HE. IN THE
SENSE THAT WE'VE BEEN THERE FOR-
FOR I FELT- THERE'S BEEN LOOKING
FOR MORE SUPPORT DURING THE- WE
RECEIVED A- HUNDRED AND EIGHTY.
BECAUSE AND CHATS. BETWEEN THE-
WHY AND ARE HEALTH WE HEARING
ONE. THANK THE- THE FED THEM
STARTED IN MARCH. OKAY HONEY-
REPUBLICAN MENTAL THANK YOU
NEEDS TO BE REVOKED THAT IS THE
BATTLE HOW. AND REFUNDING THE
PIRENNE WARM WOULD GET ME WAY DO
THAT NIGHT. I REALLY- I THE
STOCK. TO SPEAK THE- WITH-
MANAGE YOUR FIRST- CENTER EGGMAN
AND CENTER AND I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE INVESTMENT. IN THE
CONTINUE OF CAREFUL ALL
CALIFORNIANS VERSUS SUBCOMMITTEE
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- ABBY RECOMMENDED
FUNDING FOR NOT ONLY THE CALVO
FLYING BUT THE CALIFORNIA BUREAU
MORE MY FOR THIS YEAR'S STATE
BUDGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK. YOU VERY MUCH OKAY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND ONE THIRD. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
UNDER AND GALLON THE HAVE A PLAN
PARENTHOOD OF CALIFORNIA WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE WORK DONE
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
COMMITTEE AND EACH CARD ON YOU
SHOULD TWENTY WHICH WILL PROVIDE
FORTY MILLION OVER SIX YEARS FOR
CLINICAL AND CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH PROVIDERS I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS WHICH- PART OF THE FOUR
NEW ITEM PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION LISTED UNDER
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN
TODAY'S NEEDS ME REVISED-
OVERVIEW. THESE ARE CRITICAL I
AND- HOWEVER THE REDUCTION OF
ABORTION ACCESS THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY IS A LOOMING CRISIS AND
MORE ACTION IS NEEDED TO MEET
THE MOMENT WE ARE ADDITIONAL
INCLUSION OF FUNDING I PER ITEM
PROPOSED. AND THE FUTURE OF
ABORTION COUNSEL THE CYCLE WHICH
HAD NOT YET APPEARED TO ME
REVISED SPECIFICALLY THE
PRACTICAL SYSTEM PATIENT FUNDING
AND EQUITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PAYMENT AND MEDIKAL AND THE
PILOT PROGRAM WITHIN THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR HERE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE MINISTRATIONS MAIN REVISION
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ON EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN
PROVIDER RATE REDUCTIONS AS IT
UP FIVE FEW CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORS AS WELL AS THEIR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORING AB
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY
CHANGES HOWEVER WE VIEW URGES
THE ADMINISTRATION HE'LL EXTEND
COVERAGE OTHER CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS. TO PEOPLE WITH
TYPE TWO DIABETES DIABETES IF
THEY WANT TO ACHIEVE REAL
SAVINGS FOR THE MEDICARE PROGRAM%
IN THE TREATMENT OF DIABETES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THAT
BRINGS AN END TO OUR- UBLIC
COMMENTS TODAY AGAIN WE THANK
THE DEPARTMENTS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE L. A. O. AND OF
COURSE ALL OF OUR STAFF HERE IN
THE IN THE BUILDING. FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BUDGET HEARING AND
WITH THAT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.